foreign
[Music]
thank you
love me for
one eight two four
foreign
[Music]
one oh seven three seven four one eight
two four
one eight two four
one
oh seven three seven
[Music]
goodbye
thank you
[Music]
all right how's it going everyone good
morning
we are back at it again well I'm back at
it again
Tim just went to bed like an hour ago
and Peter has been
uh
Pete has been live in his
Swedish time
doing stuff
um
so I had a little bit of a catch-up call
with Peter as I was driving to the
office
um so I know a few things but we're
gonna probably call Peter
and have like a proper call now
um let's just try and call him and see
what happens I guess
hey
all right you in the office
uh what are you saying
you're in the office yeah I'm live
oh uh hang on a second I'm just gonna go
grab a cup of coffee
nice all right
I feel like Peter's paying me back
because that's what I said to him and
hung up like about 20 minutes ago
mm-hmm
um all right stream well I guess we'll
hang out
no I'm back are you back already damn
that was quick I was gonna say you were
like punishing me for
getting a coffee earlier I need some
coffee already oh nice good
someone said Maddie says ask Peter about
the get animation count method lameo
oh
a bone to pick with you or zero X
probably zero X
uh well it was blamed to you really oh
yeah no this was bad what was this mesh
swords get animation count and let me uh
bring this up oh I'm gonna I can
actually share my screen
you do that
yeah
no
Source get animation count
look at this yeah so I'm trying this
import again animation count yeah
this is gonna load the same mesh every
single time you call this which the
animation controller editor does for
every single animation asset every frame
so if you have eight animations you're
gonna be loading this eight times per
frame but Peter tell them why because it
only gets called for one reason yeah
and what's that uh to find out the index
of animations like how many animations
yeah yeah
um now
but I guess it should be it should be
that code if it hasn't been loaded yet
yeah exactly that was my thinking as
well because I'm pretty sure I I do
vaguely remember this and this would
have been for asset packing
yeah but also like I get I get that it
seems like this would be slow but it
definitely it was horrible well maybe
maybe for this game but in like
dichotomy like it doesn't obviously show
up on profiles or anything
like young unusable I mean
it was 20
Americans per call
per call
recall so what does dichotomy just not
call this function then
uh maybe wait is this a character is
this for is this maybe it's a character
controller thing animation controller no
yeah but what yeah what I mean any
skeletal animation
only when you open the animation
controller editor
so like animation
contribute what do you mean the
animation controller wait so what do you
mean yeah
oh so just just when you open the editor
just when you open it oh so it's not for
it's not for run time then yeah no and
he
and oh oh well then who cares that's not
a big deal
I mean it kind of works because it was
unusable it's a big deal if it's in
runtime code that we ship like like
literally six volume
basically make it a bit Yeah but that's
fine it's for the editor that's fine fix
it and move on if it wasn't shipped code
that would be different but like
seriously like it's pretty bad and
what's the what's the animation editor
like
when you have a bunch of states
oh I see I've never even seen that
before yeah so it's in animation
controller editor how do you get to
there like as in how do you um you
double click on another animation
control is that new-ish
no as long as animations
all right okay yep no I think I run
another one I was thinking of zero X's
animation State graph but yeah
yeah I know and it's specifically in
this asset referenced with no it's not
it's in
animation index okay property yeah we
call that yeah I figured I'd let you
know about that
um
I fixed it for Tim by just
doing this for now because um
animations.size was in fact populated
when I checked yeah just so Tim could
actually use it
um what I want to know though is like
the thing is if
like it does it potentially needs to
load the asset I think if it doesn't
exist
yeah like like if this is not is there a
way for us to check if it's been loaded
and then if so then import it so that we
can get the animation count
or alternatively alternatively there
could be a different function because
the thing is the reason why this is a
thing is it's because it's because I
guess maybe the serializer needs to know
how many animations there are before it
actually you know reads any details from
it and that's why it was trying to do
that
yeah but also why the heck does that
take 20 milliseconds to read the
animation count
because it doesn't mean it loads the
entire file like the disk every time the
entire mesh no but we go to desk for
like the engine probably reads 100 files
per frame from disk it's not the reading
the disk that's slow it's but if what it
is it's probably megabytes but you don't
need to read the whole file
it's just this probably is because this
is asimp
yeah so it's it's awesome yeah
right
so
um commented that out for now
um leave it to you or Xerox to fix yep
yeah okay I'll probably have to tackle
this one
this building asset the building asset
Packs work I mean I built it okay to
work okay
well then maybe it's not a problem I
don't know I just remembered yeah I feel
like I remember this being a thing
because we didn't we wanted to know how
many animations we had but we didn't
actually have the file loaded
and that may have been why
okay cool all right I'll take a look at
that
do you want to see the game currently
uh yes show us the game
so first of all
um
yeah you're gonna have to deal with this
tent business because we're according to
Tim we we are planning on like
generating the tent procedurally like
where you pick up your gun and the call
yeah okay
um the position the location of it yeah
yeah that's fine I'll just flatten
flatten tiles there yeah
like
modify the terrain generation to so that
yeah yeah yep that's fine
um okay I'm I'm actually going to
generate actually I think I can get to
those
here it's kind of fun when it's like
this Tim fixed the root uh root motion
based uh animations so that yep we have
this kind of behavior oh good yes and
the controls are now identical between
controller and keyboard and mouse okay
yep which is good were they not before
yeah no no they behave slightly
differently not since when we change the
camera to be different yeah okay I
changed it was because yeah because I
liked it with the controller like it
seemed to yeah be good like it felt
better
you couldn't try yeah like At first I
felt yeah no but you Queen Strife on
keyboard either it would he would turn
that way yeah yeah
um I thought this felt weird at first
but I'm actually warmed up to it I quite
like it now do they have lights
uh yes okay they do now um it's a bit
hectic
you can see we have our coffee cup on
our head yes I say that
and it like wobbles with the player
movement because it's ah oh cool yes
good
which I really like although I feel like
we could make it we could maybe make it
have a little bit of its own we should
just make it be a barn a bone with no
Mash so that when you animate it it like
animates a different because you know
what I mean right now it looks like it's
just rigidly attached to the Head yeah
as if it's part of the hat but if you
made it wobble like you know what I mean
the other way as you walk yeah you can
probably do that with a bone just add an
extra bone with no mesh on it that we
can use in Hazel to parent it to that
you know wobbles like that
um
yeah someone in my chat suggested like
having that
um why I like the idea as long as we
have time pick up put down and stuff
like that like
pick up put down uh yeah add an extra
bones if you if you just on the the Hat
I'm assuming there's a bone for like the
top of the head just add an extra bar in
this parent It To The Head yeah and as
the player animation plays make it
wobble like the opposite direction or
something like that just one bone and
then that way we could parent the mat
that entity to that bone when it's
supposed to be on the head and it would
just make it a little bit more
it'll just sell it a bit a bit more yeah
and it should take like I don't know 10
minutes
yeah I just gotta pick up the coffee
again
so when we
put it down
um
it does a little flip and then goes to
the ground oh cool can you play that
again I missed it
yep
oh nice
although the Flip's a bit Wild
oh
and it floats down yeah yeah
okay
so um but how do you like what's the
spilling mechanic because you said that
yeah uh you get shot and currently it's
only if you get shot
um all right let's see if I can I'm
guessing this particles fill out yeah
yeah and then does the level go down
yeah the level of the actual like yeah
coffee goes down okay that's nice yeah
that's good yeah I quite like it yeah
that's good
my thinking was that if we get the cup
to kind of tip a little bit when you get
shot like through some animation yeah
um that would look even better yep
which kind of touches on what you were
talking about yep
um
I also
let's see
there's some annoying problems with Ray
cost so the
the enemies don't always hit you even if
it looks like they should
um and I just I spent a while trying to
figure that out and just couldn't figure
out what the hell was going on there's
some weird Shenanigans going on there
right
um might be partially because like I've
had to kind of hack things together
slightly because of bugs in the engine
that would take too long to fix yeah
um but overall it's like
they can still hate you a lot of the
time and you can hit them
and it just feels it actually feels
quite nice
yeah okay because I'm I I might redo the
way that yeah well I did the flashlight
why did the flashlights like flip 180
sometimes
oh it's I think
no I mean like some of the enemies have
them and they're facing backwards see
like that enemy just there
yeah because that was happening to me as
the player as well sometimes
randomly I haven't had it happen for the
player
I have a feeling it's I have a feeling
it's the multiple solutions for going
from uh Euler angles or a quaternion to
a matrix and then back again
possibly because you can you can wind up
with no but that's
I guess that would make sense because if
the solutions are identical then
it would be the same orientation I don't
know it's weird
um
um also
notice the lack of floating
for physics yeah oh yeah so what
happened
the thing that that was happening was
that the enemies weighed eight kilograms
and you were applying a lot of uh a lot
of force to them yeah they got shot
right which caused them to go up into
the sky right
um but then why would they float down
because like the reason they're floating
down
from what I and it's just a guess
is the effectively their y position
gets controlled through like
translation I think it might get set to
zero or something yeah yeah
maintaining the previous wipers yeah I
got it yeah which means that makes sense
um also it's gonna look kind of floaty
no matter what because they're one by
one meter cubes floating down
um that's always going to look weird
but is it yeah
well but like why because like if I have
like eight kilograms it's still quite a
bit right that's like a a decently sized
dumbbell like imagine dropping imagine
dropping that in real life
like that's falling Like a Stone
yeah but also a one by one meter cube of
uh or one by one one meter cube of water
for example weighs a ton
so ah because jolt does something based
on the size versus the density like yeah
it you it's it's using density
calculations not just pure Mass
right and so if the density is off
things are going to look really weird
okay but then how okay we'll say that I
did want them to weigh like I don't know
50 kilograms or something
yeah
and also a one by one by one meter a one
meter cubed water does not weigh a ton
it does I checked it does he said that
exact same thing
but it literally weighs a thousand but
that's
I guess one made us quite a bit
yeah
really
which is roughly a metric ton no it's
exactly
what
um a thousand liters is not a thousand
kilograms
it more or less is what are you talking
about one liter is not oh no no you're
right yeah one liter of water I think
yeah okay about a thousand kilogram okay
sure
the metric system is nice like that
yeah
uh but yeah it's I I increased the
weight of the enemies like I think 70 or
50 something like that
um
40. and it's like it's good enough they
don't go flying off and they don't look
super floaty
uh-huh
so although you know there's still some
some
intelligence problems yes yeah
but yeah what do you think of the world
generation like should we keep it as is
or does it need tweaking
I think it needs tweaking with the hills
like
this like
I feel like it's
but you have about a 50 50 chance of
getting a world that is basically
unplayable
but this is great like this is playable
this is what I was going for this world
that you generated here
because you can you can take like once
the enemies are a bit better you can
take cover behind Hills and like it's
just nice and also it presents a
challenge because you know getting over
heels with a cup of coffee is hard
see all all these worlds I think are
fine I was gonna Maybe
well that's really easy
yeah like it's really good it's fun to
kind of see what you'll generate but
these have all been good so far
but on occasion I have had a world
that's yeah but you said 50 50 chance
well and I haven't seen one yet
see this one's a really high altitude
one
yeah it mostly happens when we get these
high altitude ones that basically don't
have like the grass yeah I mean like
it's possible that there's you know one
kind of
thing that like there's there's I'm sure
there's a case where the numbers are
just a little bit too yeah sporadic but
these are all fine most of the time it's
like it's good is what we've determined
I think
well you haven't shown me a bad one yet
I think they're bad because I've been
playing and shooting yeah I just but
again it's supposed to be hard like
you're you're supposed to well yeah but
that's not I don't think that's because
of the terrain that's because of the
game
that I'm going to spend today working on
like one thing I don't like at the
moment is I really don't like I don't
know if I like that laser that just
shows you can shoot I mean I don't know
how else we do it but one brief idea I
had which is like a little bit
ridiculous but I get I guess technically
from a technical level it would work
fine is if we could have an aim down
site where you could right click and the
camera would zoom in and show across
there in third person
hmm
I don't know my idea for the because
that way you could actually aim
because because the problem now is even
if you like with the red laser you can't
aim up and down and clearly this is a 3D
World with
you know like if I'm sliding up here I
have no chance of shooting those yeah
yeah auto aim is a is a suggestion from
chat like we could make it snap to the
closest
enemy
but I'd rather not do that maybe but
why not like why not though if you think
about it because this is already like a
you know you've tilted it pretty far
there if we just tilted a little bit
more zoom in change the field of view
and then just like it'll be third person
not first person you know and third
person display a little Crosshair in the
center of the screen and then you can
you can shoot that way
like you can still hip fire or whatever
but it would be
that's obviously kind of like very
inaccurate like wherever it tends to go
but if you wanted to you could
zoom in
because that way you could actually move
it anywhere
yeah I mean Assyria we have time for it
because we still have like the core
gameplay yeah but this that is the core
gameplay because at the moment you can't
really fight these guys
great like to have but
well also like we we don't have the
general we don't have you know the tents
being placed yeah
but if we have time for it it wouldn't
be a great time so you think it's fine
now like
I actually don't mind the red laser too
much I'm playing with it yeah but I'm
I'm talking about like generally like
because that this is why I think you
prefer the flat terrain because when
you're in water like this you can
actually kill them but as soon as you
get any kind of vertical displacement
unless they're on the same like y-axis
as you base what y value is you or
whatever you're not going to be able to
shoot them at all
yeah and meanwhile they probably can
shoot you right
uh if they try hard enough
it's all about if they can just push up
against the wall and they'll pissed up
someone said you could also help help
with vertical aim but not horizontal so
basically snap it vertically but then
leave it horizontally like horizontally
you have to aim it vertically it will
aim for you
yeah
that could work
that could work I don't know I think if
if we go for an aim downsize it's going
to be a big zoom in like a very big zoom
in no it's not I third person it's still
why you just tilt it like blow this up
to double this double the size that it
is right now and just show across here
done you could even do it without
zooming in at all just show across there
but the point is as you hold the right
Mouse button it lets you actually you
know perfectly rotate the camera
anywhere versus here which is just it's
constrained that's all that's the only
difference
and then yeah you could just get the gun
like you could could even leave the
player to not lean or anything you could
just make the gun do the aiming so that
the well obviously the player would
rotate but the player wouldn't up and
down would be controlled by the gun
solely so you would basically just tell
this
you know this gun model to point towards
where the Crosshair is and that's it
but yeah no we don't have to do that
that was just an idea
because the other thing is I haven't I
haven't played this remember when I last
played this we didn't have strafing or
moving backwards so basically you could
not run away and fight anyone you had to
always turn towards them and it was very
very very difficult to play the game so
maybe it's a lot better now
exactly so I will uh check it out
yeah I think that'd be good
um
also are we doing different gun times
because in the repository there's
already three different gun types but
we're still yeah yeah well world's the
same way that's fine we'll patch that in
Sadie
we'll have to probably we'll probably
want to update it so you can only like
pick up the weapon I also don't know
what to do with the water like
how do we deal with it we could just
make it Frozen
and then like ice and then make it very
low friction
yeah and that could be a solution just
because like the only thing with the
water is that like I don't like
obviously making behavior for water
is a little difficult
like I don't know if I want to deal with
that
I don't think I'm I'm yeah because you'd
basically have to flirt I don't know
maybe that's well yeah if we had
buoyancy that would be perfect
which someone said we did at one point
uh no we didn't
jolts did
yeah the girls can
oh
wasn't that in your presentation about
jolt you were like it has buoyancy
yeah yeah
because well 131 ammo nice
but do we need it
like you just put a center instead of
the water and the problem is yeah but
that's boring the water adds so much to
this especially with the reflections
maybe you don't care but I just feel
like
uh you could have a scene in which you
have snow going to Grass going to sand
going to ice yeah that could be fun that
could be the fun that could be the fun
okay
King of the Hill
yeah
um
yeah the enemy Ai and 101 needs to do a
lot so what's gonna happen when you run
out of coffee and I'm gonna go get
another one
10th Generation
like once those two are in place
the the like very basic core of the game
is just done I feel like it's basically
done like I it's like you obviously have
to pick up the coffee so now getting it
to a place where a general will accept
it and obviously we can we know the
level of the coffee because you're
changing the mesh or whatever so that's
basically done
yeah like the core gameplay Loop is
pretty much done like yeah you know
so
um
yeah I think the rest is just gonna be
basically ironing out this gameplay
making it super solid and adding all the
other
stuff around it
yeah and like yeah the world generation
like it should be really easy to be like
okay a tent has to go here therefore you
know make all of the yeah flatten that
area and then just transition it like
whatever
well I I think you could you could do it
easily by just being like all right well
the tent is here what is the center of
the tent what is the wire level of the
tile at the center of the tent
and then that use that basically because
what that would do is it would sure it
would make potentially a cliff either
side of it but it would still be
accessible and one like the tent might
be on a cliff you know because you'd
obviously have to flatten the ground to
make a tent and because the noise
usually isn't I might smooth it a little
bit more but it's not you know crazy uh
you know wild when it comes to like the
how much tiles go up per tile you know
what I mean like the it's not too steep
is my point so because of that I think
that would work fine
yeah so that shouldn't be too difficult
and then the generals is there a does
General have a tent
the same tent
yeah yeah I might change it
I think it should be different
we should have a coffee tent yeah that
has like a coffee bean or something on
the front
um which is that one I guess both some
kind of indicated that hey this is the
coffee tent and then the General's 10
maybe that'll be red or like yellow you
know something yeah
the color the texture just let me know
when it's yeah and then maybe have a
different uh kind of it could even say
general just a sign that says General on
the front of the tent
spray painted on the side some some code
that would basically just generate a
random position within the world for
uh the general just because I'm
basically considering moving to getting
the compass up and running
company
yes that's right I was about to ask
actually about that yeah what's that
going to look like is it like an item or
is it just a indicator above your head
or someone though
uh
I feel like there should be a button
that you have to press to bring it up
temporarily so that way you're not
constantly looking at it
so like let's say maybe the Y button on
my controller yeah
um what do we want that to look like
though like in terms of the actual
I could just make like a compass needle
and that could just like sporadically
spin up and then pull it in the right
direction
when you put it on so do you want to
sort of be like a UI element or just
have it be like I don't know a 3D
element above the player's head Maybe
yeah but so that it doesn't conflict
with location of the coffee
I almost feel like it should be a 3D UI
element like that's above the player's
head but so far it's almost like out of
view of the viewport you know like right
at the very top more like yeah yeah like
up there and it's like a big something
big so it's like obviously I don't know
I'll probably make it halfway between
the player and the top of the viewport
but also like yeah and for the logic of
it you could just like look at the XZ
position like don't worry about why
obviously just look at xzad position of
General versus
that was a big jump
um yeah also
I've only had that happen like once or
twice in the past six hours so I'm not
too I don't know if I trust your numbers
after you said that a 50 chance of
getting an unplayable level it's fine I
actually think it used to happen when
you walked over uh blood particles
because the layer had been kind of
messed up right so you could actually
play with them
but it doesn't happen that often
also this it happens a lot
it's kind of funny though yeah
I don't know like we do hate on the AI
I'm the AI but oh stream can't see
uh we do we do hate on the AI but you
know it's actually growing on me like I
kind of like this yeah that's kind of
funny like they're just humbling over
each other to be the one to kill you
exactly and once you can kind of die
slash
um
you know
once you can die slash uh what else was
I gonna say like there'll be some
animation for shooting them and like
it'll be a little it'll feel a bit
better it might be satisfying to pick
them off
you know one by one
and not have them spawn maybe as quickly
or just have him spawn in a mob already
because the thing is like this is
basically like
poor man's flocking behavior because you
just you just no no that's the thing you
don't do any flocking you just do it as
if they're not there and then you let
the physics engine separate them and I
made the Box colliders on them slightly
bigger than they are so they would never
be tight together so they're like
there's always going to be a gap between
them unless it feels extension like
Anyway also how cool is the because I
added some admission to the snow so you
can kind of see it through the fog
yeah I think that's cool I really like
that effect yeah
um
dreamy because in when I when I wrote
the fog for Forest I am
had I handled Bloom differently like
well Bloom being like immersive things
compared to non-emissive so you could
see lights through the fog
um also the I don't like there's there's
a lot of fog but the reason it's like
that is because to hide the level
generation which you can still kind of
see for the snow because it it has a
longer distance but for other stuff you
can't see it the tile the trunks popping
in
and also at the moment the world is
infinitely large well not infinitely
large but it's 70 by 70 chunks which is
a lot and that's arbitrary
yeah I just have a choice you could set
it to anything though it doesn't matter
because the only thing you're doing is
changing the amount of noise values
generated at the start so it it's not
even really going to impact a lot of
times too much
um the I'll I'll make it a little bit
more I'll make it small smaller because
I think this is a bit although on the
other hand like is there a reason to
make it smaller because it doesn't
affect performance until you go that way
doesn't affect performance at all even
if you go there
well it's not going to destroy them it's
just going to repurpose them I think
don't don't worry about touching it
until we have a complete game to play
and then we can see that the world need
to be bigger well because it's kind of
like well you know where the generals
like as long as you don't place the
General's tent like five kilometers away
yeah yeah
yeah or Too Close through this game in a
very short amount of time right yeah
okay well that's the only short amount
of time because like dichotomy nobody
would understand yeah yeah but I feel
like this game is going to be finished
in like two seconds because you're just
gonna run to the General's tent at the
moment the enemies can't catch up to you
I mean they can shoot you but
it'd be funny if every time they shoot
you you kind of roll like it's like you
trip and then you have to get up and
then see what's left of your coffee we
could make it really really uh funny
that could be fun with rag dolls
like if you turn into a Ragdoll yeah can
you add ragdolls quickly Peter
um this is that game Jam it's just being
timidly on like hey Peter can you do
this with the physics engine just real
quick just slap it in yeah
honestly I think half of the issues I've
been having with the physics engine
because there's been a few
I buy a few I mean a lot I think most of
those have actually been fixed by the
multi-threaded
okay yep
because like a lot of these issues could
just be boiled down to physics layers
not being implemented properly for
joules and they are in
uh in um
in the physics multiplayered bronze
I really want to add like a little
between search and the label on the left
in the scene hierarchy panel I really
want to add just a little piece of text
that says how many entities there
currently are
because like for example like I can see
that it's kind of dropping frames every
now and then and I'm almost sure that's
because the AI is shooting themselves
and they're bleeding and there's just a
lot of blood particles being spawned
because that scene yeah we are
destroying them but you see them like
just appearing all the time what happens
is they shoot the ground and the ground
bleeds ah yeah right okay that's funny
so yeah because I don't check I don't
check what what we hit it's just if
we're hitting something we're applying
Force to it man imagine if all of this
imagine if this whole ground was like
a dynamic rigid body and you could like
shoot these hexagons
that would be cool
maybe yeah that's pretty nice well I'd
be I'll believe it when I see it well
yeah don't fall for it okay yeah fall
for it I felt the buoyancy Beetle was
like yo jolt great physics engine come
come switch we switch look at this he's
like no no but wait oh do you found the
edge of the world
wow so how much well um
oh no
oh
you're going down with me
and they keep spawning and hey that
guy's still shooting you what's your
location well
a lot
uh
minus two times damn you're falling at
like a kilometer per three four seconds
95.
that's that's faster than terminal
velocity I'm pretty sure
pretty sure yeah
what's the drag on this player there is
none I forgot because character
controller oh characters control well I
I think it has dragon suits I haven't
exposed it the here's the thing the
character controller I spent very little
time actually implementing like fully
like all of the parameters yeah so you
went you went like two kilometers no
well you start in the middle so you went
over a kilometer
I'm traveling at over a kilometers per
second
downwards
um nice early early to think about maybe
but in about 12 hours time we have to
start thinking game name what are we
calling it we have to start thinking
Forest too that's what I actually think
all right and then the next game will be
dichotomy 2. uh we have to start
thinking like UI elements like how do we
communicate how do you play the game to
the user
um because there's some stuff
I don't know like yeah I think I want to
really like because there's like what 23
hours left I don't know if I'll end up
sleeping I might actually end up
sleeping a bit but
either way I have a lot of time
um so what I want to do is because I'm
just basically ironing stuff out and
adding you know some better AI some
better everything so I feel like part of
that will just be I want to make like
proper the no tutorial text nothing just
like pop-ups that kind of tell you what
to do like I would love it if you could
enter the coffee like there'll be like
an arrow initially being like bouncing
up and down being like going to the
coffee place I mean you don't have to
but you should so you're going to the
coffee place and then you're greeted by
someone else which could just be a cube
I don't really care or maybe just even a
sign that just says like
um
anus in chat telling me to sleep
um uh they'll be just like a sign or
something and you can like you it's not
even that you have to read it it will
just pop up for you as soon as you're
close or whatever and it will tell you
the general like has ordered an oat milk
latte
he needs to and it might randomly
generate that that would be fun if it
could be like
a long black a lot an oat milk latte and
almond milk latte like whatever a large
small medium like it'll be a different
coffee order every time that's kind of
cool
um and you have to take it to him here's
the compass like get it to him like
within you know it'll be but maybe we
should add a timer just because like
coffee does get cold you know
um this is what we should actually do at
the coffee tent there's like five
different coffee types and you have to
get the correct one of the general order
otherwise he throws it in your face but
otherwise you have to run across this
would be great if we had like I don't
know five more artists and they could
all just animate actual characters
throwing coffee and doing everything
like that would be a sick game but
anyway it's been about a week yeah
um and then no but maybe not even no
visible timer for the coffee like you
get like let's just say five minutes or
10 minutes of real world time and then
you know if you and you don't know that
like that would be thick you know what
actually if that sign that tells you the
general has ordered this maybe it's like
a note or something the general has
ordered an oat milk latte uh
you know with our current climates and
outside conditions it'll like it'll be
cold in about five minutes so hurry and
then as soon as you pour it the five
minute timer starts but you can't see it
so you either use your real world time
or you just get there and the General's
like bro this is cold
you know that's I think that's a bit
more fun than because I really don't
want to have an on-screen countdown
timer that's a bit lame
this is 2023 like this is not 2022
anymore where you do that like with
Forest
iced coffee concat hot yeah oh and
that's a cool thing if the general
happens to order something iced then you
get like I don't know 20 minutes instead
of five
but maybe the General's way more way way
further hmm
not 70 but 700 chunks worth
it's like a thousand kilometers away
just
oh yeah we should probably add some
aircraft then so you could like fly to
the like in a helicopter it's like bro
he's in another country at a helicopter
features you've added like this this
game could actually be scaled to like a
triple A level I think I think this this
idea like what is the idea
no think of the marketing as well for
Christmas you're bringing presents to
children like for the form of life this
whole this delivery theme I'm telling
you it's so it applies to like almost
everything in life Yan two days ago this
is literally the worst yeah like
imaginable theme park no I I don't like
this theme that but this is one of the
reasons because it's like delivery like
you know what I saw on the latim Dare
homepage someone legitimately was like
well ladum Dale ludum dare means to give
a game so I'm interpreting the theme as
I'm delivering a game to you
so I'm telling you like
biggest excellent theme but of course
you can you can add your own twists to
it and try and make it interesting it's
not like that's impossible
but like yeah the theme is fun
I would have preferred the help your
health bar is not a health bar or it's
more than just a helper
that's funny
maybe the bad guys could shoot cold air
with leaf blowers aren't going to cool
down the coffee
that's funny
all right well anyway I heard about 10
different features now yeah
we still don't have different guns or
Amy yeah I'll check that in in like a
few hours that like essentially give me
a few hours
but let's add planes actually speaking
of things we don't have we actually
don't have the ability to ship this game
at the moment because the runtime
doesn't work yeah for some reason so
maybe I'll get on that first okay yeah
so my plan is I'll start with the tent
being in the right place and maybe I'll
make the general intent as well once
that's done I'm gonna focus on the
runtime so maybe that will take like
less than an hour hopefully the 10th
thing and then I'll focus on the run
time and then after that I'll come back
and do the AI and I'll see what the
shooting mechanics are like and
Implement all the different guns and
yeah that's it yeah but this is good
like I'm feeling like I'm feeling like
we have a game basically like we've got
the
the game Loop is mostly working and
instead of like adding a tutorial text
in the last two hours of the game Jam I
can actually probably do that
like today you know
quite a bit ahead so that's good I feel
like we went from not really having a
game to suddenly having a game very
quickly or either that or I just slept
and you guys just worked all night well
that is literally what happened you know
what time is the food it's like 4am
right
yeah yeah British still showing a screen
yeah no I haven't been looking at it for
the last like 20 minutes all right yeah
I can see it now yeah okay cool
all right well you said you're still
gonna work for a few hours yeah
how am I gonna
yeah because I was gonna say I don't
want to step on your
sins
so are you planning to do a commit like
any any more than you've already done
and what do you what can I work on
safely
um
so I don't really need to do that much
tweaking to the actual like scene
it's mostly going to be code from now on
except for the comb pass
um I might just duplicate this scene
for like a compass scene and work in
that okay work on the Generation stuff
in here and this time I shouldn't do
anything that just completely means you
have to switch scene
uh yep
oh I'm gonna do that I'm just gonna do
so then I'll work just on the main scene
I guess because I'll be doing the jet
terrain modifying the terrain a bit and
stuff all right yeah
I mean what I could do if you want maybe
this would make more sense actually I
can work on the run time now and then
when you go to sleep I can start on the
scene because I'm gonna have to do the
runtime anyway and it's not like the
runtime has to be done after I do
something
yeah and that way I definitely like you
can have full Reign Over the everything
in the game and I'm not gonna touch
anything in the game because I'm working
on the runtime
yeah you know I'll probably still work
in a separate scene though okay sure but
yeah I'll do that and to be triply safe
I'll do the runtime first
all right and I'm gonna go grab
breakfast yep
all right okay cool
all right see you Peter
see ya
all right chat
uh let's get the music back not at full
volume
oh thinking of music I have to write the
music for the game and the sound effects
oh
but barely speaking Peter make the made
the main menu for Forest I made the game
oh yeah
dichotomy this time that's fine I'm
happy to do that because I think I'll
have time to like
it's almost like we basically got the
game already like I'm pretty I think the
hard work has basically been done
um food is great generation
when you get to that I don't know if
I'll have the models I won't have the
models yet but can you make it supported
the surround generation you're spawning
like tank traps on occasionally and
sandbags on occasion yeah yeah I think
so yeah and then you just tell me how to
make the sandbag sandbag prefer whether
you want it already complete or like one
sandbag and then you'll Build It Up
I think yeah I think I think yeah
especially just keep it simple for now
I'll just put I can put placeholders in
but yeah put placeholders in them
yeah I'll do that um
okay so I haven't played the game yet
since Peter has made all the changes so
let's just run through it make sure
everything works
uh it seems to though
wait I don't have a gun
oh and I don't have the coffee either
ah there's there's the gun I just can't
see it
yeah so we really need to flatten this
area
um
but also like why is this so big this
tent
it just looks like it's uh I guess the
tent here it is tent oh it's oh it's not
spawned in it just starts I guess he
made it really tall because there's a
chance that
it's like in the air or something but
that's weird
I don't think that should happen like
you should just make this
you know be this big basically
um and have a floor so whatever though
why was it like this or whatever
yeah all right
um I guess since I'm here maybe let's
quickly do the generation
for the tent
um
I'll call it coffee tents
General tense
okay so now we don't need this tent
anymore
because we're gonna we're gonna place it
through code
so
uh this will just yeah create tense so
let's do that
um
that's a fun thing to do though why not
have instantiate
I mean this doesn't really matter if you
do instantiate than that but yeah all
right
so I guess what we're trying to do is uh
basically based on the chunk size and
the fact that we have a
3x3 grid here
um
we can probably basically decide like a
point for this pretty easily
we could be like chunk size times three
um well times three minus one
right so what times two no that makes
sense
chunk sizes and tiles which is basically
correct
um
yeah so we can do times three so that
gives us that
minus
because we have three chunks across
right
but I guess minus chunk size times one
at the moment but
yeah so that gives us basically
that's our range right yeah that's our
range
so if we determine a position now for it
now it's a um
this is roughly oh it should be times
two because of the tile size
but maybe even times two times Z tile
offset just so that we don't get
um
so we'll do that uh and then we'll do
Vector two
[Music]
um
tent translation uh has a little random
maybe we should tighten that up so it's
a bit closer to the spawn of the to the
origin but
let's just do range and then we'll do
Min value
um uh no no no I should have not done
this this way
yeah because I need to go oh well
actually
no no I can just do um
yeah flight times range that's what I
wanted to do
we'll do that twice
to get two different values
um
I guess we might as well do this as a
vector three leave Y at zero and then
what we now need to do is we need to
basically sample
the existing environment to see what
tile we're actually at so this tent
translation we need to get a um tile
coordinate from that so I think what I'm
going to do I mean this is the chunk
index yeah so get player tile
um
that's how we get it basically
so let's do
get tile
um
we can just do that probably right
this is a bit of a lame way to do it
but it's okay it'll work
uh
okay
so now we can just arbitrarily do that
which is good because we can try and get
the tile at tent translation and then we
can look at
that's a very bad era so uh like that
should never happen but I um I may have
written bugs obviously so that's why I'm
putting it there
um okay and so this entity
um
that we have here which I guess it's not
gonna let me do that
um
am I gonna have to flatten the area
around it but let's just see what this
does
did that place the tent anywhere yeah
definitely place it somewhere
let's have a look
oh there it is
okay and did it place it at the right
why
value
uh yeah I mean where's the origin of it
though
here well then it did not
which I'm guessing is because my math is
terrible
oh that didn't place the tent at all
argument out of range wonderful
so that was wrong
I think I need to rewrite yeah and the
player doesn't work anymore
well that works actually yeah that
doesn't work I think I broke something
what could I have broken though
huh
I want to rewrite this a bit because I
don't really like it
oh wait this Ah that's because it does
get play at chunk index
ah okay never mind
if I missed this part that's why that's
funny okay
um
well let's actually still but the player
kind of broke there a bit which is weird
but let's still maybe keep this working
um and then
how can we get play a tile and get tile
can be something else
um
but I wanna I wanna Conway write it okay
so let's think about this how would we
get because I guess they're split into
chunks which is the problem but
we need to know
um like if we pass in a position
and we want to get the entity or like
even the N index no let's just get a
position so this is a world space
position
right
so if we have that
how do we get into tall space well the
why we don't care about but for the X
and the Z
right I guess we want to divide that
by
um
basically
true for the X and then two times Z tile
offset for the
y right for the Zed
and then that gets us basically our
coordinate in World space
right so this should be the coordinate
of the tile in World space but see the
problem is that the tiles aren't stored
in one big collection they're stored per
chunk so this isn't even that useful
um like we kind of need to figure out
what chunk we're in
and that's where I think we could do
this as well
we could do get chunk index from this
uh
which I don't yeah we don't need to do
it that way
X
Zed so we're just dividing that by a
chunk size now
and I think that gets us the chunk index
that we're in
um and then
since we have a coordinate
okay but that's the chunk index yeah
and so ideally that chunk is currently
loaded
but I don't know if it necessarily is
because what if it's not loaded
if it's not loaded we need to do
something different
all right
um
it bothers me a little bit that we don't
really know which chunks are loaded like
it's gonna be in here but we don't
really know which one but there's only
nine of them
so maybe it's not that bad to be honest
because basically what I'm saying is
like the
what we do is we kind of need to go
through every chunk and do this but
there's only nine of them so it's
probably not bad
but like we basically go through all of
them and check to see is this the chunk
index we're looking for and if so then
we kind of need to do yeah this like we
need to look at it from
Within like
um
I guess we want to maybe change this so
that it does do
like
oh but we need that anyway
um world core
yeah so and we no we don't need this
anymore though it's a bit it's actually
a bit easier though because we've done
it in a different space so we go through
and as long as we found the chunk index
we now need to find a local space within
that so I think what we do is we just do
um
so what's the offset here that oh but
that's not
wait do we need to though
oh no no we could do this we could do um
so it's going to be chunk index
yeah times
um
the chunk size
two no times two is
so this is tile based now I think
well it's just that I think right
I think so
oh lots of stuff here so if we do that
then we get
an offset
uh and this is a this should be a 2i I
think
I think we get an integer
offset
um and we just do
basically our world chord minus
the offset
yeah and now we should kind of know
I think this should give us if I'm right
which I don't know morning math and
stuff is usually is difficult
why is that not working
oh
this should give us the coordinate right
and then I can use that
uh this should work like this this
should be relatively easy to debug
because what I can do
um is just do it every frame and
basically be like hey player
like let's get the players World space
position right which is just that
um and then let me try and get like
the tile that we're on
and then
um
and I'll highlight it
yeah I don't know if this will work but
we'll make it work
um
so if tile
oh if tile
does a nickel previously highlighted
tile
then
basically we need to so let's we'll
change the material to something
all right let's make it like snow or
something
but um previously highlighted tile dot
get component
oh I guess we need to keep track of what
it used to be as well
so we'll get the material
yeah
I think hold it I could be pressed a
hole doesn't matter that's easy to
change
so this this way we can just put it back
um
this should probably be high currently
highlighted tile but whatever
um
so we'll set that and then we'll
basically
yeah I don't even know if we need that
necessarily I guess we do we want to
compare them
um so we'll just set the material
to be this
uh and then
we'll set the material
to be our highlighted material which I
think I'm just going to make it
made materials three which is snar for
now
so this makes sense so we find a tile if
it's not null which it shouldn't be
um then we
check to see if it is different from the
one that's currently highlighted and if
it is different then we want to change
it
um and we do that by first restoring the
material
on the old highlighted tile change the
highlighter tile to be the new tile
that's keeping track of the material and
then updating material I guess that does
make sense and it doesn't work though
but we'll see
lots of arrows no references uh line 354
looks like something I just wrote
this is now
because it doesn't have a static mesh
component or it's null ah yeah of course
wait what am I even doing here Adam yeah
this does not
um
yeah correct
but this is a little bit annoying but
whatever doesn't matter this is not this
is just debug code anyway
so I don't really care
all right well that kind of works
so you can see what tile we're on it's
just we need to offset it I think
yeah I mean it still it works uh but it
changes a bit quickly
it's very very close to working
I mean it's like off by one
um
I have a feeling that if we just
do World court right when when do we do
this
we do what this
so world's Pace position X Y divided by
that
what if we just do plus equals half the
tile basically which is
one nice uh said tile offset
all right if we do that
still weird
or maybe subtract or maybe it's
different
oh wow no
that's already been divided by that
uh hence I didn't know
[Music]
um
yeah it seems like
if I did if I maybe did it here
uh
wait that doesn't make sense
all right
um
that seems like it should work
wait what did this used to be
oh just that
right it used to be this
what
oh I used to be that
wishes effect too as well so
what's the problem
what's wrong with that
why is it converting it to a float
or float it's effect two
how is that a float
that's really weird
ah because the Constructor
I don't think we can start to take
Specter okay so that
no I mean
it's still wrong I would like I don't
the thing is realistically I don't
actually need it to be precise but I
would like it to be
and why are we getting so many errors
this so yeah this is weird this is not
really correct all the time that's
worrying
okay let's not do this
I don't know why this is out of range
though
[Music]
good
let me love me me
I'm
looking at the log over here
that's not out of range or anything
I don't really see why it would be
although am I getting errors no I mean
there is this
that's in a different file I don't
really care about that
[Music]
why was I getting out of range before
I would really like it to be accurate
because it might be useful for other
things
also why is that a
let's not make this a list let's make
this an entity
um
that is 16 by 16 although
that is going to depend on
the chunk size but this is pretty much
fixed
[Music]
okay
go away
I can't move them
weird
um
I Wanna Live Your Life
so yeah the origin is is right here
so like that should be fine but we're
not getting the origin
we're seeing the index and the index the
thing is the index is always going to be
uh kind of bottom left right
which is why I thought my code would
work
I thought if I offset the position so
that I'm kind of matching that up it
would work but it doesn't seem to
like that doesn't make sense
oh but maybe it's because this also
needs to be offset and that's why I was
getting errors
I don't know
he was
[Music]
it does seem like it would be minus uh
basically half a tile
which again is basically
two
but half a tile
and
zero point uh is that tile offset
so that looks like I'm subtracting half
a tile
um
in World space
oh but if you already passed that in
this doesn't need it
but I just don't know why that doesn't
work
foreign
it looks like it kind of looks like it
went the wrong way
[Music]
so that's just that's actually ah it
kind of looks like it's the correct you
know what it is it looks like it's the
correct it's the it's correct in one of
the axes and not the other maybe that's
the problem
um let me get a different world
I'm pretty sure this is uh
just hard to know the axes whatever I'll
just play with it
um
so if I stick a negative for example
here
no
um let's take a negative here
foreign
in this axis right
ah there we go so it should uh well not
not quite
so strange I mean this almost worked
but also it's perfect this way so what
way is that
looks like both X and said
I think it's predominantly sad though
so the X I think might be wrong
but that doesn't really fix it
so this is X
yes I see X looks like it's about half
off
which is weird but sure
that's so weird
it almost looks like X doesn't need an
offset
but that doesn't work so
I'm just guessing at this point
something worse
so it does need an offset
but how how is that not exact then and
the origin of the player is in the
middle right yeah
okay well I mean this is definitely good
enough
for our purposes but
it's just a little bit frustrating to me
um now
we should also be able to replace
so get player tile let's try that
instead
because we want to make that work
so this should be wrong I think well
this will be wrong right
I mean it's a bit more off but it's not
actually that's pretty good oh but then
it goes out of range sometimes all right
whatever
um anyway we'll make the get player tile
I think
uh
we can just make this be get tile and
pass in play out of translation
and that should
hopefully work and not give us any index
out of bounds
I mean it's definitely not not perfect
but
it doesn't need to be maybe the fact
that it's hexagons is let's bring it up
a little bit
shouldn't really be but whatever
okay whatever I'm happy with that get
rid of this
I don't think we need to get play a
chunk index either
we should be able to get chunk index
um from player.translation
that doesn't have the offset applied
though
hopefully this didn't break everything
doesn't seem to have
the level generation I meant
um okay
so I'll maybe I'll keep my highlighting
system around
just for fun in case I need to use it
for debugging
later but now that I've done that it
should be easy for us to determine
um I guess a tent translation
this is a warning
and now we can do get tile at that
translation and then place it at the
right height hopefully
not a reference exception
I mean that's in root version player Ah
that's because I'm not doing that um
because then I'm not uh I forgot to
create tents
okay so placing tent at 49 13.
49 13.
and is it at the right y value so
yeah I mean it is but we just need to
flatten it it looks like it's about the
same the right about y value so
so let's do this so once we have a tense
translation and we've instantiated it
let's see how big this tent actually is
um
so if we find it
wait what it's over there
no it's not
what was that why was I seeing something
over there
that's weird um all right so how big is
it uh
so let's see that's the origin so
one two three four five six we'll call
it six by one two three four five six
six by six let's make it seven by seven
so basically an area of seven by seven
tiles so plus three minus three
um will have to be changed so once we
have it
and if it's on a chunk boundary
that's gonna suck
which probably reduce this
but yeah we need to basically go go
ahead and
change the heights of some of these
things
so
that's not too difficult actually
actually I think that'll be easy because
if we just go Z minus one
yeah yeah I think I can do this
um
Maybe
yeah I think so I think this will work
and my head is working
which doesn't always mean it's actually
working but
yeah
no don't do that for now
uh okay
um
so if we just do get tile tent
translation
um but I'm gonna modify that tent
because it's going to basically be
uh dot X is going to be
plus equals z
times yeah I guess two
and then oh sorry x uh and then Z times
two times that tile offset
so this is going to either subtract or
add that hopefully and then if we try
and get
uh tile there we should have a tile so
let's try and for now
um
uh
I mean I could just do yeah let's just
do translation.y equals tense
translation to Y so I'm flattening that
area
um
this is a little annoying though
foreign
that didn't even work a little bit
what
ah it crashed
uh line 104 I think
this so this is null
why
that should not have a null I must have
messed this up
but this clearly exists
and then I'm going three
I'm going on a radius of three by zero
yeah
well three by three so seven tiles
seven by seven tiles right yeah
because three to three including zero
and a three um
yeah Peter all hold on call uh in one
second that's really frustrating why
doesn't this work
what
how could this not work
it's actually like perfect
all right I'll hop on Peter's call
see
all right what's up Peter
uh so I pretty much finished like in
terms of functionality
yep
um I don't think necessarily that the
ultimate is exactly what we want yet
um
this is the kind of level I was trying
to show you before ah let me just see
oh yeah
um I'll try to stream
yeah
yeah I mean yeah okay I'll I'll try and
iron it out but like this is definitely
playable like what makes this not
playable
uh it's more like just like these two
tiles for example when there's like a
lot of like tiny dips like well yeah
it's it's uh that's the type of
environment this is
it's playable it's just a different
experience which is good like that's the
whole point I think of randomly
generating levels unplayable to me would
be I'm stuck in a jet ditch and I can't
jump out
well exactly yeah
where I got stuck inside one of the
tiles when I spawned but that's a
different issue yeah yeah that is a
different issue that should be fixed now
because I redid the way I check which
tile we're on
um but this is kind of nice it's kind of
like you're in the mountains you're in
the high mountains and there's snow
everywhere and there's a few batches of
grass like
you know
diversity and also it doesn't happen
that often like I would say it's a lot
more common to get something better like
so
absolutely this is just for the yeah
okay and it's nice having diversity as
well
every time you play it looks different
yeah apparently if you hold the Y we
just get it oh okay good that's cool we
might want to tweak like the way it
looks
um and currently it's just like pointing
towards zero zero basically yep
but it's easy enough to get the position
of the general and just point it there
and then with Tim's yeah that's really
cool
um and I almost think that we don't need
need the temp model like this looks kind
of cool did you say Peter's Compass this
looks kind of cool
see
and if we had transparency then we could
have made it slightly transparent and
red or something yeah and that would
have been done
and it's only when you hold y on the
controller and what is it in maybe tab C
on the C on the keyboard yeah
maybe it should be tab yeah I think tab
would be handy yeah because that's
easier to see a bit nicer to reach
to be honest we should opt for the
cartography what's called theme as well
oh yeah
but not too far oh the tent has a floor
now
uh I think that's just temporary oh
that's yours yeah because I was gonna
say why is the tent so tall like no it's
tall so that if the yeah but that won't
happen anymore
like because we're gonna make the ground
even well the origin is still at the
normal place it's just that's yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah no that's fine yeah
okay excellent
I had a big Cube so that we could
accomplishment
yep
um I'm gonna head off for about for
about an hour take a bit of a break okay
and I'll probably be back on afterwards
because I would like to get the gun
types and ammo types actually
working yeah you can't you know get the
animal from a kind of a different types
yeah okay yeah
um cool sounds good I'm yeah I'm I'm
pretty determined to get this tent
ground flattening it made me redo my
whole uh
system for handling where the player
like which because it's not that easy to
look up which tile you're like from a
from a world space coordinate what tile
is under me because there's no like
Global list of tiles they're like per
chunk and so you have to find the chunk
index and then you have to find the
offset from within the chunk because
it's in the chunk's local space and it's
a little bit annoying versus like just
one array of like every single thing in
it but you can't really do it that way
if you want chunks so yeah it's a little
bit finicky and now the transl my y
translation isn't being set correctly
for whatever reason so I'm trying to
pick that up
yeah okay cool sounds good enjoy your
break
yep
yeah
no it sounds good all right all right so
yeah enjoy your break bye
yep see ya
all right I'm just going to set the
material
so that way we can actually see which
ones have changed because I don't know
if it's the uh
so we'll set them also snow
yeah it's not
either it's not finding the right ones
or
and maybe let me disable the fog because
the fog is making it harder to
to see
yeah like look like what did that do
nothing I mean we are crashing in line
but that's not that's not in our script
so it shouldn't really matter I don't
think
that's in
here
then why is it crashing probably an easy
fix
because there's no entity called gun I
guess
because we don't have a gun or something
whatever that does I don't think that's
affecting anything
so then why
that tent is on the edge why can't it
find the right tiles for the tent
okay let me make a new material really
quickly
we're gonna call it m underscore debug
and this material
will be like magenta or something and
emissive
and I'm gonna go into the
level generator and add one more oh no
actually let's add it as a separate
field entirely so that we don't forget
to strip it from the game I think
so debug material
and that will be our debug material
and that way I can actually like
make it be very obvious
you know
uh
which one is the problem one
yeah see what I mean see how much more
obvious that is now what the heck
that card is so wrong it's not funny
this is apparently the error this is
these are the tiles that should have
selected
what
how did I go so wrong
that's nuts
unless this get tile code is just
entirely broken
but it is getting a lot of null tent
tiles not all of them though
but many of them
okay how about we do this
so let's do
let's do this for a second because this
should work right
but I'm not it's like getting a Jason
tiles seems to just not be working
let's just return
so yeah it's obviously like it's
obviously able to get the tile on like
Under the Tent meaning I mean it picks
that but okay so it's placing the tent
wait
ah
I moved so it regenerated
the tiles and we lost the one that was
the tent uh that's that's okay though
um
yeah I did it again
okay so if we're here for example right
um
it thinks it's a 13 0 29 right and we
are at 13 29.
um and which chunk is that a part of
this chunk right
and there's this one which I happen to
pick and that's at 1329
so the one next to it
see that's the thing the one next to it
is in fact two units across because if
I'm going through this if you guys can
see this
like you can see that it's
going up by two and if I go down to the
like the next row it'll be up by
should be two times
0.86
which it is
so that's definitely correct
but then what's weird is that if I try
and get that tile
it's like it doesn't work
so if I try and
get a tile there's basically tentile
translation Plus
let's just do two
the fact that that doesn't work is very
very very bad if if true
I might despawn it
well no that worked look
what
let's try do the one
here
and I also want to just adjust the
player real quick and
say that uh if the
if the mouse is not locked
uh
how do you lock the mouse
where are we doing this
I thought we were doing this here as I
didn't play a controller
no
wait we're locking the mouse right
oh camera Rotator okay so input cursor
mode
yeah this is what I'm talking about so I
kind of want to just be like if
whatever makes the player move
uh
key code.w or whatever yeah
so let's only do that if
the cursor is locked
otherwise I don't want to do this
because I want to use
I need to use those controls for the
camera so now
where am I over here
you can say if I try and move
I can still jump but I can't
um I have to lock this to be able to
move and then if I unlock I can't move
okay good
but let's uh also extend that to jump
Maybe
I guess I can't do anything which is
good so now I can fly around without
moving to the trunks look that also
worked
so are you kidding me
what of what the heck have I done then I
must have written some very dodgy code
create a real-time strategy game I would
love to make an RTS at some point
maybe we should do that next game Jam
um okay so if this is clearly clearly
working then what have I written here
oh
my man I'm incrementing that every time
that's the offset from here I don't know
but I'm getting it every time so
actually that should be fine
dude this is strange
like this is really really weird
No Mono
yeah debugger time maybe
okay that was just a null reference
exception
line 115.
this is now
because what it doesn't have a static
mesh component
bro this is so weird
like this is really really strange how
this works and this doesn't
like what am I doing I'm using tense
translation which is this
I added you know two times that to that
which does the same
I'm adding them right
this is I'm not I mean I'm going back by
three
so this is X which is -3 for the first
iteration times two
right like
I must have done something really really
weird so -3
well okay I tried getting the adjacent
tiles but what if I get something that's
not adjacent so this works right let me
just validate this quickly
Ah that's still a null reference did I
not uh I did return
wait what does this sound not wire
what is now here
line 96
this is null
now this doesn't work
well that just working by chance but no
it worked and now mono crashes as well
but like I don't understand this was
working before
you guys were saying that oh no no I
think I didn't save the scene when I
crashed and so the material
the debug material got on set and that's
why
okay beautiful so that's the adjacent
one right let's try and do
uh you know so that's two times that
let's try and do like
offset that by
-2 for or minus three will go minus
three so now I'm setting the one that's
a bit further from the tent
uh and that seemed to have worked
predictably
let's go forward
by three so I should be in front of the
tent ah look it's here so this is
actually working perfectly
bro this is so weird
okay you know what
let's go back to this system
um but then let's just like
let's just do the math here
like I am here because I don't
understand
and then we'll do uh basically x times
two
um
and then Z times two times that Tyler
set because that's what we're doing and
then we'll get rid of this
and what do you know it works so am I
like crazy
let's go back to the old system for a
bit
because I just want to get to the bottom
of this honestly it's so weird
uh and what was it doing tentile
translation like why is that code
different
it's not
so why wasn't it working before is it
because it was like an edge case but I'm
pretty sure I tested it many times
so this is the area that I'm going to
flatten
but that's so strange and maybe I should
expand it a bit but um
what the heck
anyway I think I like this code a bit
more because it's a bit shorter but
isn't that so strange
or was the difference that I had um
this card here and that was somehow
messing something up
oh look
it does mess it up
how
dude that is weird
so by changing the Y translation I
completely mess up my tiles
oh I'm setting the wrong thing aren't I
is that why
oh man no no no no
this is this is why I don't write code
in the mornings
it's 1pm but still there you go
look we have a platform
I guess we should try and smooth it out
though so we can have our our platform
right
um but then what we could do is we could
try and smooth it out
so
um
full Edge smoothing uh is
basically
uh well
we'll see
um so
because what I mean is like what we
could do is we could do that but
we could do um
a different strategy if it's near the
edge and I think my indentations off uh
so how do we know if we're near the edge
um well basically if
um
Zed is greater than three so let's
increase this to five
well now let's do four for now maybe one
tile of smoothing is fine
um
or uh we'll do X instead in that order
so that's our Edge so then we won't
quite do it perfectly
basically what I want to do is
um I want to just set this
to basically be like halfway
I'll just use to be lazy and use a lap
we'll do we'll do a lot that's kind of
halfway between
the tenths Y and our why
and that's what we'll apply it to and so
that should just make those edges kind
of a little bit smoother
so it's affecting more of an area but
you can see it's kind of doing a middle
ground between what it used to be it
could do a middle ground between this
and this but at the moment I'm getting
it to do a meal ground before between
the original value and what it is but
you can see that still kind of creates a
a thing and if we wanted to we could
expand this
and I guess that would be even smoother
right
so that actually looks kind of cool I'm
just afraid that if the tent is too
close to the edge it will crash but it
might not because if it's now it just
ignores it
so actually that might be fine so now
let's not set the material to a debug
material but also we need to make sure
it's not like water or whatever
but there you go
see you get a nice flat terrain around
the tent now
and that should always work but you can
see if it's in water it remains in water
so maybe we should just also make sure
that if
the uh tentile doesn't equal null
check the material and we'll say if
material no I'm not going to change it
to Grass I'm just going to say if the
material
um if tentile
because well basically this
let's get the static mesh component
and check its material
and if that's snow which has materials
three
arthritis
is water zero
yep
if it's water then we'll change it to
something else
um we could like we could just make a
grass but maybe sand would be better a
grass or sand
it could look at the adjacent things do
I really wanted to do that though
for now let's just set it to grass
which is number one
be nice to have it be like a rock
that I just told him not to worry about
making
but you can see that wow that didn't
work
why did that not work
maybe that equals equals doesn't work it
should
that's ah tentile am I that's the right
one yes the right one
huh
isn't that strange
ah it's possible it would get uh and
also after it might get reassigned later
if I go out of the thing
wow look at this flat landscape
that's rare
yeah and see that sand huh that doesn't
work
strangely enough
I don't know but it only changes if it's
water
so never mind
oh look at this see this is dodgy if
it's outside I should just make it not
be that far out though
um that's easy to do
well it's for this one
um but basically I could just construct
it a bit
so that's a range I'll just make it like
point
nine
reduce the range a bit
yeah I I'm happy with how it looks
though like it because it
it's made it um
you know the blending is cool I think
yeah but the water situation that
doesn't doesn't work
is it the way uh it might be the way we
compare materials
ah I don't think we are
what's the uh equals operator is just
equals or something
like how do we um make that work
I think it's
oh I missed this one okay
I I just don't think that's implemented
for materials so let's make it in let's
implement it
um
down the bottom I guess
uh and The Way We compare it is just the
handle the asset handle
um
like that
that I knew
thing apparently
okay so hopefully now
it does work
because I guess I was comparing the
objects before where's my tent oh oh I
almost had a heart attack no it doesn't
work
why don't you work
oh what the heck
now I need to find some water oh that
looks like it worked because look
there's especially water everywhere
except for like the tent area
uh although we don't need to do that for
the smoothing because see I think it's
doing a bigger area than it needs to
um because it's including the tiles that
we smooth however
um although we can't smooth water tiles
maybe not we'll make it happen because
we can't smooth water tiles because it
doesn't make sense to change the Y
values of water it's always zero
um because you can't really have water
on an angle
yeah that's good so we're always on dry
land
I would love to do swimming but that
would be kind of tough I think
all right I think we're good like let's
try and play this
um I'll get my I'll put my fog back
it's pretty cool I like that
okay fog is back
let's hit play
let's find the tent
yeah I like the strafing it's kind of
cool I guess
it is a bit of a flat land but
the problem is it's hard to find the
tent if you don't know where it is
because before it was easy because the
world was small but now that I'm
generating chunks again
it actually might be difficult to find
the tent
which is why I guess we'll have an arrow
to it
kind of like Peter's Compass Arrow
or is it too far out should I make the
tent closer to spawn
um where is it 39 15 and we are at
nowhere near 39.15 we're going the wrong
way
okay
39 15.
I found it oh what that didn't work it's
not flat
what the heck
what
and we had a null reference exception no
that's the old one
oh no no it's not flat because it
regenerated the chunks
oh
this is going back to my old system that
I have to do
now Peter's been talking in chat sorry I
didn't hear I didn't know
see this is going back to me being a bad
person and generating stuff on the fly
but also we might be able to improve the
performance so at the moment takes about
3.2 seconds to generate a new set of
nine chunks
uh 3.9 milliseconds that is sorry um
so we need to make them
uh we need to not do the generation
because what I'm doing is I'm generating
the noise values up front but then
like I'm not doing the chunks
so the chunks aren't
the chunks should be like the chunk
translation and material type well
material type is can be determined but
the that should basically persist so
let's make that possess because we have
two otherwise it won't be good
um
so that's what this does set chunk you
can see it actually calculates
everything so I think the first thing we
need to do and the way I would probably
make this work is I just make like a
struct
or something called chunk data Maybe it
can be a class I don't know
um
and basically
we're gonna have
[Music]
um
a translation
and we could even store a material but
the thing is it's kind of it the
materials is determined by the height
I don't know but then there is a
different Logic for tense so we'll have
a material fine
um
is that it
oh but that's for a chunk so oh no so
that should be for a chunk so let's have
tile data so that's per tile
and then we just have a chunk just has
you know 16 by 16 of these
but they're not entities they're tile
datas because entities are reused
whereas this is not
you know I don't really like Strokes to
be completely honest because of the
weird stuff like initializers not being
available and before certain c-sharp
versions so maybe we'll make this a
class
um but I don't really care like it's I
don't think it's gonna affect
performance too much in this case
um
that's it right
I think it is uh what else do we do in
set chunk
yeah so the benefit here right is we're
gonna have
um for each chunk coordinate
we're going to have
a potential chunk data
um and I guess we can allocate that up
front if we wanted to right
because we have we kind of have our like
where's our noise
noise values see so we can basically
have a chunk data like that
for each chunk which is going to be
width whoops
chunks by height
so we just pre-allocate that
and then when we set a chunk it's very
easy we just basically check to see hey
man
do you already exist
and if you do guess what we can do we
can do something entirely different
um else we have to basically generate
this
um
for all of the chunks this is going to
be so much faster caching this as well
um but
we can just be like so Chunk in this
case chunk data cxcy
I'll see Zed equals uh
new chunk data
oh I'm going to do this for tiles sorry
per tile obviously
the tiles already have their eye value
so I think
so X Plus Z times chunk width
chunk size
equals new tile data
and so we need to set the translation
which is tile.translation but let's just
translation let's not access
the C plus plus and then this is
um the material
which is I mean we're setting the
material here so maybe let's do this
instead
so that we can just do that
all right
I meant uh
oh no that's okay I think
okay that's donzi's
um you right mate no no point here well
I'm such a C plus plus programmer
um all right so
yeah we still have to go through this
but we don't have to worry about the
weird even offset or whatever
like this situation even doesn't exist
anymore it's just that
um and we still need to do something
well basically we just need to
um grab the tile from the chunk
yeah so I think I think we still need to
do this
which is fine that's easy
ah radius that was fun I don't think
I'll need that anymore but whatever
um and then
you know we can obviously get the chunk
data here
and we still need to go through and
basically grab the right tile
and then set basically the tile
translation
to um so that's the chunk data let's get
the tile data
dots
tiles X Plus Z times chunk size
tile data translation material or mattes
that's it I think so that's now kind of
caching it
and should also massively
improve the performance and hopefully it
will work nope
that's to be expected
line 205.
that's wrong oh M chunk data or is it at
that index it's wrong what was the it
was index outrage right
uh oh is that negative is that why
I think so
well no actually it says zero to oh no
that's chunked index
yeah these probably are negative yeah
they are okay
so what do I do
um I need to increment it
by
I need to basically do
uh
CX I think it's going to be plus
uh map side map with chunks
divided by two right
hopefully
be funny well we'll see if it's off
we'll see pretty much instantly so
that's what we use
for chunk data
I guess we can just do
uh whatever
Central Access
okay so what I want to do is I'm going
to get out of a chunk I guess I'll turn
the fog off
um check my tent and I'll just try and
generate like a new chunk and then get
back to the old one
and get away back away back well that
seems to work oh but this failed wait
what
uh why did my tent not work huh oh look
that also changed so that's wrong
would have loved it for it to work the
first time
yeah look at that
I think the index is just like wrong or
something
it's got to be a little bit wrong
I think it might be this
I didn't do height but the width and
height are the same
is it minus one
it's really not
that's not
but see now it's consistent which is a
weird because it almost looks like
the first time it generates it's
different but also what do we use for
sampling actually because that's a good
point so excess
well that's because we do times chunk
size because we need it at the
individual thing but this is our look
plus this so This is actually well well
that's what I'm doing though
see
so this this lines up with this which is
good because that was the noise thing so
then why is it wrong
huh
well good news is we don't need that
because we can just use SX and S5
that's that sucks and I said
but I still don't know why it's not
working
you aren't updating the tents oh you're
right I'm not
you well well actually though
yes I mean you're right
the tent should
but it looks like it changes more than
just that so
oh maybe I'm wrong though maybe it
doesn't I don't know
um but let's try and obviously make that
happen so
how do we do that in a nice way
we have to basically edit the cache
right
it's very annoying
although not really like we know what
chunk we're on
and we're gonna be within we might not
be within one chunk
but um
I'm thinking about a bit of a longer
term solution because
I have to um
I have to also generate the tent for the
general and that will be on a chunk that
isn't loaded yet so it's almost like
it's almost like I would like to
it's almost like I would like to just
generate all the chunks at the beginning
of the world right that would be better
than doing it on the fly but the thing
is that doesn't scale well like for an
infinite World for example but we have a
huge World here but we we're not gonna I
don't think we'll stick with that
so what might be better to do is just to
generate everything first
and then you know in the kind of logic
that does the SAT chunk
like that will also handle the tents
right and then that way we don't have to
revisit it and edit it
but like you know I mean we could
whatever let me just make it work both
ways just because I can always change
the other system later and this way I
know that like
you know in case we need this for
whatever reason we'll keep it this way
maybe
um but let's do this
so
let's have a
um and tile data I don't know it's a
struct I'm going to change it to be a
class I think
um the only real reason is because I
want to return it by reference but and I
could use ref or whatever but whatever
so get tile data right I'll get i'll get
tile data
for and I'll I'll make it work with my
weird world space position system
because that's predictably what gets the
other thing out so it should technically
work
so if I ask for
if I ask for this it's gonna have to get
the chunk index which is okay because
I'm pretty sure that same chunk index I
can fit into somewhere else
oh no no but that's a chunk index that's
different sorry this chunk index
I should be able to easily figure out
the chunk index because this is
different
um this actually should be
how do I get the chunk index
from an offset
okay so let's just say I do have the
offset so if I just
um yeah divide this by
the chunk
size
um
and Florida I guess
my kind of flurry right here
chunk size of course is just a chunk
size okay so this now should give me
basically inside the cache
so chunk data right
this should give me the chunk data
uh and then to get the and then I have
to get the tile
from within that uh
which I was doing something else for
that's actually not bad I think
because if I just take the offset and I
divide it by the tile size which is
oh my God I'm still hard coding the tile
sizes it's a bit of a
comedy show
and it's been offset I believe so
but I think that should work like if I
just then access the tiles
and I do like I don't know
um I guess mods
uh 16.
Plus
y
divided by 16 right
times
16.
that should maybe get me in my tile data
that was nice
I don't know man this is so dodgy
um
I could get it to refresh actually let's
let's get it to refresh the chunks
so process chunks only does it if uh
yeah but let's do if
input
here's key pressed even Minecraft has it
I think in the
public release
um you can refresh your chunks or at
least with optic uh not OptiFine or
whatever
hmm
I'm nice you need this full-on for this
code but
half the game is Roger so it's fine yeah
great
um
okay well that doesn't change
I guess that's that should be good
like that means mate uh but hang on
but where am I setting my index
from
um
weird
so have I actually used this function
for anything yet
get tile data no okay beautiful
testing something without actually
testing it
um okay so this is what I kind of wanted
to do
um I want I guess I wanted to do I
wanted to be like get tile data
that's
this tent
and then let's just like
let's make sure that's not null
otherwise I want to know about it
now let's set the material to the
material
uh
well potentially this I guess
whatever I'll just do get material
uh and let's set the translation
to
t
because this is just x and z so it
should get and get it correctly Maybe
I got some null references that doesn't
look good
that first one line 416
416 is my beautiful function isn't it
yeah it is
so this is that a no reference exception
oh the tile's just not there
ah can we not access the tiles yet
no we should be able to
how strange
unless this also was not I mean let's
just uh attach the debugger
I guess it's possible that those chunks
haven't been created yet but some of
them should have been
like 35 no they're all now
am I doing this before I can't be doing
this before uh well I'm I am doing it
before it was cached for the first time
ah see this is a disaster
probably shouldn't have done this
ah
although no I am calling set chunk
though so that should have actually
populated that
and then I'm doing create tense and this
is happening in creatents
so unless I'm I'm wrong with my offset
it'll crash probably
it didn't crash
it's because the debug is not attached
Maybe
okay that didn't crash again so what's
my world space position yeah and that
should be fine and my offset's fine so
the chunk coordinate
is mine is one minus one oh I didn't
actually play with that maybe that's why
so this chunk coordinate needs to be
yeah yeah okay gotcha
this chunk coordinate
needs to be
plus equals
um
the map size divided by two
map width chunks
divided by two
map height chunks divided by two
and Hazel's gonna crash
because of the debugging bugs
no still a null reference exception oh
and that's very bad news why are we
inside a tile
417.
are still the same problem
huh
weird
yeah 35 37
that's maybe correct
but I guess the problem was none of
these looked like they were said
or were they so 35 37 right
oh no look they are oh 36s yeah so it
actually should be minus one it looks
like
well it's for this data structure it
should be
ah it's also when you reload the
assembly that's right it's not just
debugging the crashes Hazel it's when
you attach the debugger you run it you
debug or whatever and then you reload
the assembly and then it crashes
all right this thing's still wrong
somehow
which is odd
maybe I am wrong
oh look this is a null anymore
are there tiles and all no
256 tiles xs6
y0
wait
so why is this now or is it just now
sometimes
well that's not yeah
oh it's not null I think well at least
not it's not that time
um okay so F5 yeah I'd say that doesn't
persist
it goes back to what it was yeah so it's
just the tent
so basically it's probably just my
math or whatever for the tent
probably just the wrong
tile
I mean the other thing is because we're
actually getting the entity and we're
setting it
so the energy and we set the translation
to be
we get the entities around it and we set
the translation to be a little something
um hmm
but we are getting its translation so we
should be able to recover that same tile
from the cache using that
so actually I guess that should work
it's probably just me being bad
but I don't understand how and how it
would be moving bad considering
I'm pretty sure that that's right
oh look this crashed now
yeah 28.
why is 28
how
well that's 37 now
yeah well actually that kind of makes
sense but
yeah that's
yeah the problem here is chunk daughters
now
that's because I think we're a little
bit too I think we're a little bit
further from the chunk so I think that's
okay
um
we can actually just do this
because it just won't affect the tiles
that get set or whatever
like I said it just won't it won't um
those tiles won't be changed either if
they're outside of the first three
chunks
um but yeah
but my problem is it clearly didn't
write correctly because you can see that
the tent doesn't have that
so initially the tent will be correct
but then F5 it will get reloaded
um because it wasn't written into the
cache is the problem
and it should have been written into the
cache or at least the values that were
cached would not correctly update it
which again is coming back down to this
not actually getting me my right tiles
for some reason
and it's not even getting roughly the
right tiles that's the problem
and I'm updating it here all right
and this is all like Yeah by reference
so it should be
correct
and I'm never getting no like I'm not
really getting an old daughter I'm I'm
here
that might be fine am I always getting
old tile data
no tense
but it worked here yeah so I'm the fact
that I'm getting null tile data I'm not
yeah no I shouldn't never be getting
null tiled out of here so that actually
is wrong
but I'm not sure why I need this this
minus one
for the chunk chord maybe this is stupid
having this weird offset
but it seems to have worked
no I tell that as a class
um
foreign
but this does seem to be correct because
it's that's just the chunk coordinate
and I guess it is getting me my right
one
okay I think we do what we did before
and we bring back highlighting
um
no how do you do this and see Sharp
is that just that
no
I don't know man
um
Okay so
but instead of getting the player tile
let's kind of do the well oh but then we
need to reload but that's okay
um
I guess I actually want something a bit
different
no well let's just I guess we can reuse
this though
um let's do this let's get the tile data
four
where the player currently is so we'll
see if that works from World space to
get the tile data and then FTD doesn't
equal null
we're going to change the material on
the tile data
to be the debug material
um
and we can save the original so we can
put it back if we want
I'm not gonna bother with that to be
honest let's just change it to the debug
material
oh and let me stop this from happening
okay well that Chloe doesn't work
because if I did then we'd be seeing it
oh no I have to press F5 aha look
so F5 so it thinks the player is there
and you can see that does actually
persist
if I move around
which I'm not really even moving around
huh
I mean it's finding the right oh the
chunk is off maybe by one
and lots of out of range exceptions
but that didn't work before did it
because I remember I did say I wasn't
sure about the minus one
okay that is closer man
what I'm moving around oh here we go
it's like it's only working on one axis
what the heck
and now it's out of range
so dodgy
well I feel like the minus one doesn't
need to be there but I feel like this
might be just wrong
oh I'm not doing I'm not doing uh this
kind of offset for this
that's probably why
I think this
oh man
oh
yeah I think this also basically needs
to be offset by that
would that be correct
I feel like that might even be worse
well it's definitely closer but also
what's really weird is that I can't move
this axis it's like it's only working on
the x-axis
no but
I mean that's a bit better maybe but
but yeah I have a I have a feeling I
have to do that because
this will give me a coordinate that yeah
is
centered around zero being the origin
but this
needs to go around
to um like this will uh take it to
being in the right space but it's not
working for some reason
yes I've got the tile now and then I
just do that
and that still gives me a world space
tile so I need to restrict it to I guess
this because there's 16 by 16 tiles so
this this actually makes sense like
right
foreign
actually
um but is it
no no okay this isn't this is already in
tiles
uh but it's yeah but the thing that's
weird about it is it's entails
yeah that's not gonna work I think yeah
this is dumb I'm pretty sure
yeah I think it's plus equals yeah it's
the amount of tiles so this would be
times 16 I think
again not sure
but that seems more correct
no that's just a fallen error
because this is this is the amount of
tiles in the world
um incrementing it by half of that to
get an absolute tile index
why was that causing an index what is
this index out of range thing 422
this how is this out of range
as far as not why it's impossible for
this to be out of range
as long as we have a 16x16 as long as
it's like not null
and chucked out a company now tiles
could be now but
like
if this is 256
which it is
then how can that be out of range
well oh no I guess I guess no no this
would be though
obviously
if it's above that range
so I actually think that's this is wrong
yeah this is right uh this probably also
should be more than for this case
Maybe
maybe that's why I was never working oh
yes
no
that almost worked it stopped working
when I possibly left the
thing
it only works for the first chunk
which makes me think the chunk index is
wrong look it only works for the first
chunk
but that does work
and I have to hit F5 to uh reload the
chunk that's why it's like doesn't
appear instantly
trying to love your action vids thanks d
ude appreciate it
um
so what does that mean the chunk is
wrong the chunk chord is wrong
but it's right for the first one that
doesn't mean much
yeah why is that wrong man
actually
so chunk dad is already null
I don't know it was for the other one
because it's not constantly printing
that
but look it's not
setting this anymore but chunk data
isn't null
why is it not working for
oh look it's made some over there
oh man
maybe this is wrong
I have a feeling it is wrong
oh
maybe it's mod 256.
divide by 16.
would that be good no I doubt it
oh that ruined everything didn't it
but the X also does jump so
maybe that's not right
I should have come up with a better
system but it's possibly too late now or
it would be annoying to me right now
so if I have my chunks
and I have a coordinate
inside a chunk
I need to be able to find the local
space of that
I guess that's what I should do here
yeah I think this doesn't feel right to
me
but
um
because the thing is it's really easy to
find the ax but then to find the Y
how do how do I find the Y then within
this cell
if I have the actual coordinate as a y
right
obviously that's in terms of
everything
oh man
oh
I think I would have to
subtract
so that's a y right I'd have to
basically
well that's in a way that's what I'm
doing by doing mod 16 I'm seeing where
it is
within the thing but then the problem is
that I have to
does that make sense though
like if I
yeah no no that's right so mod 16 gets
me
the local coordinate no matter what
right
if I have a global coordinate and it's
divided into cells and I do mod 16 just
like with the X I get a little
coordinate but now
if I want it
but that's in a way that's what's
happening
yeah so this actually should work
um no but the thing is it does work
actually it's just that
it works within one chunk
but then when I go to the next chunk it
doesn't work which again makes me think
it's more of the chunk problem
then what I'm trying to do
but I don't know if that's necessarily
correct either
because see this does work and I can go
anywhere in here
and it will paint the tiles that I've
been on but as soon as I exceed the
chunk it stops working
and I feel like that's because oh well
not that it stops working see it's doing
it in another spot
which makes me think
that it's like
but there are only like if we look at
the chunks
oh look
actually no I'm still I'm still supposed
to be within this chunk
I haven't I thought I left the chunk
boundary but I haven't left the chunk
boundary I'm still here
what
and look now it's working here so it's
almost like it's
offset to the middle of the chunk or
something oh no but that's right as well
I think it leaves this it I think
it thinks I've left the chunk I think is
what the problem is
and it's suddenly getting tiles from a
different chunk so this chunk chord must
be wrong
I don't know how though
unless like again the minus one maybe
needs to be there but I'm pretty sure
we've tried that and it didn't work
yeah see so minus one
means I'm in a completely different
chunk
so it's not minus one
looks like it might be like a rounding
error as well
so this just adds 35
to get it to that but this could be like
a rounding thing
but we do floor to end
we divided by chunks so we take the
position divided by chunk size
we do have this weird offset but that
seems to work
oh man I don't know
kind of sucks what if I don't floor it
what if I
what if I use ants
because I am around the origin so it's
possible that something something it's
negative or whatever that ruins it I
know
Maybe
no
so same situation at like halfway
through the chunk I think it decides to
jump me to a different chunk
is what seems to be the problem and that
actually looks like the origin
so basically it stops working for the
origin
um
oops
can I just
like
you are on chunk
chord
so I'm on 3535 at the moment
and see he thinks I'm on 36 now
but
guess what
I haven't left the chunk
but you know what doesn't make sense
though
the fact that
well no I mean we treat chunks
differently when we talk about it in
terms of player like the player and
which trunk the players on
let's go back to this I mean I'm pretty
sure that does like the same thing
so yeah so thinks I'm on 36 here
and
I'm not yet am I no
but this is fine because it thinks still
35 34.
but look but the level loaded
so I feel like
that almost seemed to work because it
did look at the level
no here I actually I'm on the boundary
look I have moved to the next one
so that's possibly a bad test
I don't know where I should go like
I guess I'll try and go the other way
yeah 36. so this thinks I'm on 36 I
don't think the level loaded though
yeah I am here
I am here I'm in the middle of the chunk
apparently this is chunk 36 but it's not
this should be chunk 3535 it's the one
around the origin
so it looks like again it looks like
it's an offset
um
it's like it should be
but that's weird
why would that be happening
this offset is not uh half a chunk it's
offsetting it's converting it from um
is converting it from uh being from
negative 35 to 35 to being between zero
and like 70 or 0 and 69 or whatever
um that's fine that's map with chunks is
how many chunks there are not the size
of each chunk
like I don't know we could
it's just strange to me that the chunk
it thinks I'm on
is like
why would it change halfway through if I
is it when the player goes from
like
uh it's some other way
so that might be okay but
I wish I had a way to say which way I'd
go
but um
I feel like
yeah oh no it happens before I go
negative see
because I thought it happened when I
went negative but I'm positive
1.16. although maybe that does get
offset to be negative
um let's do this so chant chord
offset pause
let's try this
yeah I think it's one I go negative
because actually this is still uh well
this is negative now as well
no that's too difficult to see
so that's all correct correct correct
correct
correct correct
correct correct this is all correct
until I get to this boundary
which uh
that's that I don't think that's
actually anything
I think it's to do with my X position
though because the reason why that was
correct for so long was probably because
I was moving mostly in that direction
but nana jumps out of there why
why can't you just work
35.
so strange
the only thing I can think of is
obviously like chunks or single points
like there are two dimensional
coordinate
and then we have to be within a chunk
and if we're anywhere within the Chunk
we should floor it back down to that
coordinate which is what's happening now
if we're negative then that's what's why
we use floor so that it again jumps back
to this coordinate and doesn't go to say
this chunk but that's wrong
that's why I feel like you should cast
it to an INT instead
because
you know if you're within this positive
space
then you go down to here oh no sorry
that's not that's why we don't cast the
twins that's why we floor it so that we
go back down here and we don't go back
towards the origin because then
otherwise if you're in if this is zero
then the four uh chunks around you would
all say that there are zero zero because
you'd cast down to that
so we are flooring it so we are going it
to where we are going like to this guy
to this guy to this guy now the other
complication is that
um
I unfortunately made a decision well to
make it kind of Center like to make the
player in the Orange is born in the
origin and all the chunks are around the
player which means which is fine it just
means we need to do a little conversion
to go from like okay if the player is at
zero zero for example what chunk is that
in the array and the thing is it's not
obviously zero zero in the array it
would be like you know if we have 0
through 69
um it would be basically plus the width
times two which is 35. now is 35
actually correct I think so
I think 3535 would be the right chunk
for being in the origin so in other
words this is 35 35
this would be 34.35
and it should only transition when you
go past here basically
um and that way that works is we have uh
your tail position which is basically a
world's best position and you just
divided by the trunk size and then you
floor that
so if you're somewhere here like 15 and
you divide it by 16 and you get 0.8 you
floor it if you're I don't know negative
5 on X and positive 6 or whatever you
divide that by 16 you get like negative
0.3 or whatever
and uh positive 0.3 let's just say and
then you floor that so that this goes
back down to
being chunk zero and this goes down to
being negative one
so you become negative one zero which is
the right chunk
because you're in this like chunk or
whatever but again that negative one
zero what does that become that becomes
34 35 which again should be the correct
chunk
could it be ceiling in One Direction
before the others no I didn't think so
at least it shouldn't be
um so yeah so that should get me
that should that should be showing me
the right
um
like I don't know why that's not giving
me the right chunk but again it's almost
like it's specific because everything's
working like the the general the terrain
generation is working great it's just
now that I have like a bit of a cache
that's not working it seems
thank you
um we could also do a little experiment
like if I make this much smaller so it's
it's five it's 70 by 70. right now uh if
I make it like
which actually maybe that's the problem
the fact that it's an even number
what if we make it 71 by 71.
I mean
oh look that instantly breaks it
huh
but look it kind of no it does jump
still
man this is so bizarre like look at it
it also looks like it's getting further
and further away though
which makes me think it's like we're
multiplying by something
uh let's reduce it to five five or
something right
that doesn't work like we're there but
we've only got 505 chunks
or even we could even just be like all
right you know what let's just make it
three by three because that's the
starting size that's that's the amount
of chunks that are visible anyway
right so let's actually that's a good
thing like why am I dealing with such
big numbers let's just do let's let's
kind of go with this why am I able to
move
oh because
this mean the camera is locked oh it
does
oh that's so dumb that's like what I
wanted to avoid
it's funny
whatever
um
okay so it thinks I'm at drunk Ward one
one
that's
wrong I should be at zero zero
okay so does that mean that
no but hang on I should be at zero zero
because I'm in this chunk here
oh no I shouldn't be a series right no
no I should be at one one because it's
zero zero but it's
it's 1-1 because this is the whole map
now I've made it tiny
like this is basically the whole map
So within this entire chunk
I should be staying at
that position so let's try and move this
way
and see now it thinks I'm at 2-2
which is incorrect because
the player is at 16 25.
oh no hang on
oh guys I made a blunder
I made a serious blunder but I know what
it is
I divided this by the chunk size which
doesn't make any sense because the chunk
size is in terms of tiles but tiles are
not one by one
so I need to divide this
by a chunk size times two and this by
chunk size times
uh two okay I'm sick of these like magic
weird numbers everywhere so I'm going to
make another thing
I'm gonna make a
uh public
let's do
um
tile width public float tile width and
that's going to be two time and that's
just gonna be two
and then we'll have tile Heights
which is this so this is the size of
each tile
so this needs to be divided by a tail
width
and I really should just make that uh
equal
and tile height because obviously I need
to
like I need to get from um
to figure out the chunk award it's not
just the chunk size I need to like know
the world units basically so I think
this should work
I I did in play mode which doesn't work
anymore
okay it's still not really working
because I'm offset but
let's see so thinks I'm at one one
which is correct
let me highlight the chunk
thinks I'm at one one and now I change
to one two
so that's correct on that axis
let's go this this way
and yes one two
I just fall off the wild I did
wait what the heck
why are there gaps in the world
that's never happened before
oh that's really scary
oh there aren't here oh it's when I hit
a five the ride that's fine
that's probably just something to do
with me being bad at programming
um
I think that's because I was probably
doing this incorrectly in other places
as well
yeah see here I was doing it get chunk
index I should just use this this is
doing it correctly as you can see
so this is doing it by a chunk size
times tail width and tile height
and this should probably use the tile Z
tile offset
not that we're ever gonna attempt to
change the you know
tiles
um I was going to set up a timer for the
jam ending but that was too difficult so
I stopped uh it's like if you go to
ldjam.com you can see but it's like
maybe 20 hours probably a bit less
oh no it's about 20
how is it 20 hours 30 minutes I think
um
okay I'm getting somewhere though
Maybe
so see this is also dodgy
but this is used for like everything so
oh but it gets multiplied by two so
that's fine this is special okay cool
um all right so now it's kind of like
I'm I seem to be in the right chunk but
my tile coordinate I guess is wrong
but I'm always in the right chunk it
seems
I'd say that's weird
so it's also not it also doesn't seem to
be riding into the right position as far
as
um
either get tile dot like it doesn't seem
to be working
because
unless create tan smash messes with it
let's comment that out so no tense for
us
okay
that has stopped
yeah so it was great it was the other
thing that wasn't working all right so
okay cool so now I need to figure out
why I like seeing the chunk highlighted
it's useful I need to figure out why I'm
here
and it thinks I'm offset by
I don't know what that is like half the
chunk or something
let's move the player a bit
does it go into the next chunk oh it
wraps around
because I'm in the same chunk
what the heck
yeah that's weird
um I guess it just needs to be offset
within the chunk but
you know why
oh or is that what I'm doing here which
shouldn't be done
no that needs to be done I'm pretty sure
oh maybe not
yeah that stops working after a while
maybe it needs to be done in one axis
for some reason
what the heck
wait so is that working or not
I thought it wasn't for a second yeah
see here it's not working
um
and that's just because I guess I've
exited the chunk but it thought I went
back to that chunk
are you serious
is it still drawing it somewhere no
oh look index out of range
chunk hold zero zero
which I guess should be this one oh look
it's correct zero I'm a zero zero so
what's that a range pause
um
4 30.
oh this is out of range oh I guess
that's why I had this
but that was somewhat breaking out
and what was the purpose of this again
it was to get
I guess it was good to get this not to
be negative or something
but this means it's out of range how can
this be out of range though
what happens if you do -16 like minus
something mod 16. I could just do the
absolute version of it
right
maybe that would be better than this
because if you do that maybe you need a
floor it or whatever
yeah I feel like that might be the one
of the issues
might be rounding errors
oh it is flooring it though here
yeah I think I think that's fine I think
I can just um
like let's just
basically
do this
I think
crashes in play mode as usual
this should Pro I imagine this should
maybe work
no it stops after a while
oh and it's out of range again what
oh wait Florida ends is not what I meant
I wanted to do abs
okay so this should probably work no no
how dare you
again index at a range what
how
how is this how could this possibly be
out of range
oh I left the Florida ends oh come on
man
fifth time lucky nope it's wrong it
seems to be
um
like a little bit correct what is wrong
no but hang on
no that's not right either because
so if the tile coordinate
so let's just say this is our world
we're around here this is technically
zero zero
negative one negative one like whatever
if I go into a negative Direction then
my
value is going to be negative it's going
to round me down to this chunk but then
within this my coordinates
my coordinate technically would be
negative
so let's just say I'm right in the
middle or let's just do like
I'm over here so what would my
coordinate be well the world origin is
zero zero which is actually here this is
just the chunk so the world origin is
zero it's here so therefore I would be
size of Chunk 16 so I'd be maybe like at
28 negative 28 or something
so if I want to find out where I am here
this is the this is the problem I think
if I want to find out where I am here
um it's negative
but I
um can't just mod this
because if I mod this I'll get like what
12.
right
I'll get negative 12 if I'm mod negative
28 but if I ABS that that takes me to
here
so I kind of need to be like maybe if
I'm negative I do 16 minus 12 to get me
to 4 because that's where I am as far as
the chunks concerned
um
but if I was here
and I'd be
oh sorry here which is positive 28.
then
I would mod I'd be you know mods which
would give me 12 which actually is
correct so it's correct when it's
positive but when it's negative it needs
to be subtracted from 16 is basically
the thing
I'm pretty sure uh I don't know why this
was not this was an index out of bounds
though because it should have still
given me a valid value
but basically I guess I could just say
if
let's just do this let's do tile core
dot X Mod equals 16.
and Y as well and then we could just say
if it's negative
we flip it
okay so that works for this part and it
stops working as usual and again it's an
index out of range the thing that's
bugging me is this index out of range
because I just don't understand how
that's happening
so it's saying this is out of range
but how
so let's go negative or whatever
oh it's 22.
ha
how
what the heck
bro this is cooked
is there something weird with the
modulus operator when it's negative in C
sharp
because somehow this is getting is
giving me
like somehow this talk what Y is ending
up at 28. and I don't understand if I'm
modding it by 16 how can it be 28.
wait
but if it's negative and I'm doing 16
minus then of course it would be 28.
wait so what am I trying to do here that
I'm not doing
no I just want to add it
because what was my example I was on
negative 12 and I wanted to get to four
well yeah that's plus 16. okay
may have uh
just had a bit of a slow moment
a senior moment as they call it
all right well now I'm not getting the
errors but it's still not working
man the day I get this working I want to
retire this is crazy I don't know why
this is so difficult
but also like it's weird because my tile
index jumps suddenly like it goes from
zero to 15.
oh but that should be correct if that
chunk is zero
but it's not
like it's in
oh but it thinks it is but it never is
or is it yeah is my position zero then
yeah it says my position right
no well that's all correct but then
yeah that seems correct oh that is
working
okay that's not working yeah I'm on
minus two
so because I've decided to become minus
on this even though the chunk is fine
the minus one or minus two needs to
translate to being
looks like the end of the chunk which is
why it's doing 0 and 14. which would
make sense however it doesn't actually
make sense also why is one of my chunks
missing
maybe I was wrong about my thing
ah
no no no no no no it's not quite this
though oh man this is so stupid I hate
everything
it's not just this it's also
um
I should I don't know why I did this
whole centering thing that's the one
thing I regret I should have just made
everything start at zero
because during I guess like during a
game Jam like don't have the mental
energy to like do extra conversions all
the time
it like the problem is when we go
negative we're not on a chunk boundary
yet
so therefore this is rubbish
oh my gosh this is such a disaster
yeah I know I shouldn't have done this
oh my gosh no I don't know what to do
um
what's interesting here as well though
is that
like we're trying to okay so we're
trying let's just draw in a little
scenario then we're trying to
like here's our middle right
so let's let's think about this
um this is the origin of the world and
the way that it works at the moment is
this is the chunk
I was kind of assuming the chunk would
be here for some reason but it's not
this is the chunk and this is the origin
of the world so if we're trying to find
out an absolute tile index of this
within this I think it's like like the
easiest thing to do is just to pretend
that it was here
either that or we
because again the problem is that so if
the player is actually here we will get
a and 16 is the width of this Chunk in
terms of tiles which in terms of world
units is about 32 on the X at least
um then if we are at
and and it it is smart enough to I think
figure out that your which chunk you are
based on this I think uh that's why we
were seeing that problem before as well
I think that makes sense now now it
makes sense
um but anyway my point is that if we are
at like if it if it determines that hey
man you're at you know four four which
is like right here right in terms of the
the
tile index
then that's not correct
technically like and it does that by by
this card over here
because
4x4 would be correct if you're assuming
that this is where
the thing was right
so it's kind of like
I guess you would just subtract half
from this
and that will give you minus four
right no
well in this case like you kind of want
to add that amount and rapid
yeah I guess you just add half and wrap
it
no the offset World position just half
the offset World position completely
halve it
um no I don't think I want to do that
because this is also in like centered
around the origin
um
so I could add half and wrap it so that
we would at least be within the right
place
here and I think that would work
everywhere right
so I feel like you could just do
Target x equals tile chord X plus eight
mod 16.
like would that not work
and then I'm not really sure about that
whole negative thing that I'm doing
but let's see what this does
um
but what's weird is that again it was
like partially working before that's the
really really weird part about it so I
must be doing this somewhere
but it's just not
happening
somewhere
because if we just focus on tile cord
for a second
because we know which chunk we're in and
I'm pretty sure we reliably know what
chunk we're in
like I could play with that but
like I'm pretty sure that's right
because I've looked at the chunk chords
being printed they're easier to keep
track of when they're printed
um
so let's just focus on the tile chords
so we take this
we divide it by the uh tile width
and so now we should have basically
that's easy we just divided by the tile
where the tile height and now we have
um the out like an actual tile position
so the next step is that's cool
but I want to know where I am within a
chunk
so to do that
again we would simply just mod it by 16
and we'd be done kind of
if our job was just to
um if our job was just to
if like if it was Zero if it was from
you know not centered around the origin
basically
but because it is we have to do some
extra stuff but this plus eight thing
where does that come in because this
chunk because I guess here's the thing
this gives us our tile coordinate
but
um
it's not like it's kind of like a global
tile coordinate where it assumes that
zero is yeah so I feel like this plus
eight should kind of work because like
this should kind of work I'm not sure
about the negatives
let's maybe remove this for a second but
I don't think that's what's causing the
problem
because see if things were over here so
let's just stop for a second why does it
think we're over there that's at the
very end edge of the chunk right
so that's what I mean it looks like it's
like we are
doing it somewhere
and we shouldn't be negative I think at
the moment because player is positive 7
positive 19.
right so if I'm at 7 19
then technically speaking
7 and 19 so 7.6
divided by
um
the size of a tile
which is 2 on X gives me 3.8 which
becomes index three
now the enemies are moving me
I should pause it but I can't it'll jump
they'll jump the camera
um nine yeah okay whatever uh
but the thing is I'm in I'm kind of in
the middle
okay let's just make the enemies not
spawn I don't know why I'm still
spawning enemies
okay this is a nice clean map
so let's maybe take the player and put
him in the origin of the world
okay
so this is round about the origin of the
world
wait that's the origin of the world
maybe I'm wrong with my assumption that
chunks are centered around the origin
then
because that doesn't look like
it's centered around the origin at all
that looks like
the middle chunk starts from here
whoops
so
let's not do that then
at least we're getting somewhere
so that takes it back to it partially
working right
which is which now I'm happy though
because now it makes sense why it
partially worked but then now what
happens is my tile index is negative
which means that doesn't work anymore
um because I kind of got rid of this
so let's put that back
which also kind of stops working but
doesn't seem to
produce an error does it oh it does okay
so still unhappy with the index out of
Range Line 219 oh it's a different place
this
so this is now out of range
um
why
my chunk order is one zero
but it's out of apparently this is out
of range
line 219.
yeah so this would be a minus one so
that the values that will be passed in
here is zero I think and minus one
but it takes minus one
and it adds in half the map chunks which
is
half of three which is one
they didn't work properly for odd sized
things
I feel like it doesn't
yeah the tile the tile is always
positive within the trunk now
I think
well no it always kind of was
um anyway that's not the problem now
no no that is right yeah right because
then I'll I'll get basically instead of
negative one to one I now got zero to
two because I've added one because this
is what this does this adds one
so that is correct but why is it saying
it's out of range
um let's put a break point in and
uh we'll probably crash here
maybe not
okay well that's fine
that's also I don't care
so let's um take the player
and move them I guess negative I want to
go negative Zed
which is I think that way
okay so now I'm negative Zed and if I
hit F5 oh because I had to hit F5 I'm oh
I'm still I'm negative one
because this is at negative two
what
oh cause I'm there
ugh
I think the reason for this is that
there's just no bounce checking I think
there used to be
but there's not any more so this is
actually fine it turns out
um
I think I just can't do it like
we need to check bounds basically here
um
I guess we could just do that easily by
just saying if
SX less than zero or Sy less than zero I
said rather Less Than Zero OS X greater
than
or equal to
this
wrong thing
Alex
how do I sketch on the screen it's an
app called Zoom it
Zoom it
Okay so
that actually works now
ah have I actually done it
or are you just teasing me
you were just teasing me
okay I just went in the positive
direction so now I think I'm negative
and so now I might need my weird
conversion thing although I was negative
before as well all right but it's good
we're getting exceptions which is good
uh
so Line 440 back to line for 40.
so back to this
wait did I
stop doing the mod the modulus thing
what didn't I
I think I I'm just missing this
Maybe
well I mean this shouldn't crash anymore
but
whether it works or not oh I'm negative
yeah I'm in negative
reloading these chunks all day long
I mean that seems to work
okay so now we do something a bit
different we
let's keep the music playing
um
let's go to the map size and make it
like bigger
50 by 50 or whatever
don't really care uh so let's see if we
can generate new trunks
so the the good news here is that we can
mount we can properly modify the cache
now up or not okay index out of bounds
okay good I'm glad we caught that
Line 440 again uh
and what are we
where negative 74 negative 33.
and that's out of bounds again line 440.
so this is out of bounds
why would that be out of bounds
uh hang on it's because
um this this is stupid adding 16 is
stupid
here because it hasn't been modded yet I
think what I was doing before was I was
first modding it yeah that's right
I was first modding it
and then
I was so this is already perfect and
then I was doing that check that's why
so this should now work
or not
so why is that different to what was
happening before because before it was
kind of working I'm just
growing up is what it is what is
uh where's my negative I want to go
negative
player
negative and I mean this works so let's
go negative X
Negative X and we'll keep going negative
Z
well yeah I'm fully negative
chunks are still spawning in
that's probably good enough of a test
right
yep that's good
all right sweet
oh I think that's finally working I want
to probably reward myself with some
coffee
that's true no I want to go to that new
Cafe that makes amazing coffee all right
guys I'm gonna be right back
and have some coffee
enjoy this uh screenshot
I'm gonna be back very soon though like
I'm talking
10 15 minutes
maybe I should write that on the screen
all right see you guys soon
[Music]
thank you
foreign
going on
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
back
did you miss me
how long was that I said 15 minutes was
that
correct was that a bit more
I felt like about 20 but I don't
remember what time I left I guess I'm
gonna look back up live stream
all right so I got this pile of garbage
working it looks like so
um
yeah the real point for this though of
this though
was just to
um that's different isn't it yep
the real point of this
was
just two
uh get the tent ah so now we have to
bring back okay so the tent seemed to
have negatively impacted some of the
generation like I then if I hit F5
oh we don't we don't anymore okay never
mind we used to have hot oh and look the
tents
stays perfect
and that's the remote motion player
because remember how we had holes in the
world and that was very scary
now we don't
right
and you can see the tent stays there and
if I go far enough
for the tent to
disappear
well actually I don't think the tenant
will ever disappear yeah the chunks will
disappear but if I go back
we should hopefully realize that we have
the same and you can see our glowing
tiles have remained as well but we have
the same thing beautiful so let's go
back to having the game as normal
meaning uh to fog is on
where can I dock this just like here I
guess
would be fine because I like it to have
a bit of a bigger View
um
didn't know that was a thing uh and
we'll get rid of the pink tile situation
the debug tile
so we'll just
I don't know highlight
okay so now we shouldn't have debugging
I mean the debug tile thing anymore
um yeah right
so
there should be somewhere in the world
uh it's a tent and you can see now that
the tent is uh
always flat the area around the tent is
always flat and that's important
I also while I was getting my delicious
coffee
I was thinking about what like the main
menu kind of should be like like and by
main menu I mean if we even need a main
menu like how does the game start
basically and I thought it'd be cool
to kind of start and maybe show like an
orbiting camera or they might be hard
with this fog now that I think about it
but show like you know
yeah it would be hard with this whole
biting camera it would be hard with this
fog but I was picturing like an orbiting
camera around the world and before you
hit enter to play you have the ability
to regenerate the world so that way you
could kind of play around with that and
that also tells people that hey there's
this is random
because otherwise like you know you'd
have to like close the game basically or
replay it to get a different world and
someone might not play it twice someone
might just get a stupid world that just
sucks and they might be like oh I don't
know how I can't play this you know
um and then they might quit because yeah
the tenant could have lights yeah the
tent could have lights
let's add lights to the tent I want to
see what that looks like
um that actually might help because you
can see it's very foggy but if the tent
had a light on it you can kind of see
lights through fog so
that might be nice to do
so maybe let's add a point light
it could be like a siren you know like
it could be a flashing red light
that'd be kind of cool actually
yeah let's make it that
um can I make a
what do I want for this a cylinder a
capsule Maybe
sure let's make a capsule
um I'm gonna make a capsule I'm gonna
make it
like this I'm gonna apparent the
tent light
point line
tent lights
I'm going to parent the light to the
light
um
pop it like here
is a bit too big
I was thinking of just having a light
you know like here like that
so it's kind of like let me hide the
icons
so this is kind of what the light looks
like um obviously we need a material for
it materials
which I won one directory
[Music]
um
tent light
I guess I'll make it this
um
so I guess that's what it kind of looks
like
maybe make it a bit smaller
ah but the problem is it will light
inside the tent as well if I make the
radius too much
and then we could make it so that it um
that's kind of cool
we could add a script to it as well
uh what's simple
Ah that's not that's the whole thing
this looks simple this is what I was
looking for
oh no let's get that from
the initial that way we can control it
from the editor
uh speed
hmm
I'll do this at the end to avoid like
performance kind of uh should I even
have to read and write it once anyway is
fine
let's just do it this way
because I'm gonna have to do that and
then if intensity
greater than Max intensity
and it doesn't really matter
um we can do
well first of all we can I guess we can
clamp it we might want it to wait a bit
but uh let's do it let's just quickly do
this honestly there's not much time so
uh let's do a
Min intensity Max intensity
wow it's literally this actually
um and then we'll do speed
times equals negative one
else if
intensity
less than equal to zero
equals zero
and also this
uh and then yeah whatever
speed one up I don't know that'll take a
second I guess to get to Max intensity
update prefab so there's a little
little thing which you can see why it's
nice that doesn't seem ah I need to also
control the material emission but you
could see it through the fog there which
was nice
um but yeah I need to control the
emission I guess as well
um
so let's do
uh
we'll make this public though
we'll do that
material uh
uh um oh yeah that's fine
so I guess that would work right
yeah so you can kind of see over here
you can see it in the distance in the
fog and it's also animating
it's probably too slow though
let's play with the speed
so how's that done nice
that's a bit too fast isn't it and I
feel like maybe it doesn't get intense
enough
anyway this is really really minor
probably stop
let's make it
2.5
and let's make the max intensity like
five
oh this is quite the world
but 10 should be on a flat piece as you
can see
and then there you go that's kind of
nice nice and slow little coffee station
light
that you can kind of see through the fog
as you can see so you can't say the tent
at all but you can see it a lot which is
cool
all right so
I'm done now now I'm seriously done
because the next step is to fix the run
time
and the runtime needs some help
so I guess I'll commit this stuff
uh and I'll actually because Peter and
Tim have added stuff so I'm gonna just
let's do some
interesting
that's useful
yeah stream will be saved
so let's pull
it's okay
asset registry
it's fine
let's compile this
Ron Hazel make sure everything's up to
date and working
I don't know that's my idea
and I can see the pin as well okay well
it does in fact work
where's my tent huh
where's my fog light clearly not that
effective
yeah because on the other side
but there it is all right good
anyway isn't that beautiful having it
like this so that you can uh
like it's just nice and nice and flat I
really like that
wait did I just go through the tent
walls
no I think they spawned
I don't really care about obstacles
Okay so
um that's great let's try and build this
and like I guess we're going to build
the asset pack
uh and we're gonna see so Peter claims
that some of the prefabs
are not actually in the asset pack
um so
let's grab this
so tent enemy prefab
yeah but apparently he was saying that
yeah the one of the prefabs wasn't added
um and it was the
yeah it was the uh the blue one
Something Something Blue yeah so there's
a blue there's a blue hexagon that's
very very important
because it's the main level generator
that's what it uses and as you can see
we have hexagons here and it's an array
of hexagons and one that has gone blue
it's possible to erase of prefabs are
not serialized
um
that's definitely possible
wait coffee tent is null here so how did
that work oh no I'm plenty of the
surface that shouldn't happen
um but we'll deal with that later
where's my
oh it doesn't work anymore the tent
that got on set somehow
fun
uh let's just add these back they're a
tent well yeah yeah yeah and for now all
right let's save
so let's try and build the ice pack
again
uh this this should be okay
I think yeah this is that's fine that
doesn't count as a crash whoops like it
hasn't crashed
um Okay so we've got the outside pack
and it still doesn't have obviously a
blue thing right yeah I think it's
probably just a raise
arrays of um
prefabs but arrays of materials get
serialized because we have
like as far as the hexagon materials
like we have green we have blue we have
red we have all of them right wait
where's the white one
we don't have the white one
oh it's called red
that's why the white one's called red
yes it's here
okay so that's good
um if we go to scene
uh it's good in the sense that
um
yeah so this is the get asset list
function that should be doing everything
so it goes through the script component
and it looks at what's being used
um and apparently it uh ignores a raise
um
but it clearly doesn't quite acknowledge
because materials worked
FPS
so if it's an array
and it's an asset if it's not an array
of its asset so how about we just make
this handle a raise
um I don't know how to do that though
because Peter wrote the array stuff
for the script engine
so if it is an array
what do I do
how do I get the data from it how do I
normally get the data so I asked for the
field storage
is there an array field storage or
something
oh well that's nice
um so let's I guess it's an array
instead which is a field storage base
yeah yeah okay cool
um
and then I guess from this we can just
get the value at a particular index and
we can probably ask it how many it has
I'm guessing
get length okay so this seems to be good
I think
we can do this and we can just be like
you know
we'll call it array field storage
get length
which I don't know if that actually was
a size T no it's a un32 t for some
reason
so that's just length and then we go
through
excuse me we can go through and get the
value at a particular index
and then we can you know do this whole
thing if we want to
so here we assume it's
a uuid which is an asset handle
I don't know why it doesn't say I said
handle but sure
um
and that I think is it
that's basically what we wanted to do
okay so let's let's try that
uh but we do need to make sure it's an
asset actually in our mind so let's do
if
asset
uh thingy
now we'll just do if it's not an array
if it is an array
but field info type
that if it's an array it's an array of a
type so that should be fine I think as
well well we'll see
not a big deal
thank you
I'll just picture
foreign
it's now the last day
yes uh yeah I guess there's like 20 less
than 20 hours left
um
when are you going for food break I'm
hungry I just went for a coffee break
probably food is going to be long I'm
gonna I have some leftovers in the
fridge we made pea menu like two days
ago I'll probably hit them up have them
in a minute but other than that maybe
get pizza or I don't know something else
for dinner in like four or five hours
it's the plan
uh okay so let's try and uh well let me
make sure the tents are working yep
I don't need to see it pop up uh so
let's do build asset pack and now
hopefully we'll actually see more stuff
in the asset pack
um we probably just scan it and see it
but the uh hexagons should be there yep
here they are right so prefab hexagon
red has gone blue they're all in here
now so that's great because uh that's
fixed
um
let me push this out
is that even the name of the function
okay
so I built the asset pack now I might
have to build the Shader pack as well
and then I can maybe run the runtime
because Peter's fixed some stuff as well
and maybe we'll see it work in the
runtime because that's really important
obviously otherwise we can't ship the
game
I should have probably created some
baseline audio as well just to make sure
that worked
so I've done this I mean I'm doing it
again but
71 used assets more and let's do builds
Shader pack and let's do build Sound
Bank even though we don't have any
sounds and that should be maybe good
um maybe not uh and let's try it on the
runtime because I think it should just
work like I I can figure it out
yesterday
Channel I don't know if you read the oh
it worked Channel I don't know if you
read that guys the runtime works really
yep it was easy it just needed like
apart from the stuff that Peter fixed
okay crashed
possibly never mind
anyway
um uh dragon was saying China I don't
know if you read the chat but I'm
curious since you said you removed open
Jail from Hazel you think it's still
worth learning at um
I guess so because I feel like if you're
just starting Graphics programming it's
a little bit difficult to get into
uh you know
Vulcan or DirectX 12 or whatever
immediately like
I don't know it's it would yeah
like I don't know I can't I can't say I
can't say I would ever use opengl these
days though but again that's because I
am probably on a different level to you
like I've been through the opengl life
and so it's kind of like
like you know I wouldn't but that
doesn't mean you shouldn't
if that makes sense
uh one from what I understood opengl is
much more simple than Vulcan yes it is
so learning it is a good someone easy
password on a sound Vulcan I wouldn't
say it's a good path to understand
Falcon it's just a good path to
well it's good if you want to learn like
the theory more or less the theory and
the techniques of Graphics like you know
it's kind of like saying
it's kind of like you know you don't
need to necessarily buy the best
equipment immediately to start learning
something in life you know you can just
start you know like if you want to learn
photography you don't need to buy like a
medium format Hasselblad like expensive
camera you can just start with your
phone or whatever
and learn more about like how do I
compose photos how do I you know what is
exposure how do I control that you know
how do I want to like how what effect
does shutter speed have on the image or
whatever right you can learn those
techniques kind of first and it's much
more simple and it doesn't you don't
need too much to get started
um
and in fact you'll probably be
overwhelmed with
a more kind of complex camera but
yeah like that's what I would say
but obviously like you know if you see
other people using Vulcan and DirectX 12
and not opengl like that might just mean
that they've you know they're they're
their goals and their current situation
is different to you it doesn't mean that
they're
they uh it doesn't mean that you should
also make the same decisions as them
I'm running a debug build now
which is painful but it does work so
something happens when it tries to
destroy physics oh but also look at the
Shadows oh but that's fine I think
that's because I'm overriding the
settings incorrectly
so this is what a debug build looks like
guys this is why we don't
use debug too often
but I'm hoping that it will give me more
information when it tries to destroy a
body
why was it even destroying bodies
oh here we go
so but it's weird because this doesn't
obviously yeah it's to do with Gerald as
well
you know what Peter has um on on Peter's
stream he has like hazel crash counter I
should have
bloody like physics crash counter
because for me it's like 90 of crashes
are in physics
jolt crash counter
that will
I mean entity handle uh this like this
does look like a valid entity
and it's part of a scene and everything
and I'm pretty sure in Destroy entity we
actually make sure that the entity is
valid
um so like it's almost certainly
there
but this isn't happy because
but why this is a weird isn't it
oh maybe the entity isn't valid because
I think entity.get uuid is not valid
therefore
I don't think the entity still exists
but register registry of the destroy ncn
wait hang on where are we exactly
oh we're destroying the entity in
in the entity component system and
that's calling on Rigid body component
destroy aha if m is added to say in
return well that's why it works
that was why it works in the editor
um I might tell Peter about this but I
don't I actually don't know if this is
necessarily a physics issue but the
problem is I guess the entity here what
seems to have happened is this entity
may have actually already been destroyed
because we're actually trying to destroy
it
like we are inside the we've given the
command to destroy the The Entity here
but then we have a signal that that we
set up through the entity component
system to let us know but truly wouldn't
have already removed it from the
registry and all of its components right
that's it because then we can't actually
do what it's supposed to do and get uid
fails because that entity isn't valid
anymore
so I don't know if this is
Peter's fault unfortunately
um so rigid body can accent yeah so this
is on Destroy so let me just Google this
and see if
um this is in fact correct
like if this on Destroy function if this
like I mean
yeah listeners remember worked before
the components removed this makes sense
so therefore it is some weird problem
and I'd expect it to do that because
otherwise like you know
so then if that's true
but also I'm confused why does this not
happen in the editor
could we not destroy bodies in the
editor
okay let me get Peter up
let's see if he picks up do you guys
think he'll pick up
let's see if he picks up
Peter Peter Peter Peter Peter
you picked up
nice
um you've been good today with that uh
okay so basically the run time is
working
almost
um because uh you haven't been paying
attention to my stream have you
no okay let me uh share my screen with
you and I shall show you basically
um it works until it goes to a new chunk
I think because it tries to destroy uh
body
well not it's not really it's not
necessarily the physics it might not be
the physics system but I just wanted you
to see this anyway you can see my screen
yeah
so it crashes because basically the call
stack is we're trying to destroy an
entity The Entity uh gets destroyed like
from the registry which calls the signal
and calls the on Rigid body component
destroy function because we're trying to
destroy an entity that has a rigid body
I guess a rigid body component
um this doesn't happen in the editor for
some reason which explains why it
doesn't crash in the editor potentially
I don't know why this doesn't happen in
the editor like why why doesn't it we
don't have a body
like the the actual physics but it
doesn't exist in like a normal editor C
oh this isn't run time yeah yeah sorry
you're just editing the scene so this
does happen then in the uh when you're
playing the scene
yeah yes okay that makes sense all right
well that's interesting then but anyway
the point is this doesn't work why
because
um well it to destroy the entity it
tries to get the uuid from The Entity
but apparently that doesn't exist
right uh uh and it's like what I can
imagine is that it's either been
destroyed twice somehow
because obviously like this like I
looked it up and just because I mean I
was sure it wasn't the case but if you
do hook up in a like a signal throw and
Destroy they are invoked before the
component has been removed from the
entity which of course is good because
otherwise it wouldn't really be useful
so it that should be fine but it can't
find the uid which means clearly that
entity isn't valid but in terms of the
call stack like you know it looks valid
it's got a handle of 2400
um like I don't see why that wouldn't be
valid like it's not like some memory
corruption or weird situation
and could have like it could have been
removed from the end register I guess
well but but no but I also don't think
that's the case somehow because we're
currently removing it from the end
registry this is the call stack we're in
here and I believe if it was already
removed and would have told us hey that
that's not valid
yeah and I'm in debug by the way
yeah but also it doesn't happen in the
I it doesn't happen in the editor
that's so bizarre that it doesn't happen
in the editor considering it should be
the same code path
um
yeah I don't know well that is
definitely a very strange bug
yeah it's really really weird
I mean I guess
um uh could you go into
the orangebody destroy callback
uh the actual like callback and scene
yep
physics saying seems to be working
2 352 Russian bodies
that's a few yeah that's why that's
performing by my standards now they're
they're nothing well yeah because yeah
but
um
which by the way I mean I know not
everything is a rigid body but it's
that's very close to the 2400 of the
ncid
yeah
so I yeah
that further proves that that ncid is
probably valid
yeah like apparently it still exists in
the physics scene
but like
no but also we are like it's it's really
strange because clearly we're trying to
destroy this entity like outside of
physics because I don't even think this
is a physics issue it turns out because
like the only reason why I really called
you was because I thought like I misread
this thing and I thought that I can't
find anymore but I thought that um
editor scene meant editor but it doesn't
so I thought I'm like why the heck is
this not working in the editor but it is
I know that there was an issue with
something like this before
structure
the scene Destructor
actually no I think it might have been a
different issue because
yeah I think it was different usually
because we had to clear the registry
before we disconnected
um the call box yeah
they wouldn't be fired that does sound
like a different issue
yeah but like again it's like I don't
even think it's the physics it just
seems like somehow
Again The Entity like really the problem
here is that it's like asserting because
the entity doesn't have a component and
guess which which component doesn't have
the only one that entities are
guaranteed to have pretty much which is
the ID component
so that's really strange but but yet the
entity is valid
as far as I understand
because if it wasn't valid then ant
would be like hey man you've got an
invalid entity
yeah so it would have actually asserted
in and at that point well exactly and
that's that's almost an impossible
situation because how can we have an
entity with no
wait where does it get this entity from
what if it's like ID 0 or something
weird
but no but it's not it's 2400. but like
it well this is coming from a submit to
destroy entity so it's coming from here
yeah go back into that um and look at
even checks here
yeah go back to that destroy entry
function like in the call stack yep
we grabbed the ID what what's ID there
ah oh it's valid
no no no but we haven't oh yeah we do
get uuid yeah and then we do this
that's a good point
so maybe the ID component actually got
destroyed before the callback for the
original body got cold
but how
good question
that's yeah this is a good point because
this would have failed
so that's valid because there it is one
and is that a valid uid I miss I'm
assuming so but we could probably see if
it's in that map
yeah Xerox is asking if we've stored an
entity pointer somewhere but in the
meantime pools and end have been
reallocated
um like I would maybe say that's
possible but I don't think that would
have happened within this because this
should have but like it's in removal man
like this look like this is a bit
suspicious
because it it claims that it
hasn't done anything
and yet
all I'm seeing are the words remove
erase pull like remove P data remove
like
yeah can we trust and here
I'm almost certain that the ID
components being destroyed before
on Rigid body component destroy is
called
because maybe it only guarantees that a
rigid body component hasn't been
destroyed
[Music]
I wouldn't have to implemented it that
way but maybe I did yeah that's possible
yeah let me go back and read that
carefully
yeah
um that's very very strange if it does
that
but that
seems to be what's happening uh where
was it it was the connect thing
so on Destroy
before the component has been removed
and I'm guessing this is the component
yeah I would imagine so oh
but to be honest
this is exactly why I don't like this
like because it's really flaky like
I feel like we should like why have this
whole signal system you know when you
can just be like hey I'm destroying an
entity you know we should probably not
notified the physics system about it
those signals very useful but the
problem is considering how flaky they
seem to be it's their usefulness goes
down basically to nothing at that point
if they had been stable and like
actually work properly or work the way I
expect them to work I would have just
been really happy with them but
it actually cost a few problems during
the development I wonder if there's any
way we can tell and that hey this
component is literally the most
important thing delete it last
like can we set component priorities or
anything like that
post I don't know because this
is a random
um I guess so yeah
I mean it feels like there should be
something I guess like I guess what
happens and why this makes sense to me
is because I guess ant would just simply
go through all the components of the
entity and be like does it have a signal
to call if so call it then destroy if it
doesn't just destroy
and so it's not like it goes through all
the signals first and then moves on to
destroying all the components I think
it's doing it basically component by
component
which would make sense obviously because
that would be better anyway because
entities are just components they're not
really real
so it's not like you have an entity and
all the memory for everything's together
and it's not so therefore you'd go
through
you know you do it this way I guess
yeah and because that avoids iterating
through components twice
so it makes sense but it's also like I
don't really want ID components to be
like that
I guess that's why
the thing is most of those like on
Destroy signals that we have do nothing
and I'm wondering if this is the actual
reason like
someone in the team noticed what was
happening there and just went nope
I don't know is that on destroyed
is well I guess understory isn't really
required but the on construct is kind of
required right now because but that's
fine
um if we create a rigid body component
through C sharp scripts
um yeah we have to like have a neat way
of handling that but the Destroyer one I
guess technically not necessary
foreign
entity
okay I'm just Googling this stuff but I
can't really find anything useful
uh I should just write our own ETS
hmm
but what like I don't know I think it's
fine it's just we don't
have to use these features it's kind of
like C plus plus you don't have to use
everything
I probably shouldn't
they're kind of nice if they had worked
so but see the other issue is this is
happening just for the run time
isn't that a bit lull
that's very weird
why would that happen only for the
runtime
I don't know
very strange
and like you know I mean I'm serious
when I say that it works perfectly until
we get to that point like look this is
the game
it's running perfectly but then as soon
as it has to destroy a body which might
be when those particles get despawned
there you go
so like
this isn't like some this is held
together with duct tape
like it's
working
it's just on this yeah
honestly just going to the destroyed
signal and just grab the code and move
it out into the destroy and the deal
yeah I guess I guess that makes sense
for a game Jam
Pro Edition
and this will just take in an entity
like a normal person
right I was in the process of completely
nuking our gun system
this doesn't even check to see if it's
got a rigid body does it
that's all right though
yeah
okay so basically is that the only play
well the problem is that I mean here
it's happening here but I guess this is
the only place where we destroy entities
should be
so if it has a rigid body component
do this
basically
right yeah once the destroy entity
function underneath it
what does that do call this one
okay
good good and then I'll disconnect the
signal
for now
so I'll say
replaced by
for a lot of them also
just covered out the
um the connect as well for the
Constructor I've seen
which one otherwise uh in the
constructive or in oh this is the
destructor yeah that's the disconnect
whoops yeah I meant this
all right well this should work
according to you
in theory
so I say you're not sleeping
uh not yet all right yeah this gun stuff
done so like the gameplay is there fair
I might grab a few hours of sleep
um so
uh I I don't yeah I don't know if you've
seen what I've been up to but I have
been in a in a horrific place
with the World Generation stuff well no
it wasn't that it was just literally
being able to get like the right tile
because I decided to write kind of like
two different coordinate systems in one
world generator and it just made
everything really really difficult like
I basically regret centering everything
around the origin because it just made
things so much harder
um
but anyway okay this isn't crashing
and what's the FPS uh not amazing 140
sometimes drops to 88. 187 A5 but wait
let's take a quick look stream
um
main thread four milliseconds render
threads seven milliseconds oh oh but GPU
wait five milliseconds CPU only two I
wonder why these aren't combined oh well
we're waiting actually yeah because the
GPU times seven nine milliseconds so
actually we're GPU bound I think but oh
and the main thread is pretty good so
physics is 1.3 milliseconds script
update is .07 so that's amazing
uh so we can we basically got a lot of
we've got three plus milliseconds of
main thread to waste
and I mean the CPU render thread is
decently big I guess we've got like two
thousand two and a half thousand
entities to render that's why
um and they have to be kind of processed
yeah but the GPU is also a little slower
than I would have liked
yeah no well it does it bounces between
four and seven
and I don't even have screen space
Reflections on I think
uh
yeah I don't know
and then when we load the chunk I think
it spikes very briefly
that's okay
it's not too bad and I guess we can
if we reduce the size
we can see that it's yeah the GPU is a
lot faster now
and the main thread why is the main
thread kind of high though
the main thread's like four milliseconds
but the physics is only 1.4 and it's not
the script update so what are we doing
on the main thread I might have to hook
up Tracy
um Okay cool so now that I've kind of
got a list of working though
um uh yes stream the geometry is
instanced
um I want to
yeah so and I fixed the runtime right so
and you're working on the gun switching
you said I think
um
I'm basically just rewriting the way we
handle guns uh to kind of accommodate
some better gun play yep
okay so like two hours I will probably
move on then to generating the General's
tent
uh because that's where we have to go to
um and that's going to be a bit of a
challenge because that chunk probably
doesn't exist yet
it was easy for the initial tent because
it's in the initial set of chunks
and I was thinking I was thinking it
might be cool that before you start the
game
like basically the idea I had was we
would display like you know press enter
to start game
or space to start game or whatever but
then we could also be like press F5 to
regen world and that way you could kind
of like pick your world before you start
that might be fun because that would
immediately tell people that
the world is randomly generated because
I would hate for someone to play this
game once and get like the one in 100
chance of ridiculous Hills and be like
this sucks
um
so I don't know that's what I'm kind of
thinking
but it's difficult to show the world
with the fog
although I guess you could just disable
the fog just for that also did you like
my 10 did you see my 10 situation
yeah you can see my screen right
so I did a couple things I added this
red light let's see
um but also you can see how it's always
going to be flat and it's kind of
smoothly flat so if I regen the world
maybe I'll get something a bit more
challenging
um and the reason why I did the light is
so you can see it see it in the distance
you can see it through the fog oh yeah
that's really nice because the fog this
was back in Forest but when I wrote the
Shader for the fog I made emissive
materials kind of penetrated a bit
um and yeah no matter what the heels are
like you can see the tent will always be
on a flat piece of land and then it'll
kind of smoothly fall off as well so
it's like it's never my point is it's
never going to be like this and then an
immediate jump to here it'll always
gradually taper out
yeah
um
that looks really cool on the normals
uh like the yeah the lighting I mean the
light doesn't make sense no it's because
it's because we don't have shadows but
it still looks cool
The Fading yeah
um and yeah like I have never seen the
tent not work which is good like as in
it not be on flat grounds
so it's always perfect which is good
um
yeah
so I'll move on to doing the generals
tent
uh I'll do the same model for now yeah
yeah I'll just change the color or
whatever in Hazel so you can change it
however you like all of those are made
well I'm really happy that oh yeah and
Peter that I already committed this but
the reason why the prefabs weren't
working was very minor thankfully
um it was
just because
we basically had a check here being like
if not array continue otherwise just not
don't do anything so now it actually
properly checks to see if it's an if
it's an array it does what it used to do
if it's an honorary but if it is an
array it uses the array field storage
which was kind of nice because I didn't
really know how this code worked and I
was like when I was looking at this I
was like I wonder if there's just an
array field storage and there was so
that was really nice to use with no I
didn't like it look at any existing code
or documentation to figure this out
which was good so well done you code
architecture
all right cool um back to it
yep all right see ya yeah
uh Tim do you want any of the leftover
pin menu
yeah I'm about to hit them up at some
point well yeah I was thinking of having
dinner like four hours or something yeah
um okay well I'll go heat them up in the
microwave
it's all those entries inside the tent
they're made in Hazel so you look it's
arranged in Hazel so you can change it
however you like yeah
um actually before I do that
let's get the music back
um before I do that I just want to
quickly
I want to quickly see if I can just tint
the tent color and have it be okay I
don't think it'll work very well because
it's dark
what color do you want to tune to oh
like a different how long to go
now to make textures without changing
anything just textures is super easy
like I can change the color to be bright
pink if you like
you don't even need to bother it no well
it's just if you made this if you made
this texture bright like white and then
you can still have the normals be what
they are and have the yeah if you do
that then I can just make two materials
one of which is just tinted dark
and one of which is not because like if
I
um
and there is the material for this thing
where is it
right
tent material
where's my tent material oh that's
that's in the mesh yeah no do you have
the texture here
not here but okay so yeah you'll have to
do that but the thing is no I actually
don't want to do that because like we're
gonna either lose all the details of the
Albedo or like because when you do a
white texture right so not Pure White
just just with the details
well like yeah all the other channels
are fine but all Albedo details will be
gone and there are some like but why
would they be gone I don't get it what
do you mean I'm not saying make it
actually a pure white texture if that
was the case I wouldn't need you to make
a texture oh just I'm just saying that
the color change the base color to white
you can still have all of your different
things there but the idea is I just want
to multiply your texture with a dark
color like this one to get this result
um and then that way I can also make it
yellow and any other color
so that we're gonna have the General's
tent be the same model
performance issue to cubes uh do you
mean the particles
because I think that's kind of fixed
but also like I don't know if like at
the moment they kind of just spawn
particles randomly I think
like if we look at the particle system
is it in the particle system yeah if we
look here these blood particles just
kind of Spawn as you can see and yes
they do get destroyed but that's also
obviously
um
some work
that it gets done so if we look at um
the particle system and we look at
spawn impact
so root motion player does so on shot
when it gets shot he spawns a bunch
and it's annoying because they're
they're rigid bodies as well which kind
of slows it down a bit
and then if we hit we spawn impact so
yeah
I wonder if if I just return this if I
don't do this
let's build the asset pack let's just
see if this is any that's fine if this
is any uh
worse
so if I were on the run time now or any
better rather
I guess that is better
but also I really want to see
um
where the performance is going I know we
keep generating these enemies which
isn't great but I'm just curious
what is going on
so let me try and open Tracy
uh
and pause
let's get rid of it
Okay so
we are waiting a lot on the round of
thread actually
that's waiting for the update thread
okay so it's actually the upgrade thread
so jolt simulate is like 1.8
milliseconds and then
see an update and then what does this do
submit static mesh yeah the renderer
submission takes quite a bit of time
like this is how much is this man
oh that is a lot of milliseconds
damn so submitting from the main thread
to submit to the render thread is 10
milliseconds for this Frame
I mean it pretty much always is
eight milliseconds
I wonder how much of that is real
because this is saying 12 milliseconds
per frame whereas clearly we did not
have 12 milliseconds per frame and that
was because there's some overhead to
this but I guess we're submitting 2400
entities here but what's actually slow
here I think it's probably
I was going to say it might be the um
because look this is just submit static
mesh
so scene submit static mesh
uh sane submit or what I call it
that's without a space
submit static mesh so this
this is taking a while what do we think
it is
um I mean it's probably the get World
space transfer Matrix which isn't
actually profiled because it's it slows
things down a lot but let's just try
shall we
and yeah it will be slower with
profiling that's why it's kind of like
it's a bit difficult sometimes because
it's it's hard to see like
you know it's hard to see
um what is actually
uh
the problem
sometimes
okay so on render run time
uh and there's that get World space
transform Matrix
so
uh
how do I see
um
like
I want to see how do I see how long this
takes within one frame
so I want to see
this get World space transformatrix
how long that is
within this range or do I have to like
select the range
it's that doesn't seem to do anything
Peter to help me with this
um
limit range
that's cool
yeah so if I limit range
to like this
total time 2.3 milliseconds I mean that
is quite a bit of time
but that's also not all of it like
and we can see here it's not all of it
but
get well Transformer
milliseconds
half a millisecond
so we could probably iron this out a lot
if we wanted to
I know because we know we're aware of
that that's been a problem for a while
but it's just like I guess because it's
an engine stuff we have to go through it
and do all these things which is a bit
annoying
and like it only does that I guess if
it's got a parent because otherwise it
just does this matrix multiplication
which is nothing I guess
why does it even do that
but also we have to see if it has a
parent and like that's another hit
which is why I like yeah I would just
like to have a world transform component
let me just pick out pre-calculate
everything
that's rendering but also like we
obviously yeah there's lots of bad
things we do that we don't really need
to do but this was this is good like
overall I think this game
this game will be a good a really good
stress test and I like it'll be a good
like candidate for optim for optimizing
the engine I think
Jan's just spent the last six months
rewriting the renderer primarily like
using dichotomy as his trust test and
now that it performs well on dichotomy
he needs the next challenge so this will
be it but like this is not the renderer
say the good thing is now that I've done
the renderer like look at the render
thread the render thread is like waiting
for 10 milliseconds like and this is set
this is fully saturated the render
thread is very fast now
it used to be the other around yeah what
I meant is like the next Point yeah yeah
yeah yeah this is my next challenge
optimize the renderer step one step two
optimize the rest of the engine done
all right I'm gonna have a quick break
and get on those pure Mania leftover Pew
menu
um okay
um
[Music]
in America
Stars and Stripes
[Music]
things catch fire
in America
Stars
blind
ly
while she Tangles with little
still be out on the town
when we're loving this hell on Earth
you will see
America
in America
foreign
[Music]
September night
s all right
but it's getting cold
s
too
[Music]
Wanna Know
more than you
[Music]
are
Always by myself
[Music]
Is For Real
but I am changing
[Music]
foreign
all right Lads I'm back
did you miss me
that's what I always say when I come
back
the answer is always no but it doesn't
hurt to try all right so
um
we're doing the tent the general tent
um and there's yeah there's like a bunch
of room for optimization and stuff but
it doesn't really matter it runs I could
try it on
the slightly weaker
QA PC we have with a 3060 and
some worse stuff actually let me quickly
run it again in the runtime
but I just wanted to make sure that I
had more or less the right settings
selected
I don't think I did there so I wanted to
basically
uh
not I did have four here oh but and the
set the shadow settings are a bit bad
here yeah this
this is for a lot of death if you want
let's get rid of that
let's just do default uh one that
shouldn't be default though let's do
minus five five that sure
um now the spec though
is it in the spec or is it it's in the
tearing isn't it
is this what I wanted
not tearing
yeah I just want to make sure it runs
like this because the Shadows were weird
because I was using weird shadows
um
okay so the Shadows are there
uh we should have screen space
Reflections hopefully yeah we do
and what's that yeah decently heavy on
GPU time
and see a few times a bit
a bit high as well
I mean it's definitely playable but also
I have a beefy PC
full screen it's about 100 frames per
second 120 130
um which is okay for a game Jam game I
think
and I don't think we're gonna add much
more that will impact performance
what was that there's like a weird flash
that happens sometimes
I like red flashes
yeah it's fine it's pretty stable
okay
top down
no snow in this level
or is there it's possible there will be
at some point
yeah no performance is good
it's not crashing either which is great
yeah the flashing is super weird the
fact that it flashes sometimes but
whatever
this is just a game Jam game
I am continually spawning enemies but
the FPS is still fine
you can probably see the entities over
here
uh increasing
uh as more spawn in
all right cool that's good enough I
think
it works
especially and it's GPU bound so it
should be faster if yeah this is like
200 FPS
so if you have a bad graphics card you
can just turn the graphics settings down
it's nice that you can look around and
see yourself because otherwise you can't
you can look at yourself in the water
is that me
wait I turned away I think
ah because I should have done
let me find some fresh water
I should have done
this and then rotated that's kind of
high though
stupid cubes
there
yeah you can see the eye
hello
all right cool good
200 FPS
and that resolution
um
so now we go back to this and we start
looking at uh you know what I might
stand a bit
I've been sitting
for basically this entire Jam
won't stand
[Music]
um
and
make I might change the lighting around
as well
all right music and stuff for this game
I was gonna say I might uh yeah I'd like
it's getting dark so I might add some
ambient light in the office
to brighten things up a bit
about whatever
all right so the General's tent
um so
at the moment we obviously spawn
a tent somewhere
which it's a bit annoying because it's
hard to see where
but there's the tent so we have to go in
there get our coffee
um
and then
once we get the coffee we have to also
get the compass and use it to find our
way to the General's tent
which could be anywhere
um
now
how do we want to deal with that
we we kind of want to I think we want to
create so let's do create uh coffee tent
we'll just rename this because
I might as well make two functions I
think
um and create General tense so the
general tent
I'm gonna cop copy the coffee tent at
least for now
okay
with the journal stand yep
yep okay cool thanks
um and then yeah so this is still good
uh but all we really need to do is pick
a location but the thing is we have to
somewhat defer the actual creation of
the tent until later which is good it
should be pretty easy to do that because
this is almost definitely going to be on
a chunk that we
don't actually have right so
as in a chunk that hasn't loaded yet
because what this does is it
specifically finds a chunk Index right
the over here
um
that so that's the kind of world bound
that's yeah that's that bound so it just
does chunk size times three
so that's obviously making it within
this range now what I want to do
is I basically want it to do
instead of times three minus one let's
just have it generate
uh at least a little bit away
so how many chunks away do we want it
ah this is the range this was supposed
to be the range
I'm just gonna yeah generate a values
right away I think
well the thing is this is what I'll do I
think
we can do float times range the range is
going to be much bigger though the range
is basically going to be map with well I
don't want it to be that far away
let's maybe make it
uh
I guess like hey so how how much is too
much like if I is one kilometer I think
should definitely be the the biggest
so
how many how much is that in terms of
chunks
um that's 62 chunks no it's not
is it no no no no no no no
um it's so it's chunk of 16 which is two
so I guess actually it would be
um what am I doing
uh in terms of chunks
yeah it'll be divided by 32 so it's 30
chunks away
let's make it 20 chunks is the limit
so what I'll do is I'll set this
let's just be like
uh Max
chunk
this is the max
this is the max distance I'll say oops
so we have a Max chunk of 20. so
basically what that means is that the
range will think of here
will just be
uh I guess just max chunk
um but we should multiply it by chunk
size I guess so don't worry about this
negative one thing
well we won't worry about negatives for
now we'll just do Max chunk times
the size of
then this is a random range remember
right so this is going to be the upper
limit I guess
and then we want to have a min
distance from the B from the origin of
the world which I think should be like
and this is remember this isn't in
chunks or tiles this is in just units so
because this is what we do to convert it
to units
show up online so it's not the edge of
the world
um
minimum distance okay so tile
let's do
tile width
times
well actually we could even do this by
chunk so like let's just say it has to
be at least two chunks out or three
chunks out so between three and that and
so this is going to be
let's do Min chunk then
uh and Min distance will be Min chunk
times the size of the chunk times the
tile width what should say width
ah sorry this should be just a float I
think
right
that's not constant
I guess because this stuff isn't
constant Maybe
well sure let's not make that constant
all right so we have the minimum
distance
so basically when we do our random
situation well when we do this it has to
be at least that distance so we can kind
of probably apply that in the end
um
but we need to subtract it from the
range
so if that's the minimum distance then
the range
is going to be basically this is the mat
this is the upper range so this is the
max distance really
so we have kind of between these two
things
um and the max distance is going to be
maxed yeah basically the same thing it's
just where adding a little padding here
to make sure it's not at the edge of the
world that's it so we want to number
between these two I think and then we
need to randomly decide
to make it negative or not as well
so this is fine because I think we can
just do
we can basically generate
a random float
um
which can be Max up to max distance
well I guess we'll have to do max
distance minus Min distance times uh a
plus Min distance right
this first
does that make sense
so
uh if we had like let's just say ten and
three so that's seven so we got up to
seven and we got three and then
that's three is the minimum and yeah I
think that's correct
um
so we generate an X and a z
and then we multiply this by
uh
Hazel dot random
DOT sign
and then that becomes
I guess we can just do this
to be a little cleaner
right
okay and so that's our tenth thing but
again here's the thing we can't actually
place it yet we've just generated a
position for it what we need to do is
basically run the placement code when we
build a specific chunk so we need to
figure out which chunk it's a part of
and when we first generate that Chunk we
place the tent basically
foreign
[Music]
so let's determine's private
Vector 3 or whatever uh
General tense
translation
so basically the create General Town it
just does this
right that's all we'll do
um it'd be nice if we could
automatically calculate which chunk
we're in
I think that would be helpful
um
um and that should be easy I think we
can just get the chunk index
from this
so we know what chunk we're in we know
what translation we're in so basically
now when we do set chunk
and this is in fact the first time we go
through this which is here I think we
need to be like hey there's a special
case please generate my
thing
um and then we can maybe modify it as
well so
if
contains General tense
and this could just be
this needs to obviously take in a chunk
coordinate which is
ah but yeah the CX and c I think that's
I think that's all we need
because
what do we when we call set chunk what
do we fit in
we always do that actually
and indexes so we actually do that um
so the index I think is not
yeah that might be bad
like we might have to do this is my
point but that's okay
well we have to
uh
let's see
yes we will
because this is um oh no no it's not
but then why do we do that
because look this takes the world space
position which could be negative divided
by chunk size so we get we actually get
a negative coordinate here
um and I'm guessing to use it we then
have to
well in this case it gets offset I guess
but you can see over here we offset it
as well to get it and yeah so it is
negative and yeah okay that makes sense
but no what doesn't make sense is if we
do apply that here then how come we also
do it here
because
ah but hang on load chunks around index
yeah see look play a chunk get chunk
index from that
is that a bug then and then we basically
load from player chunk but then you can
see oh no no no that's just to load the
ones around the player never mind that's
fine okay so I think we do actually want
SX and S said
um because that's what we use for the
chunk data
but is that really why no but what I'm
trying to do is compare it to that so
actually no we want this
um
so let's just do that and basically
all we need to do is I guess we just
need to do
[Music]
um
General tent Chunk in index
it calls that so that's a quick
comparison but it's nice to write it out
into a function
because
uh it just makes more sense in English I
guess we're trying to be
careful here because it's going to get
light and brains are not going to work
and it's better to make the code more
readable of course
okay excellent so
my last few drops of coffee
uh
what do we do next we do
all right so yeah so if it does contain
the general tan then we need to actually
place the general tent
um
and I think that's where it does the
second part of what we had there
right so
this part
uh and so it's it's just yeah it's going
to be really simple it's going to be
basically everything else here
um
I guess we can do that
like I said we'll adjust this to be at
the tile thing and then we'll go through
and we'll adjust everything else
uh yeah I mean I guess we could
repurpose this no I'm not going to
yeah and that's kind of it and that
should actually work like as in that
should work exactly once
um
let's just see what on Earth happens
I'll stop doing the
what is it load chunks I'll stop
printing the stopwatch
okay I've got another exception but I'm
pretty sure that one's fine I really
should just fix that because it's
throwing me off so
um
wait is it actually ah I guess it'll
place a regular tent there right so that
10 is at minus two nine two so this is
it this is where it's at
so let's uh write that down I guess
because I want to try and get to it
and I could probably like
remove the player there but I guess I
think I'll just walk because
um I have to generate the chunks anyway
okay so minus 292 so we need to go that
way and this is positive
337. okay off we go we're on going on an
adventure stream
we're finding the first ever General
tent
and if it's not there
I'm gonna be very upset
so I can already sense it
and if you want to know my coordinate
it's in the
it's like down there
in the transform okay so we're almost
there on Zed oh no we're not
so we're almost there guys we're about
halfway probably less I mean more this
is a long way to carry a coffee though
isn't it
this game could be expanded to actually
be something quite cool I think
I don't know if I'll commit to doing
that after the jam but
to be honest I kind of like it oh I've
gone way past it
on the Zed Okay so
let's not go anywhere on X but then on
said we need to go back
and then I'm trying to not go anywhere
on x
so 337 we're at 400.
yeah this is a definitely a long way to
carry coffee
so it should be in this direction
oh guys look at that light in the
distance I did it
okay this isn't quite flat it's actually
pretty close though
it clearly tried it just didn't quite
work for some reason
but we did it
we actually managed to place a tent
another 10.
I guess that doesn't have a physics
collateral
that's amazing
I'm very happy that it was there I'm not
upset I was wrong uh this is fine I
don't really care about this I would fix
it if I had time but I don't know if
that's the best use of time
um we could try again
I just don't want to walk that far I
mean look we could just uh make it
obviously not as far I mean I think that
is kind of far
let's for now
it was 20. let's make it like 10.
so that's much closer that's at 170 187
. we'll do this one more one more time
and then I'll stop wasting time
I'm trying to go negative X where it's
negative X
so negative X and 187 so positive Z
and you'll have a compass guiding you I
guess this is still far like you don't
want to walk that far do you it's going
to become a walking simulator
I mean it'll be more interesting enemies
won't just spawn behind you but still
what was it one minus 170 positive 187
okay we're almost there
I've got that an all 10 thing happening
oh maybe it was on a boundary that's why
oh see that's very bad
um okay I believe the reason why that
happened though
I think I might be wrong but I think
it's because we're on a boundary
um
can I not jump to the player
that's not good
wait why is there another tent here why
oh did I start with a tent
wait where's where am I
wish the camera would be where I am
because I actually know where I am
where's the player oh there I am okay
quickly fly down
all right so what what happened here why
is this on a trunk boundary I just want
to know if that's the answer
um
yeah it is
it's on a chunk boundary but it was low
it's a loaded chunk boundary
but yeah you can see it's right at the
edge of that chunk
ah it's possible it just didn't yeah
okay that's fine that should be an easy
bug
um I think it's just that
uh this plays General tent situation
like it should happen
it should happen on the last chunk index
basically
so it's just basically what should
happen is if we're low if we're doing
load chunks around index if any of them
uh ball contains ten let's do this this
is a bit a bit of a
hack Maybe
um
but we could just make it work for the
game Jam so uh what I'm kind of doing is
I'm just seeing
and we used CX there didn't we
why can't I save this
what the heck
why is it doing save ads
there we go no
wonderful
um anyway
let me just make sure that we're using
can't save the file man
uh yeah
we are yes we are
um here's what we're gonna do
because I want it only to happen if it's
in this Branch basically
um
yeah and so what we're going to do is
we're going to continue Journal 10 we're
going to check each coordinate
okay now I can save it that's funny uh
we'll set it to true no just like that
because I'm going to set it otherwise
and then basically
um
if I equals on the last chunk right
so if I equals that minus one no no
maybe that's why I couldn't save the
file yeah because I'm out of disk space
that's funny is that Peter again drawing
ruining me
um probably
anyway to finish this thought though uh
chunks minus length minus one then we
do contains General 10 otherwise we do
false right so if it does contain it
we'll do it just on that one
so that way we do it at the very end is
basically the the point I guess
and that should be good right
what's wrong with you
but that's only if any of them contained
this that's all
okay I need to prep some disk space
foreign
destroy that view for a bit
I bet it's Peter's stuff again the jolt
debugging or whatever
yep it's the jolt captures I told jolt
not to capture and it's still capturing
okay they're gone it's okay we've got
another 80 gig
to work with
can I save my file now hopefully so why
is this not uh true is that really the
case
no argument eh
that's uh a little bit not true I think
what the heck
set chunk does take a bullying you
fern
what
is this just like
yeah this is drunk I think
Maybe
oh no it's this one LOL
uh let's just make it false
okay ah it's a bit of a hack like I'm
not happy with the code per se but I
don't care because
uh that's fine
because this is game jam and we're in
the last day of it so
all right so where's my tent there's my
first turn
which should be good
and I can get in there which is good
that's important and this is a hilly
terrain this would be a good test minus
so 122 110.
should just make the player move a lot
faster for debugging I should know
okay so I'm moving
122 110.
I don't know if that worked okay
I think that just happened to work
I don't know if that actually worked
because this null tent is the problem
like I don't like that it's saying null
tent
null tent means that that's a bad thing
I'm pretty sure
like it means that it couldn't find
a tile
and that's sus because
like if we take a look at where we are
yeah see we're on a boundary again
but it should have waited it should have
that tile there
okay well whatever
um I don't know I'll just say that works
for now uh one thing I could try as well
is at the moment
that's fine um
with the general attempt we're still
like let's just do like
three and five or something I don't know
we're gonna make it pretty close
let's see if we can get one that's
actually at three or something
98 103.
looks kind of tight
see this was an all tent for our tent
because it's close to the boundary I
guess
but they are all working like they're
all playable it just results in very
weird looking terrain I think when it
says in all tent so that's the important
thing
uh but if but I guess if there are
mountains you might not be able to get
in that's kind of the issue why this is
a flat one
okay so let's try this one minus okay
yeah so this one's fine
that's fine and minus 118
yeah they're still they're still so far
I mean I guess it's only 100 meters
um
where's the player
the compass will help
I should have just implemented that now
because that would have just been made
debugging a lot easier as well anyway
we're about to see it soon
come on tent
okay we're definitely there on the ax
but then the Zed
should be about here
uh it was minus
oh how did I not see that negative sign
all right
this way we go
walking the wrong direction come on
stomping the enemies yeah that would be
really cool I think I might want to do
that yeah
I went to
went too far in the Zed
minus 118.
okay I should be about here
do I see it no
um 119 104
uh
where's the Tamp man
that's supposed to be like right here
minus 118
104.
oh no what happened where's my tent
I've only got 110. it didn't spawn the
tent and then our reference is not
related
what
minus 118 104.
yeah
that's where I am
did it not somehow realize that it had
to spawn a tent there
and I don't see any errors
what that's not good
is this the right coordinate to ask for
that it should be
because it's also I'm pretty sure it's
the yeah because well we passed that
coordinate into set chunk
and then we used that here as well
and yeah we only do it if we're in here
which is not the cached version
that's the generator generating version
and we're told to only do it at the very
end
that's us
and this should do it on the last
iteration
and obviously if any of the coordinates
here
contained General tent
if none of them did it's always false
boy that's not good can you spawn the
player at the location of the tent I
mean I guess so
that's very very very strange though
like I guess it just didn't it doesn't
think that the tent is there or whatever
like it must not have
figured out that
that this is the chunk that contains the
tent
right
um
where does it log
does it log anything here
because when it decides the location
so that's what that's what it deemed
I mean it could maybe this failed
like let's put a breakpoint in here
uh I should probably build this as well
that might cause a that'll probably
cause Hazel to crash
yep oh no that's not a crush
all right
um
so it placed it at minus 109 112 right
so let's try and walk there
so minus 109
112 they always seem to be in the same
place which is weird I know I limited it
from three chunks though to five so it's
not a huge range
maybe it could be like two chunks
because we only really have
yeah I think it should be closer
potentially but anyway
minus 109 112. so that's minus 109
so
let's go this way
and I'm guessing we won't get it
oh look it's trying to place it
so what happens here well it looks like
it does place it
okay let's just uh hit F5
so it placed it somewhere close by yeah
there it is
I was kind of hoping it wouldn't place
it again because now I don't know
what the dealio is
I guess it's possible that due to us
being
not good people
um
and getting the uh
that fine that the way that we find and
find tiles is a bit weird
uh and so what that means
so let's put a breakpoint back
um and where is this this is a minus 108
112. why is it always at literally the
same place
like come on how is that possible or
even like it's it's always basically
it's always positive
Z and negative X as well like how does
that happen
sorry plus negative X and positive Z
how does that happen and I'm that that
being said I'm going to positive X wow
they built a wall go away
surely increase the player's movement
is that a thing
no there's no speed here
for some reason
it's probably tied to the animation
speed actually
look at this Tim look they've formed a
horde
look this is the delivery that's pretty
cool
I'm lowering them in yeah
no I'm a bit lost where am I minus I'm
almost there but I'm very not there on
Zed
it does look like a wave
that's funny
they're kind of cute
yeah
okay look it's Play It's placing it
there it is
that's pretty cool
wait is it placing it again
can you just go away
did it try and place another one
why did that trigger twice that's like
not possible because it should be in the
cache
yeah it plays two tens at the same
location
what that's not possible though
at least it shouldn't be
because um
I mean we could easily block that but
like it shouldn't be because that means
that
set cassette chunk right if we're in
this Branch it means that there's no
chunk data yet
so how is it possible that we got in
here again and we like how is it
possible that we ran this again
oh that's dodgy
oh Peter I just saw your call request
sorry I've been too deep into it
nah
damn he's really been calling me a lot
okay I'm calling him now
what's up
sorry I was very deep in the general
tent placing
yeah I figured
yeah
um so I got I have like the new Gump
um functionality working yeah
nice
it has like lower per bullet damage but
if you stand close enough you can insta
kill if all race hit the enemy okay
um you can't like hit multiple enemies
at once
um
the sniper currently does an extreme
amount of damage and just insta kills
but it has a long cooldown
yeah um the assault rifle has a very low
cooldown but also very low damage
uh-huh we'll have to tweak like all of
those values
but I can start showing you there's some
slight bugs to fix but
most of it
is functioning at least
right yeah that's pretty good that's
good I like the word functioning
yeah function is good so first of all we
have
got gun you can see like the race starts
at a weird place
um
but if I just
did the muscle Flash oh no the muscle
flash is working
uh I guess I'll wash and wash your
screen
wash my screen what
what
I was I wasn't looking at your screen
before
oh
okay
um but yeah so like yeah that looks cool
you can basically get a random weapon
and it'll drop oh yeah oh nice and the
they look like guns now
how's the shooting like how what do you
think of the
controls and stuff
I don't know like I think with the new
kind of gun mechanics it's interesting
enough it kind of feels a bit like Doom
at least when you have like the shotgun
that was a successful game though right
yes yeah I'd say so I think we've made
the next do remember let's go
and you can see assault rifle we may
need an epilepsy warning on this
um
this has very rapid fire rate um
but it it feels
relatively nice
now of course the player currently can't
die and I don't know if we're gonna add
that
just the coffee spilling I think
so what happens when you run out of
coffee do you have to go back to the
tent
so
no no I'm talking game Loop wise
like coffee spilling right so what
happens when you spill all your coffee
yeah
um also you can see I'm I'm running out
of coffee very quickly well yeah because
there's a lot of enemies we're gonna I'm
gonna obviously change the way that
they're generated like I my idea is just
to have a few of them generated in new
chunks that load in
um because that way they could be kind
of like and they won't come towards you
maybe based on like some radius or
whatever so they might be kind of hiding
around I kind of like the way they run
at you though like I feel like
they they almost don't need too much
especially now with the amount of time
we have left
because like
you know
yeah
um I just think that the way that they
appear
and I don't know maybe maybe it should
just be a lot easier to kill them as
well
like
I mean it's pretty easy now yeah in
general although I feel like they should
probably almost be one shot kills like
with a shock on us especially a one shot
kill but like I saw a rifle maybe like
two shots or something like and sniper
rifle should be able to watch uh collab
collab right uh maybe yeah double triple
kill yeah
it's almost like a job rifle it's just
instant kill now
um like it doesn't matter really where
you're standing let's say like there's a
lot of them there and they're just not
dying
I'm not shooting ah
um and also the raycast is slightly
bugged well see that that's kind of a
problem as well I think yeah
um it'd be great if maybe you could look
into that because I'm planning on
heading off to bed I think yeah I think
actually maybe the rake house is fine
it's just
the mesh for the shotgun is like now the
mesh for the shotgun is starting at the
right place it's just the rate isn't
this Ray starting like behind and like
intersecting the shotgun right
it seems like uh yeah maybe
but we can exclude entities right with
voice we should be able to yeah uh yeah
we can and I thought I was but actually
no oh hello jolt speed delivery
spawned underneath you one dog
nice that's fine um but actually yeah
hang on I don't think I'm excluding the
gun
ever
yeah you probably should
yeah we had that apparently I just said
it yeah no I'm not excellent
for both this and in enemy have you been
modifying anime by the way no no not at
all
okay good because I've been making quite
a few changes
good
um
I've been basically exclusively working
in level manager or level generator
all right yeah so I haven't touched that
you wouldn't want to it's a disaster
oh well so is the scripting engine
apparently
because it will just nuke the gun script
every now and then when you do a Reload
yeah
really need to track down that bug
and also sometimes it just crashes on GC
for me yeah but yeah that's mostly debug
related but not always there's another
crash as well yeah
it that that one's a bit more rare for
me but I don't tend to use the debugger
yes now you can see the actual Ray is
going through
and like
that's pretty much insta kill on that
that guy
um and well there's still some there's
no damage fall off to the bullets right
no I feel like there should be well you
can see like as long as you actually can
shoot array from
um with the
spell cut is like insta kill
where is this because I feel like
there's nothing more frustrating than
playing a shooting game and having to
stand there literally click your mouse
to kill somebody like oh why is it yeah
we definitely need to fix the raycast
she's like it's the I think part of it
is like it's hitting the terrain to some
degree but it might also be hitting some
other Collider
on the player Maybe
because like the player actually has a
couple of collaterals associated with it
I just thought of when when you enter
the snow the enemies should like
suddenly spawn with like winter fairy
cards
yeah anyway sorry gone
so these two
colliders could be ignored
and there are no other
colliders on the player so they might
just be intersecting like the terrain
or something there's either no colliders
or it's a mesh collider that you can't
see because there's no mesh collateral
visualization
yeah
um
I don't know
we we need to look into it though
because it's just not amazing right now
the the right cost
yeah like they're they're intersecting
something that's causing problems yeah
well I don't know I think I think
I'll I might take a really small look at
that because my plan I think is I'm just
gonna probably revamp the shooting
system like I'm going to make it uh I'll
probably make it snap onto enemies
um and so basically you'll you'll shoot
you'll shoot at the closest enemy to
your rotation angle so you can still
kind of Select which one you want to
shoot at
but like
just to make it really easy for the
player to be like I'm shooting at this
enemy because at the moment it's really
it's almost impossible to actually aim
and also be sure that which who you're
shooting at
especially like right now like what the
heck's going on you know
yeah like right now I don't have a gun
yeah yeah but I just mean like if you
were trying to fight this guy I don't
know it's just silly
so if you're like within a certain cone
it'll just snap to it yeah one downside
to that is the shotgun because that
actually fires multiple race which lets
you hit multiple entities
right
thing yeah shotgun can be uh or maybe
you know what maybe it could still be a
right click to trigger that system
so if you hold right click it's kind of
like aiming downside in the sense that
it'll snap
so that way you have both you can just
randomly hit fire if you want to just I
don't know if you want to but if you
want to actually Target an enemy you
right click
and then it'll display like a little
Crosshair above the enemy to let you
know which one's kind of targeted
yeah that'd be kind of fun
and then I'm just gonna once you've got
it so you're going to bed now yeah
okay so then yeah I guess just commit
and I'll pull because I'm going to start
like modifying the enemy script yeah
um I will when I wake up I'll probably
take care of like gun pickup because
that needs some some special behavior
um but that should all be constrained in
like the gun
um pickup script yeah well just let me
know when you wake up and I'll like I'll
push and
yeah yeah okay cool all right
all right have a nice have a nice sleep
then
thank you see you later all right see ya
okay uh
I'm I wanted to set up a little
countdown timer to when the jam ends
I don't know where it's gonna write this
whoa okay sure
um but I guess that should be running do
not minimize window excuse me
isn't it isn't this just writing to a
file why can't I minimize the window
this shouldn't even be here I used to
use something before that was actually
good
do you guys guys can you suggest me like
a good little
countdown timer that I can use like
something that writes to a file Maybe
every second or whatever
um and in the meantime
I'm gonna go set up the lighting a
little bit
yeah I might come back to Twitch one day
who knows we'll see
I kind of missed twitch a little bit
maybe we should come back to Twitch for
the last 12 hours
I'm on Twitch already so
somebody before because this like Adam C
Eunice guys is on the homepage bottom
decks he's got the most view it's
basically been in the whole stream so
maybe we should come in and take over
um all right
I will be back
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
all right I'm back
uh what did I stop at
oh yeah enemies and stuff
should pull Peters
changes
no it's fine
why not stop wait why did you refuse to
do anything
on tracked files
please commit your changes or stash them
but I did stash them oh there we go so
what that worked
just need to do do the old double pull
all right
laughs
just need to regenerate the projects
oh no
I did it with hazel open
that's a bad bad bad move
Tim I did the old pulling while Hazel is
open thing I've done that once today but
luckily
I'm pretty sure it ruined everything
happens
I'm just gonna revert my asset registry
all right
so a lot of these things are probably
going to be well
actually it somehow worked oh but that
doesn't work
so I guess it didn't somehow work ah
wait did it apply my stash or no I guess
it didn't
what was that it
uh it didn't do any of my yeah that
explains why the level generation or
whatever didn't work
so I need to apply this man
why is this an error there
I mean I was gonna delete this anyway
but
yeah got some conflicts
I'm pretty sure I can just oh this is
the
yeah I guess I'll take Peter's one
then oh no
Jerry can uh my thing is just empty then
why is that even a conflict huh
and then the asset registry
thank you Yasin for the donation you
can't expect my name to make a fan of
Shadow here as well LOL
thank you uh thanks for the
thanks for being here
um but yeah I don't know twitch and kind
of attempted to jump onto switch just to
mix it up
but
yeah
we'll see
okay I guess I want this and then I want
that but without the
without this so we take Peter's ID
okay
build this
it'll work
that's not good
wait why did all this get removed
oh my gosh
ah
yeah what
oh whatever
yeah probably
okay so I kind of undid everything
so there'll be a few things to fix up
but
not too much actually
hopefully not too much
it still isn't working though huh
I mean this is
this is the right code right
but yeah I think it is
but why ah that tent's not real
that's not the actual tent
okay oh that doesn't look right
oh yes it is right
we have one right there attended switch
um yes and no broadcasting here does not
affect anything to do with my twitch
partnership I'm allowed to stream on
YouTube
uh all right enemy cs24 is not happy
okay so yeah that's not set
um and how does that this get set
gun manager
where's the gun manager
I was at a prefab
well
what the heck
bro
where is this gun manager
I mean it's clearly been cold it still
exists because it's
causing an issue
but
it's not a thing here
oh is it just a script that's on
somewhere
[Music]
I don't know what thing it's on yeah
that's a bit that would be nice if we
could know
foreign
script here as well
but I don't know man
[Music]
I probably should just be its own SC but
it's apparently not
oh well yeah this is enemy CS but
oh maybe the fact that it doesn't exist
is the problem
but I'm pretty sure Peter made it
so if I just add it
and then all the gun prefabs need to be
here why do I have to do this why is
this not already why does it not exist
because I reverted this right
yeah it was it wasn't in the sand
does the gun manager need to well yeah
because you need to set the prefabs
that's so so strange man
okay so we got some uh prefabs here
I think
actually I'm guessing they're going to
be in prefabs so if I just go to prefabs
search for gun shotgun
assault rifle I guess they're not all
called guns
oh that's so annoying man
I don't know why it's not here to be
completely honest though
how many guns are there three
Tim uh yeah
okay hopefully that fixes it and where's
my tent hat
where's my tent
oh it's kind of far
at 43x
and let's just do it again
35 7.
again this thing man I gotta play with
that a bit
okay so 35
it's weird that it's so difficult for us
to find the starting Town it'd probably
definitely spawn a bit closer I think
okay here it is
yeah that looks correct
no Tim isn't sleeping he's working hard
yeah
well the shape of the enemy what would
you like them to look like
uh I don't know
whatever you think yeah maybe simple is
good like some like I don't know you
know one of these not I don't think not
too complex okay cool
um just because yeah like I kind of like
the cubes the way they are and don't
forget that they'll have to be they'll
have to have colliders or whatever so
yeah
like I don't know because we're gonna
have to set it up like they have to kind
of flock a bit no don't make I don't
know man
probably
yeah
because I I think
well especially if there's like a I
don't know I think I'll make the one
that you originally wanted
or something like this
I'll make it smaller than the character
that's the plan yeah about like one just
do that or maybe you can make them like
either robots or drones because that way
they in that case I was thinking some of
this like something legs not where
humans grow legs you know right
so then you'll animate them yeah I think
so
yeah I mean I guess you can and for the
general I might just copy the character
kind of
uh copy the character yeah um what's
called yeah yeah okay
sure
so drowning kind of yes
I think so
okay so this General tense situation
I just don't get why
well the good thing is though we can run
this like a billion times
let's run this like a hundred times I
want to see what the results are
um
just curious like what it came up with
maybe I'll dock it on this side so you
guys can see as well
um
yeah okay so I mean it is all pretty
much in the same range like it's very
it's like a hundred or so give or take
yeah I mean it does bounce between
negative and positive obviously
everywhere but
it's I think it's too
staticky and I wonder why that is
because what are we doing here
that not correct
digital Studio wasting time
let's just run that once so we can see
okay so it's between well because it's
between 96 and 123 at this point in time
but that's like too far away like
because if we look at
um
but we wanted it to be a little bit far
away I think that's why
because if we if we look at where like
the lot like this chunk is and let's try
and find its La I guess it'll be the
last one right
its furthest one is it 63.
um so really that's like 32 times yeah
because it's only two
um but I think we set this to three so
that's a bit odd
where's this minimum thing three
so that means it does minimum chunk so
three times chunk size times top width
to get it in tiles
so 16 times 3 that's 48 right
48 oh and then it does times two
oh I guess minchan can be two then
32 and then times 264. because that
would mean past this basically
and as long as it's outside of this
initial area it's fine so we can make it
maybe super close sometimes two and then
I guess we can expand it a little bit to
seven
but I guess that's not bad in terms of
like the distribution and whatever of it
like that's just the way it is you know
yeah that's probably okay
and then this coffee tent though I think
this should be a little bit
maybe not as far
right
well if I make it point seven so it's a
bit closer
where did it put it at 34.
we could make it be somewhere within the
first chunk
and also how are we making sure it's not
on top of the player or whatever
and in fact where does the player start
is it the player just starts at where he
happens to be
I guess we should start the player at
the origin
Okay so
So within three chunks
so that's 48 minus 16 that doesn't
really seem right
so we have
yeah what
that's going to do 48 minus 16 which is
32.
and then times two and it's clearly only
going to be that oh but this is that's
the range
oh but we don't we never negate this do
we as well
no
right
and we also don't have a minimum
that's a bit dodgy I think we should do
basically the same system as what I did
here and spend a bit more time on this
um
kind of leave that
and then what do we do
this
except the Min chunk will be
zero and the max chunk will be two
um
minimum distance the max distance will
appear that
the minimum distance will be that but
we'll we should add like a little buffer
to it
so like five meters no maybe seven
meters or something I don't know
um and that's it I think
could not Place tent
beautiful really
could not place tant you say
that's not fun
could not Place tan why
because it couldn't get a tile at that
place I think we may have been we may
have gone too far
really
okay
well I'd already placed the general tent
but okay I guess maybe that's just a
close one okay my point is I want it to
be closed the first ten I pretty much
want it to be visible
okay um
may have not worked well
for the other 10.
I could it not place the general tent
no I did 109.
but there's only one tent
what
ah no that's just where it's putting out
sorry my bad
okay so this is good I think because it
looks like
looks like it's always in a
somewhat accessible place
can I make a super powered Sprint option
because I just want to make sure that
[Music]
what like is there some kind of concept
of spade here
like how fast do I move or is that just
completely animation based
oh the compass there's a compass
apparently isn't there
oh that doesn't work
never mind
maybe more maybe it just isn't loaded or
something
yeah there's no compensation oh that's a
big compost entity uh that doesn't work
either
I wish Peter's scene worked for me
I don't know how he made the compass
oh well
actually I could just look at his commit
right
and take it kind of manually
so reworked gun Behavior added Compass
here it is
he met I metaphor and Compass scene
maybe that's why maybe he didn't add it
to the main scene
let's look at the compass scene
yeah that works see
okay good
all right
uh yes so I was gonna make myself move
quicker so I could actually debug a
little bit
oh there's a Crosshair what's oh that's
just the
broadcast situation yeah
all right
so he doesn't use move
so how how do we actually move the
character controller
foreign
I mean I guess it's just the animation
speed but how do I control the animation
speed
down
what
Tim yeah do you have any idea how to
make the player move faster
with character controllers
yeah but that's not on the character
controller is it that's on the animation
yeah
but that's fine because that listens to
it
playback speed right so if I just make
it five
yeah okay cool
sweet thanks
well yeah I'm gonna have to do that
actually I'll just leave it on fast
all right this is great
uh and for my next trick
let me show where to go
um
like as in uh that Compass situation
why is there no
Arrow here
it's three cubes apparently but I don't
see them
what the heck
oh they're not visible oh right because
he's probably okay but if I just add a
compass here
tab should met I thought tab made it
visible
now that's supposed to yeah do this
yep
so what's up man
why isn't it working
no it is working
you just can't ah wait what
is it
why is it being weird
actually that might be on me
but it's not on me
unless something is moving it like it
looks like it's right over the player
yeah what do the enemies look like right
now like how they set up uh
I don't know I haven't actually looked
at that yet
but you're on latest front
um yeah yeah oh no
and have you pushed anything no
I haven't looked at the guns at all yet
I don't know if that works or whatever
on Peter's
why is that such a big offset
oh it's being set by something
oh here it is translation y plus five
it's probably too tall maybe that's why
and it's also it looks kind of big
but also why is look it's like it
doesn't move
what the heck
but it takes the translation
ah because it's parented ah whoops Peter
didn't make a Parenthood
how do I unparent it
are
Nar
man
there was an unparent button at some
point
why can't I unparent this Tim how do I
unparent and she's I can't quite do it
there's a hidden pixel right between
label and level generator
is sure
yeah
house
no what do you mean let's parent just
level generator
we really do need that I'm gonna add
that right now yeah this is already
wasted enough time there is enough you
see it's probably because
you're on this side I don't know maybe
this pixel doesn't exist when you're
docked on this side yeah it seems likely
all right I'll update that right now
hahaha
foreign
how do I how do I unparent
like if I just set parent uid to zero
does that work oops
no how does it hmm
great
foreign
will check the current parent
otherwise if there is a current parent
or remove it sure
oh setting to know is okay
um
so isn't that done then
make if I just do that that might just
be all it takes
apparently not
setting to null is okay but it's not
obviously because we're asking for the
uid of the parent
okay that's okay I think I know how to
make it work though
oh but that
oh my gosh I can't believe this isn't
how is this not a function that already
exists it has to be right
no the default uid I don't think it
creates
uh a new one oh no it does the default
Constructor
wasn't that changed recently
I feel like it did
but I'm not that's not a uuid I'm
creating I'm creating a an entity
but I don't know if this would work
because the thing is
as if we don't do this anywhere in the
engine
that doesn't look like it
what about this is there any place
that's what I just wrote
oh look on parent entity seen on parent
entity
I guess that's what you have to do you
have to go to the scene and on parents
and do on parent entity
so I'm scene or M context
on parent test here found it
uh and we just unparents that and
convert to World space I guess so
done
is that parent takes an answer in order
to you ID
but but set parent uuid doesn't
do all the right things it just has the
uid of the parent to zero
like it doesn't go through and remove
like the children or whatever
the parents children
[Music]
all right
donzies
so where's this pointing towards at the
moment possibly the origin
direction to general journal position
and that's zero yeah okay so
um
to get the general position like we need
to
basically
know this uh
do we have access to that we've got the
player
level I should probably know though
all right that's why I wanted him level
I don't know if there's there might be a
better way to do this actually
I might rename it from Mobile generator
to just level
that's fine now I think
yep
okay so now if I go this direction it
will take me to the tent
hopefully
that's kind of far
well it's a journey
oh it's not working
it's not working foreign
but it didn't work why what happened
there man
that Arrow's not real
translation mine is that that should
work
what the heck
maybe I didn't build it properly
oh I didn't press tab
so it was just on the defaults that's
what happened
I need to be holding top there it is
steak sauce
yeah sorry that's my bad it's just I
made these be on by default
um and that's why I only updates the
position when you look at it
yeah I'm doing fast just to stress test
it like I'm not a stress tester just to
run it a bunch of times and make sure
that the generations
good most of the time it's kind of fun
though this mode
I definitely think you should be able to
Sprint
that was a coffee tan
thank you
yeah no it's good um what I'm checking
for is just wear the tents the general
tent is spawning
which is this and I'm making sure I can
like get in basically
just making sure there's no weird cases
where it's just like
completely on unreachable
of course I'm not gonna like
you know I'm lightly testing this it is
a game Jam after all or say like this
so this is bad this means it couldn't
place it and this does sometimes happen
and I don't know why because it doesn't
even put anything in a log
and this has happened once before so
this is exactly what I wanted to catch
so why would it not place it
does it not think it
uh
does it not think it can or something or
does is this just not because if that's
silently null it does actually print
though that's the copy 10 though
so plays Journal 10 yeah we'll do that
if it couldn't do this
so maybe I'll just worn out
trying to instantiate
General tense
um
but it would have printed something
that's so weird so my
guess is that it just never ran this
code
which means that for some reason this
either didn't run
or it never thought that it like when
processed chunks or whatever and one of
those days loads chunks around player or
whatever it never agreed that the that
this was true
so if this chord is that a good
coordinate yes it is if that contains
the general tent
because it mostly works as well right
hmm
it's a lot better with this Compass
though
I guess I'll try and roll this is a fun
world
a little bit difficult but nothing that
I can't handle
yeah that's that and you can say it's
it's on flat ground you can get into it
so that's good
I don't know it's it is like kind of
rare but it's also like not that rare
like I feel like it's one in ten not one
in a million so
maybe one in 20.
because it would suck to just yeah look
here it is
it didn't place it man
why so it's basically right here is
where it thinks it should be now is that
um
is that like is there something to do
with a chunk boundary or whatever here
damn it I'm moving
okay so right here right
uh
I kind of can't yeah not move okay no
that's right in the middle of Chunk four
oh chunk four that happens to be the
zero chunk that's the Chunk in the
middle
what if it doesn't work for if it's zero
for some reason that doesn't make sense
though
why wouldn't it right
huh
because yeah that one is the middle one
I mean this goes through nine right zero
to eight
it does I'm on three minus one so if I
is like one or whatever
oh I zero three minus one
yeah that should be fine should end up
with that plus zero
I don't know
oh I need to um make sure that I went 12
because YouTube live stream is going to
be 12 hours
so I need to make sure
basically that I
can stop the live stream and start it
again otherwise it'll get cut off I
think
um okay
that's really weird yeah
so either it thinks this is already it
already exists
I can add some more logging
trying rape Road Again
I guess one thing I can look for is
whether or not
where it exists right now
if that is a middle
if that's chunk four basically oh look
it is chunk four okay so it's not
because it's chunk four although this is
actually in the middle of two
yeah that really sucks though
yeah look it's not here
um okay so let's read the log then let
me pause this
let's read the log
um
so it looks like it I don't think it
ever creates
um
a chunk here
with tent being true
and it raises quite a lot from the cash
I would have thought it would have not
have existed at that
location
I guess I was walking around or
something
but
it does create new chunks but none of
them seem to have
the tent
oh guys I think I know what it is oh
it's a terrible one
I think I know what it is
woof
no no
I think it's because chunks get
recreated at different
orders
um oh man
so basically when we come into a new
area so let's just say we have these
yeah these are our chunks currently as
soon as we walk from here to here it
actually rebuilds every chunk like this
and I I'm worried what will happen is
obviously if it realizes that
the tents
but would that affect the tent being
created
I guess so well I mean it's I feel like
it does I feel like it's dependent on
the order
let me just
visualize a bit more
I mean the only real thing is it's going
to go through this multiple it's going
to go like through it multiple times and
this coordinate shouldn't change because
this index that gets passed in I'm
pretty sure is like you can see it here
it gets chunk it's a global chunk index
um and this is just responsible for
going around it and we're obviously
going around it so we're just modifying
this and we're seeing if it contains
General 10. so here's another thing that
we could do
um I think we should just see if this is
ever
if this is ever triggered basically but
the thing is this will always run
oh but that's the problem man
yes I know why it's because it it can
sometimes look up a cached one on the
last one and since it all only runs a
lot I think I know what it is which is
great
um
I'm gonna make sure though but I'm
pretty sure
whoops
wait what the heck did I do
let's go back
yeah I think I know what it is
um
I think it should probably do it on the
last one
possibly no matter what
so it shouldn't just do it if it's cash
I mean
ideally you do it the first time it does
this but the problem is it might be
halfway through to another one and I
think that's the reason why I didn't
want it to do it this way so what we'll
do is if we'll actually move this out
but we need to do this
if it hasn't already been placed
so
let's do this let's keep track of the
entity that we place
um
which is here
and if that's null we'll allow that
yeah I think I've solved it
which is good
I already built it in play mode which
causes the crash
okay so this should never I think this
will now work
um it's gonna be hard I'll run it at
least 10 times
but it's it is going to be hard to say
so guys for those who don't know what
the game is about you have to deliver
coffee without spilling it through this
second ten
so the general has ordered a coffee
and you need to go to the coffee tent
pick up the coffee and pick up make the
order I guess possibly we'll see how
much time we have and deliver it to that
tent while fighting enemies because
you're in a battlefield even though this
doesn't really look like a Battlefield
that's our original idea so basically
you get the coffee from this guy you do
not move this fast by the way this is
just for debugging you get the coffee
from this guy and then you bring it
to here
and it's all very
no tiles there it looks like it's all
very random
and randomly generated and stuff
anyway are we satisfied yet
do you guys like the play pause speed by
the way
fast and unity
like I mentioned that every few hours
there it is
it does seem to pause every now and then
though I don't know why I am I am moving
yeah like look at that why is that
pausing huh
this is pretty good I've run it quite a
few times
it's like it takes a while to
instantiate the General's tent or
something
on the journal tent
and I guess that's why
or is it why
because I didn't use the pause before so
I'm a little bit
confused oh no it's just pausing
randomly I think
well not completely randomly but yeah
all right well and you can see the World
Journal is quite you can get it's
different as well okay good well I don't
know it's not crash like it's not uh by
crashing comment it's not um not showing
up for me anymore the pause is really
weird though
oh look at this this is bad you can't
get in well you can actually but that's
kind of cool though it almost looks like
it's covered in snow but that shouldn't
have happened
well we might just leave it because it's
rare and uh you could actually still get
in
it was almost a feature
sometimes it's close sometimes it's far
sometimes it phrases
but it looks good
this will be the last one I test
beautiful
all right I'm happy
you guys Happy
yeah the tents do look different I'm
just using the same one
while Tim was making the asset but I
think he's made the asset a while ago
actually
you pushed the tenth right ages ago yeah
no there's no health bar you drop a
coffee when you get shot and we've
already done that
just because for performance reasons I
didn't separate the materials out and so
for example there's robes and poles it's
all in the semi will be vegetation so
when you're changing the fabric color
you're also tinting oh I see so if you
pick the color play around with it and
then just tell me and I'll give you this
well just make it like bright yellow I
think bright yellow yeah so play around
just tell me it's going to take two
seconds for me to do it
figure it out you can tell me the exact
tax code yeah
but yeah because I didn't separate it
actually separate materials
oh that's tent light that's the light
whoops
what's temp material then
so 10 material is what you made Tim
oh it's called M tent yeah
it doesn't really look very white
is this right it might be already
[Music]
I made it white and it looks kind of
dark like
or is that what you were going for
I was thinking like a rainco a yellow
raincoat you know
like I was thinking like bright yellow
kind of town like that
really just really distinct okay
um yeah because it has a lot of like
dirt and stuff like that but I couldn't
clean it up while the one yellow tent
done
look this is what this is what I was
picturing this is perfect
stream I'm talking about this
wait so and the the problem is right now
that when you set it to wait it does
well like see all that Darkness yeah
hmm
but like it doesn't matter I'll just
make this yeah just
yeah yellow World War One turn is what
you I can send you this photo
yeah
well you can I don't know you can adjust
the model like I mean ideally yes it
would be visually different but we don't
have time right
yeah okay me I make the enemies I guess
uh let me just paste this in
oh
my God
so now I need to work on the
enemy AI
whenever someone says not a bug but a
feature I always run my small game I've
seen where for some reason tanks were
shooting tanks instead of bullets devs
that it's a fascia that's hilarious
yeah like I don't know my plan's
probably going to be
um
okay well let's make the enemies not
spawn for a second my plan's probably
gonna be I'm gonna work on enemies
then
I would probably like to start putting
together the tutorial slash like the how
to play meaning like
you know the beginning screen and then
maybe like it transitions to play but if
the game has to kind of teach you how to
play a little bit
on screen text for that that should be
pretty easy at least base version should
be pretty easy and then I really think I
need to move on to audio because we
don't have any audio for the game and we
would have ideally some ambience
and some
I don't know gunfire in the background
or something and maybe some music I
don't know like ideally probably yes but
I don't think I don't know if I'll have
time to make music
um
um yeah so that's kind of where we're at
uh
was that it yeah I think that's it so
let's set the player's speed back to
um one
oh I didn't want to add a Sprint
let's add a Sprint for the Playa though
foreign
adjust these somewhere else
probably put that at the bottom
uh I don't know if I should bother
making it only if you're on the ground
might kind of be nice to
How We Do the whole Gamepad situation
this
I guess left joystick
you could just Sprint the whole way
though
and there are no enemies yeah okay so
let me get the coffee first so I guess
the idea is if you don't have the coffee
it should probably Point towards the
coffee if you do have the coffee it
should probably Point towards the
tent right
uh so
let's go back to this Compass situation
and then at the moment it's going to
want to look for
the yeah General tent but we need to
know if we have the coffee
so something something coffee like do we
have the coffee how do we know if we
have the coffee if we're holding the
coffee we should know
coffee because now yes a coffee okay
so if
if coffee doesn't equal null then yes
please tell me this
otherwise
I need to know where the coffee is
please
so what is coffee though coffee coffee
item yeah okay sure but then there's a
coffee there should be a coffee
uh
how do we pick this up actually
copied a place sure
how do you pick up coffee
yeah I don't like the fact that coffee
item here it is I guess this is where it
happens
this is the island pickup which is an
entity
Ah that's fine
we need to be able to get this though I
don't know if
setting it to null is a good idea
because I still want to know where it is
so I guess when you pick it up what does
it assign coffee on the player yeah it
does
how does this how does this coffee get
created
it doesn't exist initially is it a
prefab
yeah coffee particle coffee setup coffee
cup
I don't know how the coffee spawns
in fact I'm pretty sure it doesn't at
the moment
yeah I don't know how Peter made the
coffee spawn
we could probably figure it out but
I need to make the coffee spawn
okay well we wanted to spawn in the tent
in the coffee tent right
so initially it should probably start
here on this thing
okay
um
does this poem with the particles
hopefully
no it doesn't
how did Peter do the coffee coffee setup
no that looks broken
how like it's not through code did he
have it in his
where did he add coffee
out of 10. Peter Peter
had a coffee particle spawning when
players hit
add a coffee animation fixed coffee
pickup
coffee
that's just this coffee cup prefab
um
yeah I don't know man I don't know what
to do about the coffee kind of sucks
I just don't know how Peter made it
I could probably look at the look on his
live stream
to see I just don't know how Peter put
it together because I like it's not
currently spawning I made the model I
don't know yeah but how do you make it
spawn somewhere like it's supposed to
spawn on this table right how like how
does that work is it manually placed is
it not and also the prefab itself The
Coffee Cup prefab that Peter added which
is this that it doesn't actually contain
any coffee in it it's just
you know it's empty no no that that mesh
there is the coffee and then it gets
resized through script
so yeah so once I this hit play it will
have coffee in it it already has coffee
it just gets resized yeah right so I
just want to see it in the editor
you see how it's printed and inside this
coffee so if you scale that
um okay sure and it you and it was it
supposed to be in saturated through a
script that I actually don't know yeah
so that's kind of what I wanted to find
out as well
um
oh what's this
but that is somewhat helpful
yeah so what I was thinking was in that
case though why wouldn't I just add it
like this to the tent
and then just put it on the table yeah
when is that going through the table
you know like if I do that
then surely uh let's null
something small
and uh coffee item 34 or something 39.
I'm already there uh this so coffee
liquid entity is not correct
no and I didn't finish this
why is that null
I guess I'm not sure if that will work
though if you're allowed to reference it
like that
um because it's gonna when it gets
instantiated I think it'll get a fresh
ID so maybe it would be better
two when the coffee gets created
yeah actually doesn't it just have its
child why would we do that
coffee liquid entity
is basically just child children zero
uh let's do that instead
um
and that should work
yep that's pretty nice
so if we go in here we can see that we
have coffee
excellent that's a nice color it's
making me want some coffee
um
okay so now we can go in and we can
grab coffee which we really should make
that not clip uh so F I think and now
you got coffee on your head
and it kind of moves a bit which is fun
um
and then you have to carry the coffee
and you can put it down I think why is
it f
I don't know if I made that happen but
anyway the point is it's supposed to I
want now that that actually does exist
it'd be nice to be able to
tell the player about the coffee
um
so that it knows where it is
so
how do we do that
um
I guess we would
fancy shaders that act like liquid is
Polish
stuff I don't want to hear it we need
fundamental gameplay working okay this
thought
um yeah so we yeah I don't I don't know
if I like the fact that this coffee just
goes to null
ah and the webpage random because it
means that we just can't
we don't know about it
um we could probably
so
let's just do that and if coffee is null
we'll do
fine I'll just do a little find Entity
by uh tag because I can't be bothered
and
um what is it though it's
like as in what is it called
coffee cup I guess that's what I'm
looking for
I don't know if that will work
because that's not really a nullable
type
okay so it should be guiding me to my
coffee
and then as soon as I pick up the coffee
it's guiding me to where I need to put
the thing down now how do I put the
coffee down
Q
I think
yeah F's to pick up what yeah right so I
guess it's so that you don't pick up
you don't put down the coffee if you
want to pick up a gun yeah it's cute oh
does that little animation thing that
looks really weird
so you can't spill coffee at the moment
but yeah so there's a lot of game
mechanics missing
if he Place coffee in water you should
just lose
I think
well nothing there's like the game needs
a lot of love
I feel like is it just me I feel like it
should be cloth like why is the camera
so far away it should be closer to the
player
I'm gonna make that happen
what sets it to that
does the camera rig just have a nice
easy to set distance from player
because that would be nice
oh no well actually is it this yeah this
I think
that controls it
I could also play with the field of view
actually
well I could make it a bit tighter like
this
or is that worse
I guess that's worse
it almost feels like when you go in it
should go in a bit
so it should be basically based on I
don't know changing the field of view
might be trippy
but
yeah I don't necessarily think we should
punch in the field of view
that looks kind of sick
um but I do think we should
uh so if we make this like five seven
and move this in a bit so this would be
like closer
um
but I'm thinking when it's up it should
be further and when it's down it should
be closer so you kind of change that I
guess
um it'd be funny if it was if it did the
field of view though
so basically where when where do we even
do that Target rotation or something
rotation
because this is um right
that rotation there
yeah rotation X
yeah rotation X basically is what it is
so
um
so it'll be like children zero
get component camera component
Dot
uh
dot vertical five
Vehicles get false
rotation.x
this is going to be so trippy
and it's not in degrees is it
like if I do this
I think that's going to be Bad News
Bears
is that actually changing the fove it is
[Music]
except I want to go the other way
that's actually kind of cool
[Music]
maybe I could make it more dramatic
though
[Music]
nah I think that's gonna make you sick
kind of don't like it
so if it's close it's kind of in and
then as I go out I see more I mean in a
way that's cool it's almost like I've
had a zoom
but not quite let me
tell that feels like with a controller
that's not bad especially if I just flat
out subtract a value as well
like that
so that means it'll be even closer and a
bit less far
maybe that and then maybe 20 and then
maybe five
so you can get like a bit of a top-down
view that's a bit further but then when
you go in it punches in a bit
and then I was gonna make Amy downside
punch in more and by anything downside
it'll kind of
do something else but
can we Sprint no that doesn't work on
the controller
[Music]
I don't know I don't love it but it'll
do for now
can I go to the controller uh okay
I guess I'll do a commit
so enemies I guess
enemies that I wanted to play with enemy
targeting
and then maybe two hours or an hour and
a half Pizza Time
hold off for my keys
okay so enemy targeting
um all right so I guess we can continue
to spawn enemies
um and then let's do this
so let's do this
um
uh this like gets
get fall
in the camera
uh but there'll be an animation filming
downside as well
but let's just do if is aiming Tower
um okay
let's do this so there'll be a minus
aiming down sight
uh Factor
okay
uh maybe I don't want to set it up this
way
basically I kind of I guess I was gonna
just do this
um and if we make that between zero and
one
then we can just use that as a way to do
like some kind of
A's out maybe
on basically zero to
like 20.
and what that should mean
well that's
very wrong
I don't know why that didn't work
oh
too much okay and it takes a second time
downside which is also too much
so uh
so speed should be like maybe 100
milliseconds 150.
um
which means what exactly
plus is it one over
uh 0.15 what's that gonna be
is that right
times six
double time times six
yeah that's right
is it
that feels weird oh sorry times
but I don't know if that's right that
should make it faster though
yeah that's good
uh way too much though
um
maybe an extra five
so that's kind of the targeting mode
just to kind of show you that you're
you're targeting entities
yeah I kind of think that since that's a
thing
this should be probably less and maybe
that should be a bit more
so this is now more subtle but you can
zoom it you can kind of do that
be sick if it made it go slow-mo as well
hahaha
yeah increasing the field of view when
moving would be kind of cool especially
whilst printing uh we'll see though
that'll be I'll do that later all right
cool uh so we've done that now we just
need to know
if we're in a targeting mode or not
so
private ball
uh targeting
is targeting
so we can basically be like
I guess in the update shooting or
something I don't know
if we're ever gone then yeah return if
there's no ammo return
if we shoot then yeah this
but let's for now basically be like if
we're targeting
um
we basically need to find like nearby
enemies
snap to closest so we're adding like a
bit of a nemesist thing here
um and
we'll snap to closest by yeah
do we even have that is that even a
thing find near find
near kind of close entities or whatever
I don't know if that's a thing man
we've never done that before in any
hazel game
um
I need to find entities in a radius
from me
no I don't yeah like a sphere cost no I
don't want to do that
I think it should be okay though because
as long as enemy like I said I could do
that without either even adding that
function to the engine because
um as long as enemies are spawning
and if they actually spawn in like an
enemy container which I'm gonna create
now
then I could just go through the
children there and just check them all
basically and there's not going to be
that many enemies like less than 100 so
it probably shouldn't be too bad I think
and that's only when you're targeting as
well
so I think it should be okay
to do it that way
would be good if it was obviously like
you know spatially partitioned or
whatever but whatever
uh
[Music]
foreign
just do this in 2D as well that doesn't
really matter but
but yeah uh
so we could do like um
basically for entity child for each
entity child in an uh enemy container
dot children
uh I don't know if it's good to
be getting that every frame probably not
by every iteration
I don't know man
probably safer uh all right
so return null if it couldn't find
anything
uh Vector three
can I just do like dot distance
what's this guy
public static flow distance between two
or
origin dot distance
child translation right
uh
uh but I need to know I need to know uh
if it actually was so let's do
um if
uh let's do that let's we'll have to
write it out a bit because we also need
to set it out and
uh let's do out distance
I guess we can just write to that
so basically if distance less than
out distance
then we need to update uh out distance
and we need to set the entity
child
okay so that's it
that's going to be all the enemies
so entity
closest enemy equals that
now that's not really quite correct
though actually now that I think about
it it's going to be a little bit harder
than that ah because I was going to have
it be based on where you're aiming so
it's going to be like a current immune
to finality within that cone I guess
that's not too difficult actually
because if you just
you can
um we can find out obviously the angle
like
yeah
we could so that okay well let's just
see let's make sure this works first
yeah
um
so let's have a little bit of a
Crosshair or something
um let's do
let's do cross out and we'll basically
just like move the Crosshair
to we can make it visible we can hide it
but we can also just move it
so if close to Center me it doesn't
equal null
let's
set the Crosshair translation to the
closest enemy translation plus and we'll
make it like a little bit above them I
guess
so zero like 1.5 zero that might need to
be twigged
um
no this needs the origin so it'll just
be our player translation
on the up distance
sure
okay so let's make a Crosshair where
even am I
okay that's my world
um
yeah I mean I was just gonna make like a
for now
let's I guess we'll make a plane
and we can make it we'll grab a
we'll give it a material it might it'll
probably be like some kind of actual
material like a Crosshair material
I guess I could just make across there
maybe I'll make some art for once how
about that
Photoshop
uh how big should it be
I don't know 256 56
make it white because I can always tint
it
um let's make a circle
oh I could just place a circle from
Santa
that's not from Santa as in writing
click on the center I guess
that's annoying uh width and height
200 200
we'll Center it later um
where's the thickness oh it's a stroke
thing isn't it
how do you guys think does that look
good
it's probably too
oh it does have a fill
let's give it no fill let's give it a
white stroke
um
sure that works
what are we thinking a little bit too
is that centered
that's not bad is that cool should be
thicker
I guess we'll play with a stroke for
that
okay let's ship it
foreign
[Music]
ah this has no actually that should work
what
why is my texture not here
huh
that's a bit annoying
what
oh I know why
I know why
um it's because the transparency thing's
weird I don't I think this will probably
crash the engine if I do this
okay I didn't somehow
but I also don't think it will work
I don't know how that's supposed to work
but
it does not work
hey I feel like it used to maybe it's
just a menu renderer
this is a bit weird
like do we even do anything with
transparency
but I guess that's a good point we'd
want this if it does no but it would
just discard pixels it's not gonna blend
but it should it should honestly work
like even in an opaque pass because it's
just it's not like it's blending
uh
I just don't know what happens with
things that are transparent at the
moment
I mean there are like
things for it
like it does seem like it does some kind
of
like when it does the geometry pass
right
it's just because I rewrite the renderer
I may have just not
done it yeah look
okay so I think let's just try this
because it'll probably be the easiest
thing to do if I just actually add this
back in which probably isn't going to be
that difficult right
uh the problem is it isn't a different
render pass though
we can still try it
is there a geometry I've probably
already made a geometry transparent pass
now
I really not do that
I was a bit lazy it seems
so I never made it transparent
super annoying man
okay well let's quickly do it
it's basically going to be the exact
same thing that's the thing
I'm gonna be lazy and just quickly do
this now to not waste too much time
hopefully on this and I hope it works
now the pipeline is going to be
different though
but it also needs to make sure it isn't
clear
stuff yeah how do we make that happen
here
what was that not on the pipeline no it
would oh this float this load frame
buffer
yeah which is okay
oh look transparent geometry pipeline so
we have the pipeline we just have to run
to pass okay good
thank you
and that should be it believe it or not
so now we should just be able to do this
and I think that's it
I mean I don't know if this stuff will
compile
uh looks like I did fix it though
[Music]
I didn't save my Crosshair
yes I did it's here I don't see it
wonderful
uh I guess that didn't work
it's rendering
that definitely doesn't clear the frame
buffer or anything weird
to get we'll make this work the only
thing that may have stopped it actually
is the depth pass
oh that's why we have this oh does it
need its own I think it needs its own
rejection situation
Maybe
yeah I think this is the problem
although I feel like we should have
still maybe seen it
at least a little bit
basically like we need to make sure that
we use a different depth buffer because
there's a kind of uh like we do we do a
pre-depth pass and obviously that makes
sense for opaque geometry but for
transparent things not so much we can't
just reject it
quite that easily
and that's not happy and unfortunately
now is this did that actually happen it
should have
and what does that use pipeline
pipeline's back
Brian buffer
I think we just don't do it
yeah it's commented out
so pre-depth transparent past okay this
is old old code this is garbage
from my old renderer that's also
gone I think this one's gone this one's
gone and that should be it
okay let's try that
I don't know why that gets set again but
whatever
so that this is a different era
what pass is this
[Music]
uh copy that it's probably
it looks like it's just the geometry
paths but
it happens before the transparent one
and we're riding into the same color
buffer but that should be fine
right
what's it using this pipeline
which means
oh no no no I know why
yep
because we're not it is actually a
different frame buffer uh which means
that pre-depth transparent needs to be
resized and I believe we're not doing
where's geometry
um well we're doing it in a weird way
but yeah geometry transparent pass needs
to be
uh reobtained
the
image
okay
um
interesting
this is black
this almost makes me think like the
depth is not working
uh
yeah I don't know it's weird
I mean that should be working uh the
transparency is yeah that doesn't matter
though
the same time matter
but what I'm what I'm confused about is
well no that might not work because it
might reject all the pixels behind it
which is the problem that's why I wanted
it to work with this pipeline
um but I just don't know why
it's not working but let's quickly
I just need to see
um if there's anything here
if this is working at all meaning like
if it's actually getting
to if we're able to write pixels
basically into it
because I have a feeling we're not
[Music]
I guess not
so we can't actually write pixels into
here it could be the depth
hmm
Crosshair Mash yeah actually that's not
a bad idea I could make a Crosshair Mash
that's a good idea
um I'll give this like 10 more minutes
and if not then yeah I'll remove it just
because it's something I want to kind of
loosely get working facial in general
all right so
um
just need to make sure yeah that's
definitely being reset I'm suspicious of
this of this guy
like what does that even do
well
oh look it uses the pre-depth Shader
so then like
that writes the depth though
how would that work
what
it needs to basically set depth to like
I don't know one or something
in this pass for all for all pixels
how why like
why would this work
or alternatively don't write any depth
information but then we kind of need
depth information
we could just not write depth for
transparent things
[Music]
I don't know what my what like what this
is supposed to do
um because this that's just gonna result
in it riding depth
I mean like and if it doesn't write that
like it needs to though it can't just
like discard or whatever and just be
like don't well because that's not gonna
do nothing first of all but also
it's that's wrong it kind of needs to
you know
that's annoying
yeah I might give up on this
yeah I'm moving up on this
no time
okay so across there then
um what it's gonna be
gonna remove this uh it's going to be
um I guess I can move this over here
maybe again so you guys can see
okay
so let's see
um
oh I guess I'd build it in blender
though
because I need to get a a circle which I
don't think I can do
right
yeah I'll build it in blender
looks like default Cube's staying around
uh so what do I do 0.1.1
um
a Taurus can I make the Taurus
have like no segments
I mean that's kind of done
looks kind of lame
I mean I'll make it emissive so it won't
quite be lit
but
I could make it I guess I could make it
have a flat um
now make it a bit thinner as well
I could make it have a flat I could make
these faces flat
because they're a bit curved at the
moment
how does that look maybe that's a bit
too fat
that's not bad
all right so let's um
make that flat basically
uh and then I'll make all three I guess
use one material
okay I think that made three materials
or it made at least two I'm pretty sure
which is not really what I wanted
to make two materials
I didn't make three and it didn't make
one
but anyway the only reason why I'm
making a material is so I can just
control them all with one material later
I'm gonna do it in in Hazel
it's pretty big isn't it
um let's go to
assets meshes sauce
oh my gosh what I just delayed the
compass
that's all right I have to really the
scene there's no control of that
yeah
that's okay there
I'll go back to this and I'll delete
this again
okay uh it's obviously big but
that's quite okay
um and then I had a
across a material
and that's obviously crazy
what
why is that not uh
oh there's something weird going on with
bloom
it's like it's pink masked
that's really strange
that may have been something to do with
the new depth pass I added
I should probably remove it before
everything becomes bad
I'm gonna remove this just in case I
broke stuff and also we don't need it if
we don't have anything transparent
foreign
that still doesn't really work I don't
know what happened though
but that's not blooming at all
it's like only blooming on existing
geometry which is crazy but I feel like
I've seen this before and I forgot what
caused it
uh it's not good
see it it's not blooming
my Bloom is broken the one feature
that we like in Hazel
okay so let's just say that's my
Crosshair
um
so now if I hit play
uh
it's supposed to
find the closest enemy right
I've got my enemy container I got my
player
for my enemy spawner enemy manager so
let's do spawn enemy
so if that spawns someone
we should see them in an enemy container
oh it's it is pointing them oh okay
they're not going into enemy container
yeah that's another big problem
um so this enemy manager needs to know
about the enemy container
which it does not so
yeah I'm concerned about the bloom
because that's really really strange
that that's not it's like it's not
compositing it correctly maybe I don't
know
very weird anyway
um so if we're going to enemy manager
enemy container
we're supposed to do instantiate child
so we'll pop it into there
yeah and looks like they're in here now
so if I do right click I should see my
Crosshair which I'm not saying which is
wonderful
is it even moving
no
huh I wonder why
I mean it should be
as long as this is a null
uh
let's do
the distance
see if we even found anyone
uh no it's not working
so either was not finding anyone
or it's
ah it's because I got my gun okay let's
move this up here I think it's because I
have no gun
yeah okay that's that's failing
in terms of like it's a null reference
exception but that's good
um
has component called with invalid value
object reference on set to thingy
and three three four and that's line
what's the what is this
oh Crosshair is not potentially present
because I remained the cross there
hey check it out
that's kind of cool it's too big
um
and obviously when I stop it should
disappear
uh it's child
I actually restart Visual Studio because
the intellisense has stopped working a
while ago and it's saying that a lot of
this stuff is
just that
and that's too far well the enemy size
might change but
that's probably too
so let's wait for a few enemies to spawn
and there's no limit at the moment
but you can see it's gonna go between
these two
yeah and if that
it'd be good if I could make it not uh
clip ever
but I can't really do that wait maybe I
can just no that requires a different
pipeline though it's gonna say if I just
render it with depth testing off
and then of course that would work
that's not that easy to do
yeah we need a lot of different material
parameters like depth testing and stuff
that'd be good so let's make this like
let's make it like one
okay
so uh we can basically be like
like it can depend on the gun Maybe
five meters is too much isn't it
wait is that really five meters
that should be more than five meters
okay well there we go now this time it
didn't
wait oh because there's someone closer
man they're quick
like look that's why is that still there
I don't think that's right
what the heck is the distance
oh look it's printing it
4.4 fire
the heck
why is it that that seems very wrong
because those tiles are two meters
actually so what
ah
wait
that doesn't make sense
what the heck
what have I done wrong
so if it finds an enemy
I'm gonna do origin it's gonna do the
distance between
that and that right
yeah I wish there's a square root and
everything
it's not like I paid a special word
um
ah it's always visible
oh I see
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay yep thanks
so we can do that
no but the distance was wrong I don't
know it doesn't stop being printed
so there we go that's more like it
that's probably too close though
maybe like
10 but again sniper rifle can have more
range
and this doesn't mean you can't fire the
gun it just means it's not gonna lock on
that's probably good
if we could draw this as a billboard as
well
that might be better
um
what would be the simplest way to do
that probably just Orient it towards the
player right
what was the camera rather
um
do we have the camera here camera rig
yeah we do
um
oh man how do we do that I've done that
before as well I just don't think
there's a function for it
yeah I don't I forget where I did that
um I think we have to do like set
rotation Maybe
and then we can
a quaternion yeah I think we could just
do quitarian look rotation
maybe I don't know if that's necessarily
correct though
okay let's restart virtual Studio
I need my Intel sense oh
yeah
my help
um
well I know the forward Vector I don't
really know the up Vector that would
just be
somewhat crossed maybe well it no it
does that here though
it'd be good if we could just make it
Point towards an entity really easily
but I don't know if we can
so forward is just going to be
uh
I think I'm a rig
maybe it's not camera rig maybe it's
camera
maybe this isn't worth doing
uh or actually
how about this uh I can get the child
from the camera
then I can get the transform then I can
get the world transformed then I can get
the forward vector and negate that
and I guess I could do the same with the
up Vector
but that wouldn't be negated that would
be probably reflected
I don't think this will work but
oh that's that's actually I think that's
working I think it just needs to be
rotated
yep
huh I did it
that was nice
so now it just points now I just like if
you tilt or whatever it will
kind of tilt towards you I don't know if
that was worth it but I did it all right
um and now obviously if you want to
shoot towards the guy
then it would just be uh the closest
enemies translation so the targeting so
[Music]
um
Vector three so there is there is a
shoot Direction
it's at the moment it's this so
OT Direction
uh equals Vector 3.0
um
so it's forward
I guess it would be
uh would it just be
I guess it would just be
not even our Ford but just in the
direction of the enemy that's the thing
we kind of need to make sure the gun
maybe points in the right direction and
we can easily make that happen as well
but um for now we'll just make sure the
bullet works so that whatever and so
we'll do that by
um probably doing closest uh translation
I'll just avoid getting it twice though
um so we'll do that minus I guess our
translation which I do keep getting but
whatever
um and then
uh this is a bit dumb but
uh if it's zero
we'll do that otherwise we'll use
shoot Direction
uh and then I think what I kind of want
to do is just be like debug around draw
a line
uh I'll make it magenta probably
from origin to
Direction
uh origin to origin
plus Direction times ten
and we'll make a new Vector four I'll
make it like magenta
uh that's only if I fire and that's only
if I have okay
um let's not do that I mean I can do
that
but I just want to do it up here
um origin origin origin origin is this
directions shoot Direction
okay sweet
so now it should well I mean that works
it's arbitrarily 10 meters but
that definitely works
kind of cool
[Music]
okay
yeah so that's good
um I guess I can I'll leave that in the
uh
so now we should probably try and pick
up a gun
maybe I should move slower as well
actually because I can Sprint right
um but if I'm
is there
where's my aim down sight thing what did
I call it
uh it's targeting
maybe half so if you're sprinting you're
still going faster
but this way it's like
really kind of slow maybe not that slow
maybe like seven five
okay all right sweet so let's try and
find the gun
there's a gun here right
I don't think there is
and I wanted to
get out I don't know why that's on an
angle that's a bit weird
um
moving sporadically doesn't actually do
anything either that's okay though
um
can I get a gun from here I guess not
there's no pop-up
so how do I
survive
um let's maybe go to the tent and place
a gun
be nice if they randomly spawned as well
what am I looking for 10 prefab prepared
tent
so this has a coffee here let's make a
let's place a gun maybe I don't know
what kind of gun
not a shotgun let's go with the assault
rifle first
what does that say so rifle pickup I
guess that's what I want right
good to pick up
oh my gosh what did that add man
gun
uh-huh
no whoops
why they're too tense
what the heck
okay this is the Imposter tent
that's weird
ah that did not work what oh did I not
parent it to the tent
I didn't that's funny
um
gun intent please
not quite ah because the Y changes right
no maybe that's I don't know if that's
why okay now I have a gun
and I can shoot you suckers
Aimbot this is just a name bot
but it doesn't seem to help because but
why does the gun not uh or is the Box
collider just does it have a box
collider that's just weird or something
let me look at the color it is
yeah it's got a collider that's way too
big for it that's why uh but I think
it's supposed to because it's a pickup
okay well that makes me feel better um
but
the enemies take way too much to kill I
think
because look I can't even kill them and
I'm I think I'm already out of ammo I
can't really see the ammo because it's
here
yeah the ammo needs to be reworked a bit
I don't know why it's I changed the
field to view the camera and stuff I
think that's why
um
but I want to massively increase the
damage
is there a damage here deal damage
how much damage Man enemy on shot damage
damage take damage damage damage damage
gun damage five five grow
I don't know if that's gonna be set
somewhere else surely or are we just
flat five for now
give me the coffee give me the gun
I'm ready to go guys let me just aimport
you they're not dying
is that because the raycasts are lame
it might be
laughs
do the guns not have like surely the
guns would have like you'd think the
guns would have the ammo the uh damage
on them so it wouldn't be flat 50 like
that maybe that's why so if I go to the
tent again
and I click on the gun and I look at the
damage that it totally doesn't have
oh that's a gun item actually so that
gives us a gun that gives us the assault
rifle prefab so let's look at the
assault rifle prefab
here it is
this is the assault rifle prefab
uh
uh also no damage
but the assault rifle prefab has like
the same thing as
yeah no is this really it
assault rifle that's pickup oh I must
have done that again here it is oh
damage five so let's up that to 50.
well where is it
yeah it's nice to have that tab thing
okay
well I did kill them pretty quickly oh a
sniper rifle don't mind if I do
um actually I do mine because that's
probably not gonna work very well what's
this a shotgun
this is sick this is actually becoming
fun I'm kind of Happy
Tim you should check out my Aimbot
so basically oh so I've done so so much
stuff the field of view changes slightly
when you do this you can aim with right
click
um so let's pick up the gun and the
coffee so basically what happens is you
can Target enemies right so it's going
to Target the closest one with an
arrange and when you shoot it's gonna
shoot at them so and I made it very high
damage for now but you can see it's like
insta kill
so that should kill him yeah
um I think the raycasts need a little
bit the target I was aiming over there
yeah at the moment the gun's not doesn't
point there but I'll make it point and
it yeah I guess I'm on 50 damage not
and that might be a
no that's not assault rifle that
probably should have killed him I just
have a feeling Peter was saying that
some of the raycasts are a bit lame so I
have a feeling that if it's not working
it's because of that
also that
pink line
should be only from from me
two can play this game yeah apparently I
I'm the one again this is a really nice
time oh okay and also I did this by the
way I made the game work so if you hit
tab it shows you where the coffee is
because that's the most important thing
so if I grab the coffee
it shows me where to take the coffee but
then if I drop the coffee it's like nah
man you gotta pick up the coffee so you
go back you get the coffee and then it
tells you where to go
and then you go with the coffee and your
assault rifle as you do all the way to
and then you can Sprint as you can see
two the General's tent
which also has an identical cup of
coffee and an assault rifle because it's
the same prefab but there you go that's
the game Loop done and of course you can
just unload on these guys although that
did nothing yeah I don't know assault
rifle just does zero no no I made it to
50. you used to do five yeah
I I don't know I I think there's a lot
that needs to be done in terms of
raycasts
um like as in they just don't seem to be
accurate at all
but it should be okay because that pink
line as I said that should actually be
you know
but it's not showing me a pink line
right now which it should be
oh no I removed that it only doesn't
want to shoot yeah see it killed them
see that's good
I'm out of ammo unfortunately
oh yeah I do have two
I must have shot them one Sage
how much health did that I guess when I
oh hello
upside down
oh yeah because sometimes it flips
outside the flashlight goes backwards
can you see these parkour did you see
that parkour
he just went I think you'll see it here
in a minute
that's like that was like a Jedi jump
that's I was sick
yeah grenades could be cool but not not
enough time we got physics for it I mean
that explosion function that you can
call yeah that's true
all right
uh I think they turn about half an hour
cool you're gonna take a nap cool
yeah attempt slept for like one hour
today so
all right
um so yeah a little bit weird with the
yeah I'd like I guess I'd like the gun
to point towards who I'm targeting
um
although it's a bit weird and also it's
a bit weird that I can just shoot
someone
oh that's right the major weird thing as
well at the moment is that it's
the angle it doesn't care about the
angle
so I need to care about the angle
because if the angle is too high then
the saws
um
so
how we're going to deal with that
what's the best quickest way
to to do that
so there should be like a
um
foreign
[Music]
so basically I guess like the thing is
the player has a forward Vector right
so it's basically going to be like
um where am I
so this fine closest enemy function
the player is going to have a uh
forward Vector so we have a forward
vector
and then I guess this is easy because
we're gonna get like our we're going to
potentially reject these things because
we're gonna we do figure out
um the distance so this distance this is
just a float but if we subtract the two
vectors we get a vector from this is the
player so we have a forward Vector which
is where we're looking and then we have
another Vector that's going to be
you know basically from us to the
closest enemy and I guess if that angle
uh if the angle between these two
vectors
is greater than a certain amount that we
allow
which could be like 30 degrees or I mean
30 degrees is I guess quiet I don't know
30 degrees isn't much 30 degrees each
way I meant so 60 degrees that's no
that's not much should be probably like
100 degrees or something
100 apparently 100 degrees I think maybe
but anyways that's 50 either side or 60
at the side oh whatever
um
then that's fine so
do we have anything here that can do
that for us
um
I guess so well we can just use the dot
product though
yeah I guess we should do that
so let's grab find the closest anime
let's grab the forward Direction
so this is where we're aiming
and the max angle like we could just say
like it has to be positive even because
if it's positive that's going to make it
90 degrees if we just use a DOT product
um
so let's just do zero I know that
doesn't really make sense Max angle zero
but whatever
um okay so what that means is that we're
gonna basically
get a vector from
[Music]
our origin so we'll get a vector
pointing towards no we want a vector
pointing towards there
so we'll do that
uh to anime
and then F2 enemy
uh is
uh
uh no we'll do
I guess we'll can do origin Dot
doesn't really matter what order
dots to enemy let's turn our origin
forward vector
uh greater than Max angle
um no sorry we'll do Min angle
no we'll do
we'll call it dot angle I'll be special
and if it's less than that we'll
continue because that's not a candidate
um I guess this would be cheaper to
check though so we could check but then
we need the distance we could check this
first
maybe that would make more sense
that might be a static aesthetic guy
okay so that should be okay now maybe
so that should be within 90 degrees
I don't know if that's gonna work
no it's not gonna work
what'd I do wrong
are the Heights
you're right I don't want to do the
height but why
um
[Music]
uh does what
Vector 2 doesn't have Dot
um I guess not
no it's still not working though why
ah they need to be normalized
well actually this one should be but
this one isn't
I guess it would be better to normalize
the other one though wouldn't
it yeah like as in uh if I do XZ XZ
then this is a two-dimensional Vector
now
and then I can normalize it
maybe that would be better
still lame
still apparently not working
what's wrong with that huh
Ford Vector should already be normalized
we're just doing XZ so we're getting
that vector
so that's a two-dimensional kind of oh
but that probably needs to be normalized
as a vector
I imagine
um
probably
because that's going to change it
yeah uh
what the heck it's it's weird because
it's like
unless the forward Vector is wrong but
it shouldn't be we can actually test it
though
um if I just do debug
draw a line we can just be like hey my
weird vect two forward Vector thing
um
let's draw something from
the X and the Z oh but that's anomaly oh
that's okay so we'll go from the
player's origin
uh player origin 2 forward
so origen plus forward dot X
uh zero
four dots y times ten
and let's do
um
color
let's do green
okay it's the exact back of us
that's not bad that just means we need
to negate that why though why would the
forward vector be back that's bad news
for other things potentially what the
heck why is this
backwards
okay well there we go so now does this
work
oh but it's not the camera it's not
where we're looking it's where we're
facing
which in a way makes sense because if
I'm that way but I aim that way I don't
want that's not real I need to be
actually aiming at them like this
so that makes that's actually makes
sense so that does work
as you can see
all right so wait let's find our assault
rifle and take out these suckers
wow look at that they got wrecked
and I'm out of ammo
if I can pick up their guns too bad to
really suck
and I was gonna say the guns suck but
they don't give me another gun
I would love to know how much yeah so I
don't know if the shotgun
all the guns really should work
um but yeah there should be a range
probably
it's kind of fun like I was in the game
I like it
gonna have a break in about
25 minutes though
to get some pizza and also just have a
break
but I'm happy with where this is going
because the game Loop's kind of there um
the enemies though I haven't really
watched on the anime so I'll have to do
that next
or at some point but the targeting
system I think is cool I'm concerned
about the different guns as well so
assault rifle
um
then we should have shotgun
okay so I think this is probably like I
probably
made it a little high the damage let's
make it like 30.
then we have the shotgun
so let's make that
maybe do
40 but it'll have a much slower much
smaller range which I need to enforce
and it's supposed to have like a an
actual range but it does several
raycasts I think that's how it works
which is good luckily bullets are
basically raised
so it works out well and then the sniper
rifle so the sniper rifle
needs to
[Music]
um
the prefab
the sniper rifle needs to basically do
well we can do 80 damage
or should we just do a hundred
damage I don't even know how much health
they have
but the real big the real interesting
thing about this is again the range or
at least the range of aiming
and it has to be the concept of accuracy
like there's a lot of things that I'd
like to add
something
okay that's a sniper rifle
and they're not dying
I'm out of ammo already
no it looks like I'm shooting them that
just was difficult for some reason
and the
I don't I love to see the oh that was a
one shot kill it looks like
is there a cooldown maybe that I'm not
saying
okay I can get rid of that stupid green
uh debug line
which I don't even know what that is
here it is
love to be able to fight them
like because then fist fight them
okay so what do I have this is an
assault rifle right
the lion rendering super weird
like it looks like it's in the ground
see that why didn't that kill them
oh they're doing the thing where they
fly again
and yeah the I think the bloom is weird
unfortunately
that's why the muscle flashes look weird
I really wonder what went wrong with the
bloom
um what could it have been
uh what did I change in the engine
especially in the renderer
I mean I did play with this
well since this I'm pretty sure this
does nothing
what I could do just to see if this
fixes it quickly is just stash those
changes
right if I let's just let's grab this
stash
I'll do 53 transparent wait
and then let's see if this fixes it at
all
oh I think that wait did that fix it
No it didn't
what the heck happened to my bloom
yeah look it doesn't
it doesn't glow
what could have happened
this doesn't make any sense
but also I feel like I've seen this
before somehow
does it work in the run time
so if I just uh build this asset pack
real quick I won't build a Shader Park
but what the heck happened that's fine
okay that's done
that is bizarre man
I guess I can't really tell if it's
gonna work in the
well actually it just kind of looks like
it's not compositing it
yeah that's wrong I think
because it's not glowing
yeah it kind of looks like it's the
compositing that's wrong oh that's not
working somehow
but my I don't have any changes to the
compositing Shader
I don't think that was the only Shadow
change
that's so weird
no it's nothing to do with transparent
stuff because I just reverted all those
changes
I'm one of this disable fog I don't
think that has anything to do with it
though
hmm
looks like it does somehow
but that was working before wasn't it
what the heck
wasn't it working before
huh
so the fog reduces
yeah it is the compositing The Fog
reduce is the amount of Bloom
and I guess it's just doing it's
reducing it by too much
well I don't think
I guess I can play with it but
yeah it's a bit weird isn't it
because
um no no
like that doesn't do anything so it
looks like any amount kind of reduces it
so it does a smooth step between
ah because it uses the fall off
from here
I think that's why because this is kind
of harsh
probably
can we just what if we don't touch bloom
but that's going to be bad because
stuff's going to be very visible from
like this from far away
and like it might be nice on one hand
because like you'll see that fog light
fog light thing
but it also means that
Snowy Peaks will be visible because
they're a bit of massive see but that's
kind of nice it's just it's bad because
you'll see it loading in like that
that's what I wanted to avoid
but I just think that it needs to be a
different ramp really
um
but it's supposed to be so much more
permissive here
and yet it ruins it
but that doesn't make sense because it's
doing one minus
basically 50.
what why would I do what
that doesn't make sense this is just
resulting in a very very negative number
see colors being mixed but this is being
like just flat out multiplied by one
minus that
which I don't think is good
and Bloom gets added on
so I guess it's fine for it to go
towards zero
so it should just go towards zero really
um
no no but actually no I guess it should
go towards one
um
and it should start oh but there's also
Bloom clamped and intensity and that
contributes to this ah because there was
this whole thing man this is gonna break
a lot of stuff I think
uh
that's weird thrown away
um but I was going to say that you could
just make it
I don't know if that's good to do
I don't know what I wanted to look like
but that's still weird the way that it's
currently working
kind of almost remember that from forest
though
but yeah the problem is it's just too
much
um
because this is such a like a different
value man
that sucks
one minus plume
yeah I almost just don't want to do that
I guess that might be better
even though it's gonna make it's gonna
be weird for the
yeah but actually hang on let's do this
I think I can just do it quickly
let's just do a loop
um based on the app
but hang on that's linear depth
maybe that's bad as well
that kind of sucks yeah
I think that's not gonna work
that's why it was like that okay that
makes sense
these are the two edges and then that's
the
thing we're interpolating
yeah okay I know that actually makes
sense never mind
so then why doesn't that work
I think it's because I'm not clamping it
um
I think if I just did
uh
that
no
but it's clearly I I just think it's
clearly negative
uh uh and I am inverting it
if I don't invert it
kind of weird
so yeah it's it's like I get the
opposite
which is super annoying
but what's weird is I can see the glow
on the geometry just not
the back and the reason why is because
the depth value here is obviously much
smaller than here
and it's obviously using the depth to
determine what should be oh that that
would explain why
of course because the bloom there's no
geometry behind it ah
so therefore the value in the death of
is infinite
and you can't really do that because
that's a glow
because how do I determine if the glow
is not supposed to be there if I'm not
actually if I don't know the depth of
the glow
aha
all right so let's not do that I think
is the solution basically
it's a shame but I think it's okay well
we'll see what everyone else says but
um
yeah because it's gonna look kind of bad
for snowy levels but maybe but I could
always reduce the emission or make it
not emissive and that would fix it
but it's in a way it's nice because I
feel like we'd see
we would see in the snow
all right sorry we would see the um
and now Bloom kind of works which is
cool but we would see
um
in the distance where the tent is
but I guess we don't need to because we
have the arrow
so it's not really a big deal
but basically this thing
would be visible so even if we're far
away
in the fog we can't really tilt the
camera more but yeah you can see it
there see that red light
I'll take a little thing there it is we
can see that even though we can't see
anything else
um so it's kind of nice
okay now that's back that looks stupid
though that muzzle flash
um now this ammo text what's that
actually parented to
because that should be parented to the
camera
oh but the camera filter view changes
which makes stuff very difficult I think
unless we have something else but I
didn't really want to display the ammo
um I think that's lame let's blame the
ammo apart from for debugging
foreign
hello
yeah so we're kind of not bad I think
now
um
like we need to tweak the guns and stuff
but we can aim
at enemies I don't like the fact that
yeah sometimes the aiming's a bit
doesn't really quite work I think
which is a bit weird
but that just could be like we might
just be hitting stuff it'd be nice to
see what we hit though
because see that's not working
and I don't know why
so if you were like clearly hitting
something anyway it'd be nice to but we
can technically know what we're hitting
like
um like I can just
because when we shoot right
whatever we hit so gun dot shoot
there's all Peter's stuff
what happens when we hit something so
deal damage sure So that obviously only
happens if we
if we do hit
but
no here it is Sam
wait but what happens here if this is
null what the heck physics costs Ray
why are we doing this
shouldn't we check to see if that hits
anything
or is it just gonna be this is a struct
right well
this might just be null oh so that's
what we do here we check to see if
that's anything
um we do spawn blood particles at the
place
uh but I just I just got rid of them I
think
so everything should bleed so that might
be nice because if I do shoot I'll know
what I hit
wow
I'm not shooting though am I
damn
oh my coffee's being spilled
don't really like the particles how they
spawn and stuff but also I think I might
just make them not uh they Collide and
stuff now but that might be a little bit
bad for performance so maybe I'll make
them
not to be like that
but still they're all individual
entities which kind of sucks I really
need a part we really need a particle
system I think in Hazel like a problem
yeah I was gonna make the movement
itself spill coffee
probably should still do that
so I rigid body at faucet location if
it's not null and if we hit an entity
but we also know the hit position so
we spawned this particle at
entity.translation Plus
uh
Direction times 0.5
maybe if it's an enemy we should do this
but otherwise I feel like
let's make them last like two seconds
but also like um
foreign
if it's going to be blood like that then
yeah it should catch that's what should
happen I guess if you if the entity
itself is uh an enemy right so I guess
we could check that
or if it has a rigid body well no they
all have rigid bodies actually
oh but this might not well because at
runtime they do so they're actually they
might not always
oh I hear it well no well yeah so you
can do yeah so we could do basically if
let's do this
if entity is
anime
then let's do this
so I should only see blood from enemies
now
I think I say I do I guess
[Music]
um
else I might want to just uh
just have some Sparks or something I
don't know some dust basically
um
I'll call it dust particle Maybe
it should be Sparks
sure
um
and we can do minus Direction and minus
Direction so it's like you know a
Ricochet kind of thing although we
should probably reflect it
but I'm not gonna do that because for
that you need to know the incoming angle
as well right
well now you're doing it the direction
is the incoming angle you need to know
the normal of the surface but I'm not
going to bother with that so we'll just
do that um
yeah uh and the Sparks particle
um
is going to
so I'll basically make this like where's
this Blood particle
okay so let's make
it's called a Sparks particle
um I don't want it yeah Dynamic version
but well
uh because it's physics so they have to
kind of have to be physics based in a
way all right whatever
restitution will make kind of high
frictional make low
they're gonna last like two seconds
um
materials
oh man all of the
yeah I don't think I want to do it this
way
um
let's put this sure blood particles
already set up that way but if we
actually go to the particle system we
can give it
like you know this and then we can be
like uh spawn
box
and for now we'll just do this
uh
oh that is so static does it
yeah I guess that's a bit annoying
well we didn't have to make this
aesthetic class it just makes it easier
okay fine
that's annoying there
because it's annoying because I have to
go to every single gun now
like
this
and I have to add
this box particle
that's the pickup
all right
so let's see if this works
see man like that's what it thinks it's
hitting
why why are you okay apparently hitting
that this is really good actually
because it lets me debug this because
Peter said the raycasts are weird
and I can kind of see that because now I
know what I'm actually hitting
and right now it's supposed to be
oh there's random rotation oh that's
probably too much
okay let's not make it random
maybe Peter went way too random
I'm gonna pick up the gun
but see that's still weird I'm supposed
to be hitting that what the red Line's
looking at and yet this box is spawning
in other places right
let's make them smaller
that's super not good though
ah but they're also shooting actually
okay let's not spawn our enemies we
don't need them for now
what the heck so it's just not spawning
them at all
so what does that mean I'm not hitting
anything
what the heck
no it's just not I'm not
if it's not an enemy it should be doing
this yeah
The Entity is what I hit
him oh
um
so I did hit something
apparently
but I don't see my particles
that's false
that's true oh look I see something
look that kind of works but also I I
think that that pink line seems to be
what I hit
but I'm not seeing the particles here
I mean this looks like a kind of wax
this is so weird
where am I supposedly spawning them I'm
supposed to be spawning them where they
get like the hit position right
and that's in that's the world's face
oh no I'm not
oh my gosh what am I doing man
I'm doing entity translation oh it's the
hit
ah well
yeah that's a bit weird how about we
just do
I guess I meant I mean Andrew's
translation it means the origin of the
entity
so let's do hit position and then we'll
the direction of the force will also be
minus Direction so maybe this is what I
meant
maybe things are working fine
let's try and shoot the
tent yeah okay
and it's where the pink thing is now why
is it where the pink thing is
we must be sending out array kind of
into the wrong place
because shoot
the shoot direction right
is what it's the world transform forward
which of the player though right oh and
this is enemy doing it but
yeah origin is
um translation plus Direction
uh
um wait but shouldn't it be huge
Direction
uh that's what direction is uh so that
yeah so the direction and there's my
pink line so the direction oh but
because I'm not targeting at the moment
[Music]
origin I just don't think origin should
be this
I think the origin should be my gun
doesn't that make sense
but actually I don't know if the guns
like
the rifle the assault rifle
sniper rifle shot sniper rifle like
where is its origin in the middle right
so it's not it should be the The Gun
Barrel I guess is what it's called so
if I look over here as Oregon Barrel
yeah so the Gun Barrel
looks like that's just a locator thing
do the guns know where where their
barrels are
or do I have to find that
I think I have to find that
and that makes it pretty much impossible
because I would say that it'd be nice to
just get the gun barrel
and then you can just you know
like it'll be from there basically
but that being said that's because I'm
not targeting at the moment because
there are no enemies but if I go to
enemy
manager and I turn this on
we'll get some enemies spawning
now I should hopefully
so you can see that I'm missing them
because there's Terrain in the way
but they should bleed I think
yeah there's some blood these are the
blood particles
and I can also go into me
I don't know if I'll keep this box or a
bit weird I mean it'd be good if it was
green for example for this I could make
them yeah be what it what gets hit
that'd be kind of cool actually we need
a lot of different particles for that
but that's that's fine I think
um
I was gonna make my ammo I was gonna
make me have more ammo yeah here we go
just annihilate all these people huh
you want some of this
Get Wrecked
easy
but yes I could make it that okay guys
I'm gonna
um have like a break and have some
dinner and stuff
so I will be up I'll be back soon but
I'll probably end the Stream
because we can only have like if the
streams longer than 12 hours it gets cut
off on YouTube so
like it's in the VOD won't quite work
so I'm going to
I'm going to
and like pause the Stream
so
another two hour dinner no um yesterday
wasn't just dinner I had to go home
um but uh no this will probably be like
an hour break I think but I also want to
have a break so it's not just purely
eating all right we'll see you guys soon
goodbye
[Music]